THOSE THAT ARE.
ENTERING THIS BEAUTIFUL CITY
HALL.
TO INTO THE ROOM AND FIND A SEAT
AND COME FORWARD.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE BACK.
THERE ARE TRANSLATION SERVICES
AVAILABLE TODAY SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOMEONE WHO COMES UP TO
THE MIKE. TO SAY THAT.
SO LET'S GET STARTED THERE.
ALL THAT -- ONE BUT NOT POSSIBLE.
TESTING.
WE WENT TO CS AT THE LOW C. I'M
GONNA SEE THAT THE LOOKS ON AN
ESPANYOL THE NAME WAS HE
SUPPOSEDLY WAS HE'S FUNNY BLISS.
HOST OF WHAT OTHER LESS SPORT
THAT'S AWESOME I KNOW THAT IT
JEFF.
IBM MANY LIVES.
YOUR FRIENDS ARE HERE LET THIS
ITEM CAN -- GATES.
MIKE CHAT THEY ACHE WITH THE
CORNER I'M OUT DHARMA NOT BUT
JANET THE NECK OKAY WE HAVE ONE
WITH HIM.
THANK YOU.
NOW TELLTALE -- TODAY ONLY CAN
LISTED THERE BUT THIS IS A
PATHETIC LAST SAW I LOVE THAT H.
WOULD SAY YOU ARE NEVER ALONE
FUNDED BOOK ONE BUT A ONE WAY.
I'VE BEEN A CLINICIAN A LOVE
SCHEDULE.
HEY WHAT THE SHE TURNED ON IT'S
GOING TO SHE'S NOT THAT GOOD
STUFF.
THIS IS WHAT CALIFORNIA LOOKS
LIKE WAS THAT AMAZING THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND YOU HAVE FOUR OR
FIVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
TRANSLATE THAT MAKES ME VERY
PROUD TO BE A CALIFORNIAN.
GOOD MORNING FRESNO.
I'M STATE SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL --
I AM PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT THE
THIRTIETH SENATE DISTRICT.
A LITTLE FURTHER SOUTH FROM HERE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ON AND I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
CHAIRING THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF CHILDREN'S WELL
BEING WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
SENATOR MITCHELL THAT IS A FANCY
WAY OF SAYING.
WE KNOW THERE ARE CONDITIONS
THAT LEAD TO POVERTY.
AND WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACT THOSE CONDITIONS HAVE ON
A CHILD'S ABILITY TO BE WELL.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
STUDYING AND TALKING ABOUT US
POLICY MAKERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE --
FOR OUR SECOND HEARING IN THE
CITY OF FRESNO IT'S AN HONOR FOR
US TO BE HERE AT CITY HALL TODAY
WITH ALL OF YOU TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES AND WORK
BEING DONE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN CAN DRIVE.
OUR HEARING TODAY IS STREAMING
LIVE FOR THOSE OF YOU WATCHING
FROM HOME OR WORK WE WELCOME YOU.
WELL YOU'RE NOT HERE PLEASE KNOW
THAT YOU CAN FIND THE AGENDA THE
BACKGROUND BRIEF AND OTHER
MATERIALS FROM MY PALACE ONLINE
AT THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE
WEBSITE.
AND THAT CHILD WELL BEING.
DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GO I'LL
REPEAT.
CHILD WELL BEING ALL ONE WORD.
DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GO.
WE ALSO INVITE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS WHICH CAN BE SUBMITTED
USING THE CONTACTS ON THE
WEBSITE. FOR AUDIENCE AND
PADDLES PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS
HEARING IS BEING TRANSLATED LIVE
AS YOU JUST REALIZE SO AS SUCH
WE ALL HAVE TO BE MINDFUL THAT
INCLUDES ME.
ON THAT OUR INTERPRETATION WILL
NEED TO HEAR YOU AND TO
INTERPRET AS WE GO ALONG SO.
TRY TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITIES
TO SPEAK SLOWLY.
THAT'LL BE A CHALLENGE FOR ME.
I WANT TO THANK OUR PARTNERS AT
SIERRA HEALTH FOUNDATION FOR
PROVIDING US WITH THE
INTERPRETERS IT'S REALLY COOL
THAT WE GET.
TO PRACTICE WHAT DEMOCRACY
SHOULD LOOK LIKE I APPRECIATE
THAT.
THIS HEARING ON THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS THE SECOND.
IN A SERIES OF SIX HEARINGS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE WILL BE
HOSTING OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
DON'T LIVE IN OUR WORLD EVERY
DAY.
SELECT COMMITTEE SELECT
COMMITTEES ARE DIFFERENT FROM A
STANDING POLICY COMMITTEE.
IN THAT WEIRD DON'T TAKE
ACTUALLY WILL BE VOTED ON THE
BILL OR BUDGET TODAY.
OUR WORK IS INFORMATIONAL IN
NATURE -- IT'S OUR WAY
VERTICALLY DURING DOWNTIME LIKE
THIS WE'RE IN OUR SUMMER
RESOURCE WE CAN GO TO
COMMUNITIES AND HAVE A DEEPER
DIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT A POLICY
ISSUE.
THIS IS OUR WAY OF HEARING FROM
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
LEARNING SO WHEN WE DO GO BACK
IN THE FALL AND WE HAVE POLICY
COMMITTEES WERE WERE TAKEN
ACTION ON BILLS WEEKEND THIS.
WHAT WE LEARNED IN GLEANED FROM
YOU ALL CAN HELP INFORM OUR
OVERALL DECISION MAKING PROCESS
EITHER ON VOTED ON BILLS ARE
DEVELOPING POLICY OUR SALES?
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE'S WORK IS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME I'M AT ITS
CORE IT'S WHO I AM AND AND AND
HE'S REALLY KIND OF GOVERNMENT
I. CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
THE WORKERS ALSO TIMELY IT'S
CRITICALLY NECESSARY AND CALLS
FOR IN LIGHT OF OUR EXPANDING
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND THE NEED TO
FOCUS ON PREVENTION.
AND NOT JUST TREATMENT.
AND THE NEED FOR US TO FOCUS ON
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
HAS ACCESS TO CRITICAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND THAT'S MY
COMMITMENT AND THE COMMITMENT
SHARED BY MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE PANEL.
I PLAN TO SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS TO TRAVEL TO
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
WERE ISSUES LIKE POVERTY ACCESS
TO SERVICES NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
NEGATIVE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
AND CHILDREN'S WELL BEING ARE
HINDERED BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS.
ALL OF OUR COMMITTEES FACE.
THESE HEARINGS -- A REALLY
IMPORTANT AGAIN TO OUR POLICY
MAKING PROCESS OUR FIRST HEARING
THIS IS OUR SECOND WAS IN MARCH
TWO TOOK PLACE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND WE FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
AND ITS IMPACT ON A CHILD'S
ABILITY TO BE WELL.
OUR NEXT HEARING WILL BE IN
OCTOBER IT WILL BE HELD AT MY
HOME DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES --
WHERE THE POVERTY RATE IS ALSO
HIGH -- AND WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT RACE AND CLASS DIFFERENCES.
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT RACE
CLASS AND IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
HOW THAT HAS AN IMPACT.
ON A CHILD'S ABILITY TO BE WELL
AND THRIVE.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON I WANT TO
THANK STAFF COMMUNITY PARTNERS
WHO WORK HARD TO HELP US PUT
THIS HEARING TOGETHER THESE
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN JUST
OVERNIGHT WE MAY HAVE THE BRIGHT
IDEA.
BUT IT TAKES ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
YOU'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH ONE
VIDAK YOU WERE AT THE TABLE.
THE ENTIRE SENATE FAMILY OF
STAFF -- THOSE WHO ARE
TELEVISING OUR SERGEANT.
COMMITTEE STAFF SENATOR TITLE
STAFF MY STAFF WHO WORK TOGETHER
SEAMLESSLY TO HELP PULL TOGETHER
TODAY'S AGENDA -- AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I AM THRILLED I GOTTA TELL YOU
I'VE THIS IS THE SECOND SELECT
COMMITTEE THIRD I GUESS -- THAT
I'VE -- CONVENED.
SINCE I WAS FIRST ELECTED AND
YOU CAN'T ALWAYS GET MEMBERS TO
SHOW UP TO SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS OVER THIS BE IN OUR
FIRST MONDAY IN FRESNO OF OUR
SUMMER RECESS.
AND WE HAVE A DAY IS FULL OF
PEOPLE ON THE TIP MY HAT TO MY
COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE.
THEM ALL SHOWING UP AND THEY
WILL ALL -- HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE YOU -- GREETINGS.
AGAIN I WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK --
BY ONE OF MY NEWEST COLLEAGUES
IN THE SENATE SENATOR HER TATTOO
ON HER STAFF FOR BEING SO
GRACIOUS AND HELPING US FIND THE
LOCATION -- AND TO WELCOME US
HERE TO THE CITY OF FRESNO.
CENTER TARA YOU WANNA GIVE
OPENING REMARKS OR SHALL WE
INVITE THE COUNCILMAN UP TO
WELCOME US FIRST HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO DO IT.
OKAY SENATE TO RETIRE HER TITLE
PLEASE OPENING REMARKS.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE -- I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
I IN TAKING SOME TIME OUT OF
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO JOIN US
FOR THIS HEARING.
I WANT TO GIVE A BIG WELCOME AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE --
THAT YOU KNOW MADE.
THE COMMITMENT TO TO CHAMPION
ISSUES HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND TOOK THE TIME TO COME
AND AND AND DRIVE DOWN HERE TO
BE WITH US ALL TODAY.
BUT I SPECIAL WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO TAKE CASH
ACTION ON ISSUES THAT.
ARE SEVERELY IMPACTS THAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
I KNOW JUST LAST WEEK I
ANNOUNCER GREEN INVESTMENTS ARE
TOTALLY ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE GENERAL
FUNDS WHICH INCLUDES ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
ASTHMA PREVENTION A DEFENSE
AGAINST FAMILY SEPARATION.
AGING AND DISABILITY CENTERS AND
A WHOLE LOT MORE FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND SENATOR MITCHELL HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN FIGHTING
FOR POLICIES THAT.
NOT ONLY HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA BUT HOPES UP LIFT
COMMUNITIES HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE US.
A SENATOR GALGIANI WHO HAS BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE MENTOR TO ME AND
HAS PROVIDED ME WITH GUIDANCE
AND HAS BEEN AN AMAZING LEADER
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN HER
TERM IN THE SENATE.
AND OF COURSE I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE RECOGNITION TO SENATOR
RUBIO -- HERE TODAY SHE HAS BEEN
SO SUPPORTIVE OF SENATE DISTRICT
FOURTEEN AND ANY TIME WERE IN A
MEETING OR DISCUSSING POLICY.
HER FIRST QUESTION TO BE AS
ALWAYS HOW WILL THIS IMPACT THE
VALLEY.
SO C. MY COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY
IN MY HOME REGION MEANS THE
WORLD TO ME AS I'M SURE DOES TO
ALL OF YOU SO I WANT.
TO ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO IN A
REALLY ASK QUESTIONS AND AND
THERE IS NO RIGHT OR WRONG
ANSWER.
WE WANT TO KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
YOU KNOW AND I ESPECIALLY WANT
TO GIVE ONCE AGAIN A THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE
TODAY.
IT IS AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU ALL
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THREE
MEMBER AROUND THE DOCTOR AROUND
A LITTLE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
IN THE OPENING REMARKS.
WELL I WOULD.
IF I CAN I'D LIKE TO START IN
SPANISH THAT'S YOU'LL GET ALL
THIS IT GRASS US SOME SOME OF
THE WHAT MITCHELL OKAY STONE
IMPORT DANTE QUE LOS HALF IS
THEM STYLO YOU'D BUT OLD PRO
PARK THIS THEY LIST THE OTHER
WELL KNOWN THEY I. IN WHICH THE
SCHOOL.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PARTS OF OUR
STATE THAT OFTENTIMES DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE GET HURT.
THAT YOU DRAW ATTENTION AND COME
TO THIS AREA SENATOR MITCHELL
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK.
NOW FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WATCHING OUT THERE WHAT YOU WILL
SEE IS THAT I ACTUALLY HAVE THIS
ALL THE TIME I'M SURROUNDED BY
SMART WOMEN.
LOOK OUT NOW SO SO YOU'LL SEE.
THAT THIS RATIO ACTUALLY WORKS.
NOW IN THE LATINO CAUCUS WE
ACTUALLY CAME TO A REALIZATION
RECENTLY THAT THERE ARE MORE
LATINOS IN OUR CAUCUS SO WE
RENAMED OUR CAUCUS.
TO IN A CAUCUS TRYING PLEASE TO
BE SURROUNDED BY TWO LATINOS
HERE TODAY.
NOW OUR VALLEY RECENTLY HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SENDING THE
YOUNGEST FEMALE STATE SENATOR
WE'VE EVER ELECTED IN OUR STATE
HISTORY MOST OF HER TADO.
AND SO I WANTED TO THANK THE
CROWD WHO IS HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE IT'S OFTEN TIMES WHAT
YOU DO.
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AROUND THE LITTLE
LOUDER WELL I'M.
I WAS RAISED IN A WAY THAT IF
YOU DON'T SPEAK THAT ALLOWED
PEOPLE AFTER WORK TO LIVE SO
LONG.
YOU KNOW I WAS MOVED AND ALL
JUST IN MY COMMENTS AFTER THIS
IF I CAN.
BUT I WAS MOVED IN THE
DISCUSSION AND THE LITERATURE
THAT COMES TODAY.
ABOUT A MASON DIXON LINE THAT'S
MCKINLEY THAT WAS IDENTIFIED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WELL I LIVE
SOUTH OF THE MASON DIXON LINE I
GREW UP SOUTH OF THE MASON DIXON
LINE AND I WENT TO SCHOOL ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE TRACKS.
HERE IN TOWN.
AND SO I'VE SEEN MY FAIR SHARE
OF STRUGGLE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
AND IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT THE LEADERS OF OUR STATE
ARE HERE.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO WELCOME
YOU AND THANK YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE THE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR THE SENATE.
AND IT IS YOUR ADVOCACY THAT
DRIVES RESOURCES TOWARDS
PROGRAMS LIKE THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAMS.
THAT REALLY START TO DEAL WITH
THE INEQUITIES THAT WE SEE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
ITS PROGRAMS LIKE THE PROMO
TORAS THAT REALLY START TO HELP
TO DEAL WITH CULTURAL
SENSITIVITIES AND ISSUES THAT WE
FACE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IT'S THE IDENTIFICATION THAT
THERE ARE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES
WITH HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE
MEETS.
AND THAT THE RECENT INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE AT A STATE BOTH
HELP WITH LOAN REPAYMENT AS WELL
AS INCREASING RESIDENCY SPOTS
HERE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
AM EXCITED. FOR THE DISCUSSION
THAT COMES FURTHER ALONG.
I AM SO PLEASED.
THAT WE'RE HERE IN THE CITY OF
FRESNO BUT I WOULD JUST ASK.
THAT WE NOT FORGET ARE MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THAT CAN'T EVEN BE PRESENT IN
OUR URBAN CITIES.
AND THAT OFTENTIMES ALSO ARE NOT
HEARD IN THIS DISCUSSION.
BUT THANK YOU FOR COMING
DIFFERENCE.
THE MOBILE. ONE THANK YOU.
CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME AS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE --
AND I REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
CHAIR AND I. NINETY LOOK UP TO
HER MY MENTOR HOLLY MITCHELL AND
I ALWAYS.
ALWAYS JOKE WITH HER I WANT TO
BE HER WHEN I GROW UP -- SHE'S
BEEN AROUND.
WAY LONGER THAN US AND I THINK --
SENATOR OR TOM MYSELF LOOK UP TO
TWO MENTORS LIKE.
OF CATHLEEN GALGIANI AS WELL AS
MITCHELL IN.
MISTER RANDY LARA WHO YOU KNOW.
THE PATH THE PATH FOR US TO BE
ABLE. TO TO BE HERE AND LEARN
FROM THEM AND I THINK THAT OUR
PERSONAL STORIES USUALLY INFORM.
OUR DECISION MAKING AS WELL AND
THIS ISSUE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ME I'M NOT ONLY AS A STATE
SENATOR BUT AS AN EDUCATOR I WAS
A TEACHER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
AND I SAW SO MANY OF OUR KIDS
THAT WERE STRUGGLING.
WITH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ISSUES AND
DYING I RAN INTO SO MANY OF MY
FAMILY'S FOR SLEEPING IN CARS
AND DIDN'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING.
OUR CHILDREN THEY CAME TO SCHOOL
WITH THE SAME CLOTHING AND IT
WAS OBVIOUS AFTER A LITTLE WHILE
AND SO.
ALL THESE THINGS I BROUGHT TO ME
WITH TO THE STATE SENATE IT
REALLY DOES.
HELP INFORM HOW I RECEIVED THE
POLICY -- ON A PERSONAL LEVEL I
HAPPEN TO HAVE BEEN.
THOSE CHILDREN AT ONE POINT IN
MY LIFE I YOU KNOW IT'S I'VE
BEEN VERY OPEN ABOUT MY
BACKGROUND I HAPPEN TO BE
PROBABLY THE ONLY UNDOCUMENTED
DEPORTED STATE SENATOR NOT TO
SERVE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY MY FATHER
WAS ALSO A FARM WORKER AND SO WE
BRING ALL OF THIS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH POLICY.
BUT YET.
GOING DEEPER IN TERMS OF NOT
ONLY LISTENING.
TO WHAT I HAVE TO SAY IN TERMS
OF MY EXPERIENCE BUT THAT OF MY
STUDENTS AND OUT OF ALL OF YOU
SO ALL OF US REALLY COMING
TOGETHER TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING
CARE OF OUR CHILDREN AND LOOKING
INTO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN PARTICULAR.
WHICH I HAPPEN TO TO REPRESENT I
AM ALSO A STATE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
THAT I REPRESENT THE SINGER
VALLEY WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT.
EAST AND SELF THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND TO THE FRESNO CITY
COUNCIL -- TO FOR ALLOWING US TO
TO USE OUR FACILITY -- I WILL
ALSO SAY A FEW WORDS IN SPANISH
IF I BY MAY.
WHEN A STYLIST AT THOSE GLASS
YES FOR THAT OLD LAPTOP WITH ME
THAT IS THAT A KEY CONTROLS THE
STATUS?
GET HIM ALL SET ON IS THE MOST
CONVENIENT DOES A GAY
CALIFORNIA'S WE GET ON DAY THE
NAME WAS NOBODY THAT THE COMPANY
THAT THEY C..
WHO FOUND A LITTLE SPOT I'LL EAT
WHICH HAVE HAVE LESS?
CONNIE CEILING AS A DEFENDANT
BOB THERE'S A CALIFORNIA'S WE
IMPORT ON PICK ON THE SYMBOLS
POLICE HE'S GAY NO SUFFIX HANNAH
TOTALS WHICH HAS GOT US YES YES
BATTLE ABOUT COME CLOSEST TO
THIS PERSON I MEANT THE AND AND
AND AND PUT THE GRASS YES.
THANK YOU SO TO GALGIANI.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND THE TOPIC OF THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AND PARTICULARLY NOW
THE TIMING IS REALLY GOOD
BECAUSE THE STATE.
IS DOING MUCH BETTER THAN WE
HAVE SEEN IN SO MANY YEARS WHEN
I WAS ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SIX I
REPRESENTED PER SE THIRD
TELEVISION AND SOME A PROMISE OF
MONEY FROM THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND WE SAW THAT GROW INTO A
UNIVERSITY THAT EDUCATED
STUDENTS AND WE REALIZE HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS TO HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY IN THEIR BACKYARDS.
SO THAT THEY KNEW SO THAT YOURS
YOUNG PEOPLE HERE IN FRESNO AS
WELL KNEW THAT THAT UNIVERSITY
WAS BUILT FOR THEM AND THAT WE
HAD DREAMS AND EXPECTATIONS.
THAT THEY WOULD DO WELL IN THAT
THEY WOULD DO SUCCESSFUL AND OUR
GOAL AT THAT TIME WAS TO BRING
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE SHE IS C.
MERCED WITH THE IDEA THAT.
THAT THAT SCHOOL WOULD PARTNER
WITH CSU FRESNO AND UC DAVIS
SAID THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE
CURRICULUM THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS AT UC DAVIS.
AND THEN THE STUDENTS WOULD THEN
DO THEIR INTERNSHIPS AND
RESIDENCIES HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND FRESNO MERCED MADERA
COUNTIES.
WHERE THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK
IN OUR HEALTH CLINICS AND
HOSPITALS?
WITH THE IDEA THAT THEY WOULD
THEN STAY HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT FOR YEARS WE HAVE HAD
SHORTAGES.
OF MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS NOT
JUST PHYSICIANS BUT WHEN YOU
START EDUCATING PHYSICIANS YOU
ALSO BRING ALONG NURSES
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS AND ALL OF
THE OTHER HEALTH CARE WORKERS
THAT ARE NEEDED.
SO THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM HERE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE WE SAW THE
ECONOMY DECLINE AND TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT WITH THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE BUT THINGS HAVE
RETURNED TO NORMAL.
WE HAVE SEEN THE STATE IN A MUCH
BETTER STATE THAN WE EVER HAVE
IN THE TIME THAT WE'VE BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO NOW IS THE RIGHT TIME TO
RE FOCUS OUR ENERGIES AGAIN TO
BRINGING THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS HERE.
AND EDUCATING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT ARE RIGHT HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO THAT THEY WILL
BE THE FUTURE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS SO I THINK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND AGAIN THIS IS A
VERY TIMELY AND IMPORTANT TOPIC.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I PROMISE IS NOT GONNA BE
TALKING HEADS APPEAR WE GO WE
REALLY COME HERE TO HEAR YOU.
SO THAT WAS EVERYBODY'S INTRO
ONCE WE GET THE PANELS WILL
ENGAGE IN QUESTIONS BUT THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR FOR MAKING THE
COMMITMENT AND YOUR COMMITMENT --
TO CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
I'D LIKE TO THANK COUNCIL MEMBER
IDEAS -- WHO MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR US TO BE HERE IN THE COUNCIL
CHAMBERS TODAY -- HE WASN'T ABLE
TO BE HERE WITH US -- AND SO IF
COUNCIL MEMBER -- BUT I ALSO
WILL COME FORWARD AND BRING US
GREETINGS AND OFFICIALLY WELCOME
US. TO YOUR HOUSE [INAUDIBLE]
COUNCILMAN.
AREA THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL --
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF FRESNO
AND MY COUNCIL COLLEAGUES I'M
COUNCILMEMBER NELSON AS FAR AS A
I WANT TO WELCOME.
EVERYONE HERE -- THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL -- TO
FRESNO CITY HALL THE SPACE SHIP
YOUR FRESNO.
I WANT TO THANK -- THE
CHAIRWOMAN CENTER HOLLY MITCHELL --
FOR RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR
SUCH COMMITTEE FOR SPEARHEADING --
THIS INITIATIVE -- I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE -- AND THINK -- MY TWO
FRIENDS -- CENTER A TITLE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- REGULAR --
FOR INSURING THAT OUR VOICES
HERE IN THE VALLEY I HEARD THAT
THE REPRESENTATION -- AND THAT
THEY WILL IN FACT BE HEARD HERE
TODAY -- DIRECTLY -- IN PERSON --
SO I I. REPRESENTS THE ONLY LAMB
LOCKS DISTRICTS -- IN THE CITY
OF FRESNO -- THE VERY INNER CITY
OF FRESNO -- COVERS A CENTRAL --
SOUTHEAST PORTIONS OF THE CITY
WHERE THESE ISSUES THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS EXPLORING ARE ON A
COMPLETE -- AND FULL DISPLAY.
ALSO WE ARE LIVING THIS REALITY --
EVERY SINGLE DAY -- IDOL THAT
GROWING UP HERE IN THE VALLEY I
DEVELOPED ASTHMA BY THE AGE OF
THREE YEARS OLD -- AND I WORRY
ON A DAILY BASIS ABOUT -- MY
EIGHTEEN MONTH OLD DAUGHTER
FACING THE SAME FATE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE WHO CAME
OUT TO PARTICIPATE -- TESTIFY --
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR OUR OUR
VOICES ARE HEARD TO THIS
WONDERFUL GROUP OF SENATORS WHO
I BELIEVE -- SHARE OUR SAME
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE ON OUR
COMMUNITIES -- THE NEED IT MOST --
SO AGAIN WELCOME -- I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE ABOUT A TWO TWO
POINT FIVE HOUR HEARING -- IF
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN THE FRESNO
CITY HALL BEFORE IF THE
RESTROOMS YOU WALK OUT THESE
DOUBLE DOORS -- THERE'S A SET OF
RESTROOMS TO YOUR RIGHT AND
CENTER RESTROOMS HERE LEFT US TO
GO IN THE DIRECTION -- YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO FIND -- THE BATHROOMS --
AGAIN WELCOME -- CITY MY C.
TODAY.
CENTER GALGIANI SAM I SEE
WELCOME REGULATIONS YEAH IT
LOOKS REALLY GOOD ON YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COUNSEL AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU.
SINCE THE GALGIANI DON'T LEAVE
ANY NOTES OVER ANYTHING OVER ON
THE DEATH PLEASE THEY WANT TO
BUY THIS BACK.
SO GETTING INTO THE MEAT OF THE
HEARING -- I AM THRILLED THAT
YOU ACCEPTED OUR INVITATION.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF MEETING DR
MARK GALLI THE NEW HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY
APPOINTED BY GAVIN A GOVERNING
NEWSOME JUST A COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY SIT DOWN
IN THE OFFICE ARTICLES RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS.
AND I TOLD HIM ABOUT THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AS WE WERE GETTING
TO KNOW EACH OTHER AND SHARING
KIND OF OUR BACKGROUND THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE WITH DYLAN AND I
SAID HEY I GOT A HEARING COMING
UP.
IN JULY IN FRESNO.
ANY CAME ANYWAY RIGHT.
BOB FRESNO BEFRUGAL ISN'T EASY
TO GET TO CENTER TOGGLE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU.
SO JUST SO EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
WHO DODD THE GALLEY AS HE IS IN
CHARGE OF THE LARGEST.
AGENCY IN THE STATE.
HE'S RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING THE
GOVERNOR IMPLEMENT HIS VISION OF
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND NOT.
TO YOU KNOW.
MAKE LIGHT OF IT HE ALSO HAPPENS
TO HAVE A MEDICAL DEGREE FROM
HARVARD CELL.
WHICH SHOP IN HIGH COTTON TODAY --
I AT APPRECIATE YOU COMING WE
WANTED -- TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR NOT ONLY HIM TO
SHARE IN THE LEARNING EXPERIENCE
WILL HAPPEN HEARING FROM ALL OF
YOU.
BUT THE ALSO -- OPEN THIS UP AND
LAUNCH US OUT WITH SOME REMARKS
AND THOUGHTS YOU HAVE.
REALLY ABOUT -- THE THE FOCUS OF
THE WORK OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
OF THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING HERE TODAY IN TERMS
OF THE SHORTAGE OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS CONSISTENTLY ACROSS
THE STATE -- AND SO WITH THAT.
I'D LIKE YOU TO KICK US OFF AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
ONE THANK YOU -- FRESNO FOR
WELCOMING ME IT -- AND TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE -- IT'S A REAL
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE -- YOU IT
IS GOING TO BE A FULL DAY FOR ME
AFTER THIS SELECT HEARING NOW
HAVE A CHANCE TO VISIT SOME OF
THE FACILITIES IN THE FRESNO AND
CENTRAL VALLEY AREA.
AND REALLY TAKE A CHANCE -- TO
NOT JUST IMAGINE AND LISTENED TO
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE BUT I
HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE THE
PATIENTS THE STAFF THAT WORK FOR
THEM AND WITH THEM -- AND
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
HOW WE AT THE AGENCY THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL DESCRIBED TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO REALLY IMPACT
WHAT HAPPENS HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
SO AGAIN I'M DOCTOR MARK ALLEY
I'M THE NEW HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO HAPPEN TO BE A
PEDIATRICIAN -- WHO UP UNTIL
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO WAS IN
CLINICS IN A SAFETY NET HOSPITAL
IN -- LOS ANGELES TAKING CARE OF
LOTS OF PEOPLE AND FAMILIES WHO
BENEFIT FROM MEDICAID IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT TODAY I HAVE A
CHANCE TO OVERSEE.
IN WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE TOPIC
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND THE
THE THOUGHT OF HOW DO WE REALLY
DEVELOPED THE WORK FORCE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW WE ADDRESS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS THAT DRIVE SO MANY
OF OUR YOUNG CHILDREN TOO BAD
HEALTH DOWN THE ROAD -- I CAN'T
HELP.
BUT THINK ABOUT -- THE CARE OF
THE FAMILY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THE FOCUS ON
KIDS AND IT'S EASY FOR ME TO
FOCUS ON IT AS A PEDIATRICIAN
AND SPENDING A CAREER A
SENSUALLY TAKING CARE OF
CHILDREN.
I'VE YET TO MEET A CHILD WHO
REALLY STRUGGLES WITH HEALTH.
AND ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
CHILDREN WHO STRUGGLE WITH
HEALTH WHO ALSO DON'T HAVE SICK
PARENTS.
GRANDPARENTS WHO REALLY HAVE THE
CHALLENGE OF THEMSELVES
ACCESSING CARE.
SO I WOULD JUST REMIND US THAT
AS WE THINK ABOUT THE CARE OF
CHILDREN HOW IMPORTANT AND VITAL
IT IS FOR US TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT.
THE CARE OF OUR FAMILIES AND IT
GOES WAY BEYOND WHAT WE DO IN
THE FOUR WALLS OF A CLINIC.
RIDE THE DRIVERS OF HEALTH.
DON'T START THE DAY YOU COME IN
FOR YOUR FIRST WELL CHILD CHECK
CERTAINLY WE DECLARE VICTORY
WHEN WE GET ALL OF OUR KIDS THE
IMMUNIZATIONS THEY NEED.
TO BUT VERY FEW OF THE KIDS THAT
I SEE WHO SUFFER FROM -- THE
SOCIAL MANIFESTATIONS OF OR THE
MEDICAL MANIFESTATIONS OF SOCIAL
INEQUALITY OUR DINER HAVING
PROBLEMS FROM THE LACK OF
IMMUNIZATION.
IT'S THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT TODAY.
IT'S ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT CENTRAL THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FACES -- CONTAMINATED
WATER AT A RATE GREATER THAN ANY
OTHER PART OF OUR STATE.
THE FACT THAT A QUARTER OF THE
NATION'S FOOD COMES FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT WERE ONE THE
THE THIRD MOST FOOD INSECURE
REGIONS.
IN THE NATION -- IS A SHAME AND
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY I THINK
THROUGH NOT JUST THE TWELVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT I HAVE A CHANCE
TO LEAD EVERYTHING FROM SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO SENIOR SERVICES AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. TO REALLY
MAKE AN IMPACT ON THOSE THINGS
BUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THE WATER ISSUES THE AIR QUALITY
ISSUES.
NOT JUST IN THE BIG URBAN
CENTERS WHERE WE ARE HAPPENED TO
FLY IN AND OUT OF ALL THE TIME
BUT TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF DRIVING
ACROSS THIS MORNING.
AND COMING HERE TODAY.
I WILL TELL YOU ON HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE IT IS -- AS A AS UCSF
RESIDENT -- ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
COMING TO FRESNO -- AND HELPING
CARE FOR SOME KIDS IN THE
CLINICS HERE AND IT IS A
TREMENDOUS PLACE WITH GREAT.
RICHNESS IN P. ALL AND
CALIFORNIA.
OUR BIGGEST ASSET OUR OUR OUR
PEOPLE.
AND THE FACT THAT WE NOW HAVE A
DECADE AND A HALF LATER SOME
REAL PLANS ON HOW TO BUILD THIS
HEALTHCARE RESOURCES RESOURCE
NOT JUST WITH.
MORE DOCTORS AND MORE NURSES
WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY NEED BUT
BUILDING UP WHAT I WOULD SAY ARE
THE HEALTH COMMUNITY
PROFESSIONALS OUR PROMISE FOR US
THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW THEIR WAY
AROUND.
WHO DON'T DRIVE TO WORK BUT WALK
TO WORK AND THEY KNOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN A WAY?
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SELECT COMMITTEE OUR
GOVERNOR ON DISCOVERING ALL OF
THE GREAT WORK FOR US
INVESTMENTS AND OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT WE CAN REALLY TAKE ON IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS NOT
JUST IN THE HEALTH SPACE BUT IN
THE MENTAL SPACE I DON'T WANT US
TO FORGET.
THAT.
SO MANY INDIVIDUALS AND CHILDREN --
WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF BY
GUARDIANS FOSTER PARENTS --
ADOPTIVE PARENTS BIOLOGICAL
PARENTS AUNTS AND UNCLES OF
WHALERS AND GRANDPARENTS ALL
OVER THAT -- THAT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES REALLY WEIGH
HEAVY ON THE KIDS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND HOW DO WE NOT ONLY ADDRESS
THE HEALTH CARE THE PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
BUT THAT MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND I THINK THIS IS A SPACE
WHERE OUR EFFORTS AROUND FROM A
TAURUS AND COMMUNITY
PROFESSIONALS REALLY NEEDS TO BE
BUILT UP.
I'M I WILL END WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF GOOD NEWS -- THE GOVERNOR HAD
A VERY HEALTHY HAVE THE BUDGET
AND IT WAS A PRIVILEGE TO BE
PART OF IT.
NOT ONLY DID WE MAKE GREAT
INVESTMENTS AND NEW EFFORTS LIKE
LOOKING AT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EVENTS IN OUR PEDIATRIC
PRACTICES AND WORKING ON
TRAINING AND SUPPORTING THOSE
PEDIATRICIANS AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY ASSESS AND ADDRESS ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EVENTS WE INVEST STOOD
IN MEDICAID RATES ACROSS THE
STATE BUT WE ALSO MADE A GREAT
INVESTMENT AND WORK FORCE AND
PAYING OFF PEOPLE'S.
LOANS WHO ARE CHOOSING TO WORK
IN UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
HUGE UNDER ADDRESS NEEDS AND IN
OUR FRESNO.
OR IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE
AWARDED ALMOST FORTY JUST SHY
FORTY THIRTY NINE PHYSICIANS WHO
ARE WORKING FOR THE MEDICAID
POPULATION ACROSS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
LOAN REPAYMENTS OF UP TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
HELP THEM STAY COMMITTED FOR
THIS REGION.
AND NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HOW
ARE THEY GOING TO PAY OFF THOSE
MEGA LOANS THAT THEY TOOK ON TO
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK IN.
LOW INCOME UNDER SERVED
COMMUNITIES ON THE DENTAL SIDE
WE AWARDED ACROSS THE STATE
FORTY DENTISTS.
LOAN REPAYMENT AWARDS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TEN SO A QUARTER
OF THE DENTISTS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT RECEIVE THIS AWARD LIVE AND
WORK IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
THINK THAT'S JUST A SMALL STEP A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP.
BUT SOMETHING TO BUILD ON AND I
THINK THE THEME IS CALIFORNIA
HAS A TON TO BUILD ON AND
ALTHOUGH THEIR AMBITIOUS AND
WONDERFUL INITIATIVES WE'RE NOT
STARTING FROM.
ZERO YOU ALL HAVE BEEN PART OF A
MOVEMENT. TO SAY WE DESERVE
BETTER WE CAN DO BETTER AND I'M
JUST PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE IN
THE SEAT TO LISTEN AND LEARN
FROM YOU THROUGHOUT THE DAY SO
SENATOR MITCHELL AND ALL OF YOU
ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE INVITATION.
IT WAS A NO BRAINER IT WAS A
QUESTION OF DO I FLY OR DRIVE
AND IT WAS A GREAT DRIVE AND
IT'S A REAL PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
IN I. ONE ECHO THAT WE HAVE TO
TIP OUR HATS -- TO THIS GOVERNOR
WHO'S MADE IT VERY.
CLEAR EARLY IMPRESSION ON ALL OF
US AND HOPEFULLY ON YOU AS WELL
IN TERMS OF HIS COMMITMENT. TO
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS --
VERTICALLY IN THE AREA OF
HEALTHCARE SO THANK YOU.
I WOULD REGARD TO MENTAL HEALTH
YOU KNOW THIS IS HEARING NUMBER
TWO OF SIX WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF
TIME TOP BUT ALL THOSE
ADDITIONAL ISSUES.
AND PLEASE TRUST WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE.
A LANDSCAPE OF THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF MIKE TO DIVIDE UP OUR FIRST
PANEL.
AS THE APPROACH I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PALACE NOW THAT
WE'VE GOT A TIME KEEPER WHERE'S
THE TIME KEEPER WAY OUT THERE
SHE IS -- THEY'RE GONNA HOLD
SIGNS UP TO SIGNAL BUT YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH TIME YOU HAVE LEFT FROM.
ONE MINUTE TO THIRTY SECONDS.
TO ZERO AND IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN --
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING
YOU ALL KNOW THAT I KNOW HOW TO
KEEP THE TRAINS RUNNING ON TIME --
AND SO WE ARE WE'RE GOING TO
STICK TO THE TIME FRAME --
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO ASK QUESTIONS.
AND EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE THE TOM
COMMIT FOR THE HEARING BUT WE
ALLOW ENOUGH TIME AT THE END OF
THE HEARING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON OUR FIRST PANEL -- WE HAVE
DOCTOR JANET KAUFMAN IS A
PROFESSOR AT UC SAN FRANCISCO
DOCTOR COPPENS BETUL D. AS ABOUT
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE SHE'S I
THINK NUMEROUS ARTICLES ON THE
TOPIC.
WAS A CONSULTANT TO THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION.
ALSO JOINING US IS DOCTOR
CATHLEEN FLOORS DOCTOR FLORES
WAS BORN INTO AN EVER GET
MEXICAN FAMILY RESIDING RIGHT
HERE IN FRESNO.
AND WORKED AS A MIGRANT FARM
WORKER FOR FIRST SIXTEEN YEARS
OF LIFE.
HE'S AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
FAMILY MEDICINE AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF BREZNO
LATINO CENTER FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION RESEARCH.
AND FINALLY BACK TO CARLA -- YOU
DIRECTOR OF THE PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AT VALLEY
CHILDREN'S HEALTH CARE DR YOUNG
IS BOARD CERTIFIED.
AND PEDIATRIC GASTROENTEROL LOGY
ARE TOO YOUNG IS WIDELY
PUBLISHED AS WELL.
WE'VE GOT BETH -- THEIR FULL
BIOS I DIDN'T DO ANY OF THEM.
SERVICE FOR WHAT THEIR TRUE
BACKGROUND IN AND THE
SIGNIFICANT IS SIGNIFICANT
SISTER THIS TODAY'S CONVERSATION
BUT YOU'VE GOT THEIR FULL BIOS
AVAILABLE IN YOUR PACKETS WE'RE
GONNA START WITH DOCTOR KAUFMAN
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
HIT THE MIKE SEE THE BUTTON
RIGHT YOU GO OKAY WELL JUST
GRASS YES SENATOR MITCHELL'S
WILL CLOSE MEMBROS DEALER
COMMITTEE SECRETARY GUY IT.
WOULD LARA OPPORTUNITY DODD OF
LARA KWAN WAS STATUS AWAY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND SECRETARY GOD FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU.
I TODAY OUR I THINK MY ROLE HERE
IS TO GIVE YOU SORT OF A THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT OVERVIEW ON SOME
OF THE WORK FORCE CHALLENGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE VALLEY I'M
GONNA FOCUS ON PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BECAUSE I
BELIEVE OUR RESEARCH WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT THESE ARE. TO THE
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES WE CERTAINLY HAVE
CHALLENGES EVERY AREAS BUT THESE
ARE TWO OF THE GREATEST SO WHEN
THE INTEREST OF TIME WILL FOCUS
THEIR OUR SERVER FIVE KEY POINTS
ON THE CHALLENGES WE FACE FIRST
OUR PRIMARY CARE IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
ARE NOT DISTRIBUTED EVENLY
ACROSS THE STATE THE
DISTRIBUTION IS QUITE POOR AND
I'LL SHOW YOU A COUPLE SLIDES
ABOUT THAT.
A SECOND SOME PRIMARY KERR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS DO
NOT ACCEPT MEDICAID PATIENTS WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THAT IS
CHANGING AS THE STATE HAS
INCREASED MEDIC COW RATES.
BUT IT IS A PARTICULAR CONCERN
IN PLACES LIKE THE VALLEY WHERE
A LARGE PART OF OUR POPULATION
IS IN POVERTY AND ON MEDICARE
NOW -- SECONDLY A THIRD MANY
PRIMARY KERR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
AT OR NEAR RETIREMENT AGE --
WHICH MEANS WE NEED TO THINK
VERY SERIOUSLY ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO REPLACE THEM AND THE
FORECASTS THAT I AND MY
COLLEAGUES AT UCSF HAVE DONE.
SUGGEST THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
INSUFFICIENT NUMBERS OF NEW
PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO REPLACE
THOSE WHO RETIRE AND LESS THE
STATE AXE PROACTIVELY. TO EXPAND
THEIR NUMBERS AND INDEED I THINK
THE BUDGET FOR THIS YEAR MADE A
GOOD DOWN PAYMENT ON THAT
INVESTMENT BUT THERE'S STILL
MORE TO DO.
AND THEN FINALLY PRIMARY CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
ARE NOT AS RACIALLY ETHNICALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
THEY DO NOT LOOK LIKE CALIFORNIA.
AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY
LOOK MORE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
OKAY SO JUST A FEW -- GRAPHS
HERE LOOKING AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE MAJOR REGIONS
OF THE STATE -- AND THESE ARE
ACTIVE PATIENT CARE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION NOW WHY DO WE DO A
RATIO PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION WELL THAT ENABLES US
TO MAKE MEANINGFUL COMPARISONS
ACROSS REGIONS OF WE JUST LOOKED
AT RAW NUMBERS.
WE SEE THAT LA HAS MORE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS WELL LOS ANGELES
HAS MORE PEOPLE MORE FREEWAYS.
MORE CARS PROBABLY MORE
STARBUCKS THAN ANY PLACE AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT JUST
DOESN'T HELP WAS PUTTING HIM ON
A HUNT PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SCALE.
MAKES MEANINGFUL COMP --
COMPARISONS AND SO WHAT WE SEE
HERE.
CALIFORNIA OVERALL HAS FIFTY
SEVEN ACTIVE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ONLY FORTY FIVE SO WE'RE
BEHIND THE STATE.
AND THEN IF WE LOOK HERE AT
PSYCHIATRY THE SITUATION IS EVEN
MORE BLEAK CALIFORNIA OVERALL
HAS FIFTEEN PSYCHIATRIST PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION.
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS ONLY
SEVEN LESS THAN HALF.
OF MOVING TO MEDIC COW THIS
GRAPH PERCENTS.
SOME WORK THAT -- OUR I
COLLEAGUES AND I DID FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION --
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND L. WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
AT THAT TIME 64%.
OF PHYSICIANS IN CALIFORNIA HAD
ANY MEDIC HOW PATIENTS IN THEIR
PRACTICE SO THIS ISN'T WERE THEY
WILLING TO ACCEPT NEW OR NOT
THIS DID THEY HAD EVEN ANY
EXISTING.
MEDIC HOW PATIENTS IN THEIR
PRACTICE AND ONLY 64% DID SO
AGAIN -- THIS IS A CONCERN FOR
AREAS OF THE STATE WITH A HIGH
PROPORTION THE POPULATION MEDIC
HAL AND WE'RE CERTAINLY HOPEFUL
I THAT THE INCREASES IN MEDICAL
PAYMENT WILL RESULT IN MORE
DOCTORS SERVING MEDI CAL
PATIENTS.
I'M RACE ETHNICITY HERE
APPLAUDED DATA FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN ON RECENT GRADUATES OF
M. D. D. O. THAT'S OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIAN.
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND ARE IN
EDUCATION PROGRAMS BY RACE
ETHNICITY AND AGAIN WHAT WE SEE
THEY DO NOT MATCH THE POPULATION
I GOT THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA OVER ON THE RIGHT.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE PERCENTAGES
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS AND
NATIVE AMERICANS IN THE
POPULATION AND WE LOOK OVER AT
THESE -- FIVE PROFESSIONS THERE
ARE.
THERE'S UNDER REPRESENTATION FOR
ALL NOW CURIOUSLY IF WE LOOK AT
SOME OTHER FIELDS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR JACQUELINE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND EVEN
PRIMARY CARE WOULD BE SOCIAL.
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE GREAT ROLES
TO PLAY IN COUNSELING AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND THEY CAN
ALSO BE VALUABLE IN PRIMARY CARE
IN HELPING FOLKS.
GET THE FULL RANGE OF OF
SERVICES THEY NEED TO BE AS
HEALTHY AS THEY CAN TO ADDRESS
THEIR SOCIAL NEEDS AS WELL AS A
MEDICAL AND THAT'S A FIELD WHERE
FOR LATINOS IN AND FOR OTHER
CHRISTMAS SPECIAL FOR LATINOS WE
SEE A MUCH HIGHER REPRESENTATION
SO I THINK ONE OF OUR QUESTIONS.
ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES IS HOW CAN
WE GET THESE MORE CLINICAL
PROFESSIONS TO LOOK MORE LIKE
SOCIAL WORK.
OKAY TWO MINUTES I'VE GOT A
SPEEDED UP.
I'M SO JUST THIS SLIDE I WON'T
GO INTO DEPTH WITH THIS IS A
TYPOLOGY OF DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
FOR ADDRESSING HEALTH WORKFORCE
NEEDS TO SORT OF YOU CAN KIND OF
THINK ABOUT OF A WAY TO KIND OF
CATEGORIZE THE DIFFERENT.
STRATEGIES YOU MIGHT PURSUE SO
FIRST IS ENHANCED THE PIPELINE
GROW THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE PURSUING HEALTH PROFESSIONS
EDUCATION AND FOCUS ON IN
RECRUITING.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
INTERESTED MOST PASSION ABOUT
SERVING UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
AND PREPARE THEM TO DO THAT.
UP RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
PROGRAMS OF THINGS LIKE LONGER
PAYMENT STRATEGIES TO TAKE OUR
PHYSICIANS NURSES OTHERS WHO
WERE RICHARD COMING OUT OF
TRAINING AND GET THEM TO
PRACTICE IN THE PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE THEY'RE MOST NEEDED
GET THEM TO THE CARE.
FOR CARE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST IN NEED OF MAXIMIZING THE
EXISTING REPORTS TAKING STEP
BACK AND SAY MORE WE USE THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE.
MORE EFFICIENTLY MORE
EFFECTIVELY WE CERTAINLY HAVE
HEARD SEVERAL PEOPLE TODAY
MENTION CHROMODORIS AND THAT'S
DEFINITELY ONE TYPE OF A HEALTH
WORKER THAT WE COULD EXECUTE
UTILIZE MORE EXTENSIVELY --
FINALLY LEVERAGING DATA I MEAN
THIS IS ADMITTEDLY A LITTLE SELF
SERVING I'M AN ACADEMIC BUT I
WANT TO SAY IT'S NOT JUST THAT.
IS THAT WE REALLY DON'T HAVE THE
DATA SYSTEMS IN PLACE IN OUR
STATE. TO ENABLE -- THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND AND THE SECRETARY
AND OTHERS TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS ABOUT INVESTMENTS IN
THE HEALTH WORKFORCE AND OUR
GROUP AT UCSF WILL HAVE A PAPER
COMING OUT IN A FEW WEEKS LAYING
OUT WHAT WE SEE IS AN IDEAL
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA.
I'M I'M NOT GONNA TALK MUCH
ABOUT THE STATE BUDGET ITEMS
BECAUSE OTHERS HAVE DONE THAT
BUT TO SAY THAT THEY ARE A GOOD
A DOWN PAYMENT.
AND THEN SOME RECOMMENDATIONS OF
WHERE WE MIGHT.
GO BEYOND THIS IN TERMS OF X.
THE EXISTING WORKFORCE THERE'S
LEGISLATION PENDING BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE TO GIVE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS FOR PRACTICE.
A STORY THIS CERTAINLY ISN'T THE
ONLY THING WE COULD DO BUT IT IS
ONE THING THAT TAKES LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
MOST STATES NURSE PRACTITIONERS
CAN BRIBE CAN PRACTICE.
WITHOUT SUPERVISION AND THERE'S
VERY STRONG ROBUST BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT THEY CAN DO THIS
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
AND WILL STOP THERE AND OR DO
YOU ONLY CAN [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
OKAY WELL WELL WELL.
WILL STOP THEIR OWNERS PRACTICES
SAFELY EFFECTIVELY AND THOSE
STATES THAT HAVE FULL PRACTICE
OF FORTY TEND YOU'RE MORE FOLKS
ARE ENTERING THE FIELD.
AND THERE'S BETTER ACCESS TO
CARE SO THE LAST THREE REALLY
QUICKLY INCREASE FUNDING FOR
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
AND PSYCHIATRIC NURSE
PRACTITIONER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THERE CERTAINLY SOME MONEY FOR
THIS IN THE BUDGET BUT IT'S NOT
ON THE SCALE OF THE INVESTMENT
IN PRIMARY CARE.
SO I REALLY THINK WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE SCALE OF THE NEED AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THERE'S A NEED
FOR MORE INVESTMENT THEIR
RELATIVE TO PRIMARY CARE --
PROVIDING FUNDS FOR TARGET
INCREASES IN A MOMENT A
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
SCHOOLS.
OF THE FORTY FIVE TO THE FORTY
FIVE STATES HAVE MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ARE FEW THE SMALL STICK JUST
DON'T HAVE A FORTY FIVE STATES
HAVE MEDICAL SCHOOLS.
CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY THIRD.
FORTY THIRD IN THE RATIO OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS TO POPULATION.
SO OUR YOUNG CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE INTEREST IN BECOMING
PHYSICIANS HAVE FAR FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN MOST OTHER
STATES.
OF AND I WOULD COME INTO THE
REPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION THAT
HAS. SIX SEPARATE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR STRATEGIES
THAT COULD BE PURSUED TO
INCREASE.
ENROLLMENT AND USE THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL SO I THINK.
THOSE ARE ALL WORTH TAKING A
LOOK AT AND THEN LASTLY
INVESTING IN THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION PIPELINE.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE TO LOOK MORE LIKE
CALIFORNIA UNLESS WE INVEST IN
THE PIPELINE AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE IS PARTICULARLY TO
INVEST IN THE PIPELINE AT THE
COLLEGE AND POST BACCALAUREATE
LEVEL.
THESE ARE OUR YOUNG LATINO ALL
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AFRICAN AMERICAN
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WE'VE ASKED THEM TO
DO TO GET THEMSELVES INTO
COLLEGE AND IN SOME PLACES HAVE
DONE.
EVERYTHING WE'VE ASKED THEM TO
DO IN TERMS OF THE PREREQUISITE
COURSES AND THE TESTS AT THAT
YOU NEED FOR ADMISSION TO HEALTH
PROFESSIONS SCHOOL.
AND THIS IS THAT ADDED ACADEMIC
SOCIAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO HELP
THEM GO THAT LAST MILE TO
REALIZE THEIR DREAMS.
AND WITH THAT I'LL STOP AND I
THINK WE TURN IT OVER TO DR
FLORES [INAUDIBLE] TO MIKE.
OKAY NETWORKS -- FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING TO
FRESNO IT REALLY DOES MEAN A LOT
TO ALL OF US IT'S MUCH EASIER TO
SPEAK TO YOU HERE THAN HAVING UP
TO SACRAMENTO SO.
HE WHICH HAS GOT HIS PRODUCT UP
UNTIL SKINNER SCANDINAVIA LUCKY
CONSIDER SAUDA.
ON SAME LITTLE WHAT WE'LL SECOND
WHETHER A PERSON.
ON A SECOND MINI THAT.
SO -- I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW JANET
COUGH DR KAUFMAN AND THE REASON
I LEFT TO FOLLOW DR KAUFFMAN IS
BECAUSE IT FITS RIGHT INTO WHAT
MY REMARKS ARE FOCUSED ON MY
REMARKS ARE FOCUSED ON
INCREASING -- THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE AND WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WHICH FITS THIS
PARTICULAR -- CONVERSATION SO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME AND WHY I'M
DOING WHAT I'M DOING AS WAS
MENTIONED I DOES COME FROM I DO
COME FROM AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY --
AND I WAS A FARM WORKER -- FOR
THE FOR SIXTEEN YEARS OF MY LIFE
SO I'VE LIVED.
WHAT MANY OF MY PATIENTS AND
MANY OF THE MANY OF THE STUDENTS
THAT I WORK WITH HAVE LIVED
THROUGH AND CONTINUE TO LOOK
THROUGH AS IMMIGRANT TOM?
FAMILIES.
HAVING THAT EXPERIENCE --
INEVITABLY.
WE FACED MANY INEQUITIES IN
HEALTHCARE -- I SAW WITHIN MY
OWN PERSONAL FAMILY -- TRAGEDIES
THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE OCCURRED
HAD WE NOT LIVED IN LABOR CAMPS
HAD WE NOT LIVED IN CARS HAVE
BEEN NOT LIVED IN TENTS.
ON THINGS THAT COULD HAVE BEEN --
HANDLED BETTER BY THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT TOOK CARE OF
MY FAMILY HAD THEY RECOGNIZED
UNDERSTOOD WHERE WE CAME FROM
WHAT OUR RESOURCES WERE AND THEY
WOULD HAVE OFFERED OTHER TYPES
OF REMEDIES IF YOU WILL -- AND
SO THAT'S WHAT DROVE ME INTO
HEALTHCARE.
I BECAME A FAMILY PHYSICIAN IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I WANTED TO
PROVIDE.
PRIMARY CARE FOR THE ENTIRE
FAMILY BUT BEYOND THE FAMILY THE
COMMUNITY TAKING CARE OF A ONE
PERSON IS IMPORTANT TAKING CARE
OF THE FAMILY IS IMPORTANT BUT
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS TAKING
CARE OF THE COMMUNITY AND
UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITY FROM
WHERE THEY COME FROM -- I THEN
BECAME A FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND THE
REASON FOR THAT WAS BECAUSE
HAVING GONE TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
AND NOT HAVING ANY MENTORS AND
ROLE MODELS -- IT WAS A CUTE FOR
ME TO GIVE BACK TO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE -- TO HELP THEM NOT
STRUGGLE THE WAY THAT I
STRUGGLED AS I WENT THROUGH
UNDERGRAD AND THEN COLLEGE --
MEDICAL SCHOOL -- AND EVEN
RESIDENCY PROGRAM RESIDENCY
TRAINING.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT -- BACKGROUND --
WE FOUNDED THE A DOCTOR'S
ACADEMY -- IT'S AT THE UCSF
RESIDENT AT THE IN A CENTER FOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND RESEARCH I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE AND HONOR OF
BEING THE DIRECTOR OF THAT
PROGRAM.
AND WE WORK -- WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
STARTING IN SEVENTH GRADE ALL
THE WAY THROUGH COLLEGE AND THEN
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
ALUMNI WHO ARE ALREADY IN HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
ON BECAUSE OUR MISSION IS TO
INCREASE THE CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND THE LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY OF
THE PROVIDERS THAT SERVE US HERE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ON THE IDEA WAS TO GROW OUR OWN --
WE WORK WITH THE DISADVANTAGED
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS WHO
HAVE NO HIGHER EDUCATION LEGACY --
WE WORK TO DEVELOP A COLLEGE
GOING CULTURE TO HELP KIDS --
DEVELOP THAT SELF EFFICACY THE
BELIEF IN THEMSELVES THAT THEY
NEED AND ALSO TO WORK WITH THEIR
PARENTS ON TO HELP THEM BELIEVE
THAT THE KIDS REALLY COULD
SUCCEED.
AND IN ADDITION WORKING WITH THE
TEACHERS TO SEE THAT THESE KIDS
DESPITE WHERE THEY COME FROM
DESPITE WHAT THEIR BACKGROUNDS
ARE THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL -- WE
ALSO WANT TO HELP OUR KIDS NOT
JUST BE SUCCESSFUL BY PROVIDING
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES IN
ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
AND HEALTH MENTOR -- ADD
CONTACTS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY --
TO REMIND THEM TO HOLD ON TO
WHERE THEY COME FROM HOLD ON TO
THEIR CULTURES AND THEIR
LANGUAGES SO THAT THEY CAN
RETURN TO THE VALLEY AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
WE PROVIDES A BUNCH A TOTAL
COMPREHENSIVE ACADEMIC SUPPORT
ENRICHMENT HEALTH CREEKS BOWSHER
WE HAVE WORKED WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO DATE -- A
100% OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE AND
A 100% OF THEM HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED INTO HEALTH.
INTO. FOUR YEAR COLLEGES.
WE SEEK TO EMPOWER THEM TO
EMPOWER THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WHETHER TO
BECOME A PHYSICIAN ALTHOUGH
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO US WHAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT THAT THEY BECOME
SUCCESSFUL -- COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND THAT THEY RETURN AND PROVIDE
SERVICE.
IN OUR WORKFORCE COMMISSION ON
THE ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND DOCTOR COFFIN ALLUDED TO
THIS WAS TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
HEALTH HALFWAY PROGRAMMING.
AND THAT INCLUDES HEALTH PATHWAY
PROGRAMS AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOLS BECAUSE IF YOU
DON'T EXPOSE KIDS TO WHAT THEY
CAN BE EARLY ON THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN
DO IT.
BUT BEYOND JUST EXPOSURE YOU
NEED TO GIVE THEM THAT ACADEMIC
SUPPORT BECAUSE TO GIVE A
MCCARRON SAY THIS IS WHAT YOU
CAN DO BUT NOT PROVIDE THAT MEET.
OF WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE THAT --
THAT ACADEMIC JOURNEY ON
SUCCESSFUL WERE NOT REALLY
HELPING THEM AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
IN ADDITION WE SO SUPPORTING
THOSE TYPE OF PROGRAMS AND THERE
ARE MANY INCLUDING IN ALL OF
YOUR DISTRICTS -- THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
FUNDING OF THE H. COP PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE THE HEALTH KERR
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY AT OUR ALLEN ST
COLLEGE IS THAT WE ENCOURAGE
THAT THAT BE EXPANDED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND TO UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES THOSE PROGRAMS DO
BASICALLY WITH THE DOCTORS
ACADEMY DOES HERE IN FRESNO
WHICH IS AGAIN PROVIDE IN
RICHMOND ACADEMICALLY BUT ALSO.
EXPOSURE -- AND THEN HELP THE
STUDENTS FIGURE OUT HOW -- TO
APPLY AND GET INTO THEIR HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS -- THOSE WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE THAT ARE VERY VERY --
PROMISING BUT WE NEED FUNDING TO
EXPAND THAT TO OTHER PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE OTHER COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
ULTIMATELY THE PROGRAMS THAT I'M
DESCRIBING WILL LEAD TO MORE
CULTURALLY LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT HEALTH PROVIDERS WHO
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE.
STUDIES ARE VERY CLEAR THAT
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
PROVIDERS ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO PROVIDE CARE TO PATIENTS WHO
COME FROM -- DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS PATIENTS WHO HAVE
MEDICARE MEDICAID I'LL ON AND SO
IT'S VERY CRITICAL AGAIN THAT WE
GROW OUR OWN SET WE ASSURE THAT
OUR PATIENTS CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
CARE -- WITH THE INSURANCE THAT
THEY HAVE -- SO I'LL END BY JUST
REMINDING US AND REMINDING OUR
VISITORS -- THAT GROWING OUR OWN
IS A CONCEPT THAT WORKS IT'S
PROVEN -- WE JUST NEED MORE
FUNDING AND WE NEED TO MAKE MORE
STRATEGIC AND BRINGING THAT --
TOGETHER SO THAT RATHER THAN
HAVING SPOT PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE HAVE COORDINATION
COLLABORATION AND THAT -- WE'VE
BASICALLY LEARN BEST PRACTICES
AND SHARE THOSE ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
DR YOUNG.
THE MORNING HANDS I WANT TO SAY
GOOD MORNING TO EVERYBODY OUT
THERE I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT I MET AGAIN FROM DIFFERENT
OTHER ORGANIZATIONAL MEETINGS.
AND I'M NEW ORDER FRESNO BUT I
HAVE TO SAY JUST LIKE EVERYONE
SAID FRESNO'S ON THE BEST PLACES
TO LIVE AND I'M I'M A BELIEVER
SO I WON'T BE.
I'LL BE STAYING HERE FOR A LONG
TIME.
I WANNA THANK YOU -- DOCTOR
MITCHELL AND OUR SORRY STARTED
TELLING SENATOR DOLE AND SENATOR
DODD OF FOR FOR INVITING ME AND
ALSO THE OTHERS LET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- IS KIND OF FITTING
THAT I'M THE LAST PERSON TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I'M GOING TO TAKE
IT A LITTLE BIT MORE IN A
GRANULAR LEVEL.
I WAS FORTUNATE TO BECOME OF THE
VALLEY CHILDREN'S PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM DIRECTOR AND I
CAME HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I WAS IN THE MILITARY
FOR A LONG TIME AND THEN AT
JOHNS HOPKINS PRIOR TO THAT --
BALTIMORE HAS ITS OWN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION IN.
COMING HERE THE THE THING THAT
I'VE REALLY APPRECIATED IS THE
FACT THAT EVERYONE REALLY DOES
WORK TOGETHER AND I THINK THIS A
GREAT EXAMPLE IN THE ROOM IS
PACKED.
VALLEY CHILDREN'S AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW WAS -- BORN OUT OF THE
VISION OF FIVE WOMEN OF THE
VALLEY WHO.
DECIDED THAT A PEDIATRIC
HOSPITALS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
OVER SIXTY YEARS AGO.
AND RIGHT NOW OUR MEDICARE
POPULATION RATE WRITES ABOUT 80%
ACROSS OUR NETWORK -- SOME
PLACES MORE THAN OTHERS AND IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAM THAT TRAINS THIRTEEN NEW
PEDIATRIC DOCTORS EVERY YEAR.
HOWEVER WE TRAIN UP TO TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTS PER YEAR FROM
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY FROM EVERY
SPECIALTY INCLUDING.
NURSE PRACTITIONERS FAMILY
MEDICINE INTERNAL MEDI US ARE
NOT INTERNAL MEDICINE EMERGENCY
MEDICINE SURGEONS WITH
ORTHOPEDIC AND GENERAL SURGEONS
AND WE REALLY FOUND THAT AND FOR
DISCIPLINARY TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT
REALLY MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN INCLUDE THE
NURSES IN THE SOCIAL WORK AND
TURNS AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO COME
TO VALLEY CHILDREN'S FOR
TRAINING.
TODAY I WANT TO DESCRIBE.
HOW BUILDING A WORK FORCE IS A
DIRE NEED THAT REQUIRES CONSTANT
TENDING?
BASED ON THE LITERATURE AND WHAT
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY SAID WE WANT
TO RECREATE THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE --
GOING TO LOOK LIKE OUR
POPULATION BUT THE MEDICAL
SCHOOLS ARE NOT -- HAVING
RESIDENT ARE HAVING MEDICAL
STUDENTS THAT COME INTO THEIR
SCHOOLS THAT MATCH OUR
POPULATION. ONE EXAMPLES LATINO
POPULATION WORDS ABOUT 60% IN
OUR AREA BUT ONLY ABOUT 15% OF
OUR RESIDENTS CURRENTLY AREN'T
FORTINO DESCENT.
WHAT THE WAY WE TRIED -- TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM IS BY.
EMPHASIZING TO OUR RESIDENTS
EVEN BEFORE THEY ARRIVE HOW
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IS GOING TO
BE A PRIORITY FOR US.
WE'VE BEEN EXACTING IN OUR
SELECTION PROCESS AND I WILL
TELL YOU IT DOES IN FACT HOW
EASY IT IS TO RECRUIT PEOPLE
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE REALIZING -- HOW WONDERFUL
IT IS TO DO THIS WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT OUR RESIDENTS ARE
COMPLETELY ENGAGED?
WE HAVE ABOUT I DON'T KNOW EIGHT
PROGRAMS AT LEAST WHERE
RESIDENTS HAVE REACHED OUT TO
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND OTHER EXPERTS.
SO ONE OF OUR PROGRAMS IS A
RESIDENT LET IT -- MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM FOR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS I'M ONE OF THE
UNIVERSITIES HERE IN FRESNO.
AND SHE HAS EIGHT STUDENTS
ENROLLED SHE'S ONLY BEEN WITH US
FOR TWO YEARS.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE HE'S BEEN
WORKING WITH THE PREMATURE US
INTO DERA HAS CREATED A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER PROGRAM
TO ADDRESS OBESITY PROBLEM.
FIND COULD PROVING HEALTH
LITERACY WITH NUTRITION AND
OBESITY WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE THAT
HAS SIX STUDENTS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN A TEACHING
KITCHEN TO LEARN HOW TO TEACH
THEMSELVES -- HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS
AND INEXPENSIVE MEALS.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER GROUP THAT
PUT ON A SYMPOSIUM FOR ABOUT THE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS FOR CHILDREN.
IN THE ADOLESCENT INJURIES TO
DISCUSS SOCIAL REPRINT ARE SORRY
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SO THIS IS JUST AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE ARE ALREADY CONNECTING
THIS COMMUNITY AND WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE -- WE ALREADY HAVE
ANOTHER CLASS STARTING THEIR
PROGRAMS.
I JUST BRAG ABOUT MY RESIDENCE
BECAUSE I REALLY DO THINK THAT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT FAR
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT.
TOTALLY AGREE THAT THE FROM A
TAURUS IS GONNA BE A BIG ASSET
AND I WANT OUR RESIDENTS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM.
I'M GOING TO TELL THE STORY GIVE
HER A LOT OF INFORMATION I JUST
WANT TO TELL THE STORY BECAUSE I
AM A PEDIATRIC GI DOCTOR ABOUT A
YOUNG PERSON.
TEENAGER WHO HAD.
D. I. BLEEDING FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS BY THE TIME SHE ARRIVED
TO THE CLINIC VISIT.
HER LACK OF ACCESS TO CARE
REALLY RESULTED IN AN ESCALATION
OF HER CARE SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED
FOR MANY WEEKS BECAUSE OF IT
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE ABLE TO MAKE
THE DIAGNOSIS VERY QUICKLY.
AND THEN WHEN SHE WAS DISCHARGED
THE INSURANCE PLAN DID NOT ALLOW
HER TO GET HER MEDICATION SHE
WAS BACK IN THE HOSPITAL.
THIS JUST SHOWS AGAIN HOW
IMPORTANT ACCESS TO CARE IS BUT
ALSO -- I THINK DR DALLY.
MADE A POIGNANT -- POINT TO SAY
THAT THE SENATE THE THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF THE
FULL FAMILY WAS AFFECTED.
AND LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT THE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS UNTIL WE FIND ONE OF
THE PARENTS HAS PASSED WAVE
OTHER TITLES IN THE HOSPITAL AND
THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT JUST AN OCCASIONAL
OCCURRENCE.
I ALSO WANT TO TELL THAT STORY
BECAUSE COMPLEX CARE IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE VALLEY
IT'S EASY FOR ME AS A
PEDIATRICIAN TO EMPHASIZE THAT
AND I TAKE CARE OF A LOT OF
CHILDREN WITH COMPLEX NEEDS.
BUT WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT THEM.
I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
WANT THE BEST DOCTORS.
WE WANT THE ONES THAT ARE GOING
TO THE BEST INSTITUTIONS AND I
KNOW FROM MY INSTITUTION WE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO RECRUIT DOES
BEST DOCTORS BUT IT TAKES A LOT
OF TIME.
SO WE CAN GROW THEM FROM OUR OWN
THAT'S IDEAL -- WE DON'T HAVE A
MEDICAL SCHOOL HERE YET BUT
THERE WILL EVEN BE BETTER --
WHEN I SAY THE BEST THESE
DOCTORS ARE TRAINING FOR MINIMUM
SIX YEARS FOR PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTIES AND FOR THE SURGEONS
SINCE? SIX TO TEN YEARS.
WE HAVE DOCTORS AT OUR
INSTITUTION THAT ARE ALSO
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THEY ARE -- MENTORING
STUDENTS ALONG THE WAY MENTORING
RESIDENCE AND I REALLY HAVE TO
EMPHASIZE WHAT I'VE SEEN IS THAT
THIS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
THIS WORK FORCE THAT'S WORKING
TOGETHER.
IS WHAT WILL BE OUR BEST BET FOR
RETENTION EVEN WHILE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET DOCTORS MONEY I
KNOW PEOPLE THINK WE ALWAYS WANT
MONEY BUT ACTUALLY WHAT I'VE
SEEN AND I CAN SPEAK TO IT FROM
THE MILITARY WHEN I WAS IN THE
MILITARY TO NOW.
THAT IS NOT WHAT KEEPS DOCTORS
DOING WHAT THEY DO EVERY DAY.
SO MY ASSESSMENT.
IN CONCLUSION WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
INTELLIGENT AND DRIVEN PEDIATRIC
WORKFORCE PROVIDERS THAT
REPRESENT THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES OF OUR GREAT CENTRAL
VALLEY.
WE NEED MORE PIPELINE PROGRAMS
TO ATTRACT AND SUPPORT THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS MANY OF
THEM -- ARE ASKING FOR SIMPLE
THINGS LIKE MENTORSHIP FOR
TAKING A BOARD EXAM IF YOU DON'T
HAVE GOOD SCORES YOU DON'T GET
INTO MEDICAL SCHOOL AND THE
LINGUISTIC AND CULTURAL --
BARRIERS ARE PRETTY SEVERE IN
THE VALLEY. FOR MEDICAL STUDENTS
WE NEED TO WE NEED CREATIVE
PROGRAMS TO ATTRACT THEM THE
PEDIATRICS I'M PART OF THE UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY COMMITTEE
OF ASSOCIATION PEDIATRIC PROGRAM
DIRECTORS FOR THE NATION.
AND ALL PROGRAMS IN PEDIATRICS
ARE REALLY HAVING A HARD TIME
DUE TO OUR CONCERNS A WORK LIFE
BALANCE AND SALARIES SOMETIMES
OF MEDICAL STUDENTS DON'T
REALIZE HOW WONDERFUL IT IS. FOR
PHYSICIANS IN ADDITION TO
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAMS
TO TRACK THEM TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO STAY.
I SUPPORT THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER ACADEMIC RESOURCES AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
MENTORING ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
SUPPORTED.
THE NEED IS NOW AND WE'RE READY
TO VOLUNTEER AND BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOROUGHNESS THE
FACT THAT YOU INCLUDED ACTUAL
RECOMMENDATIONS -- IN YOUR
PRESENTATION -- AS WELL AS YOUR
APPEARANCE AT THE TIME FRAME I
APPRECIATE THAT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND BACK TO GALLERY OF COURSE OF
OUR FIRST PANEL [INAUDIBLE]
DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S TIMES I'VE ACTUALLY
JUST WANNA.
ACKNOWLEDGE HOW LUCKY I AM TO BE
ON A PANEL WITH PEOPLE AND DR
FLORES WAS A HUGE INSPIRATION
FOR ME AND MENTORSHIP AND BEING
THE FIRST LATINO MEDICAL DOCTOR
WE'VE EVER ELECTED TO OUR STATE
WOULD NOT HAVE OCCURRED.
IF PEOPLE LIKE DR FLOORS HAD NOT
GIVEN.
SOME OF US A CHANCE ALONG THE
WAY SO I JUST WANT TO WELCOME
YOU TO THE PANEL AND WHAT AN
HONOR IT IS.
TO TAKE PART WITH YOU -- YOU
KNOW I I WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY
TALK ABOUT GROWING OUR OWN.
BECAUSE IN SOME WAYS THAT'S WHAT
YOU DID WITH ME.
AND I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
DOCTORS ACADEMY BECAUSE IT'S A
PROGRAM I WORKED WITH YOU ON
I'VE HAD SOME OF YOUR STUDENTS
WORK SIDE BY SIDE WITH ME IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND NOT ALL OF
THEM I KNOW WILL BECOME DOCTORS
BUT WILL BECOME A PART.
OF OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
[INAUDIBLE]
FAIR ENOUGH.
SO I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH DR
FLOORS ON HER DOCTORS ACADEMY.
AND HAVE HAD STUDENTS WHO HAVE
SHADOWED ME IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AND I'VE WORKED SIDE
BY SIDE WITH.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP IF I CAN
OFFLINE HOPEFULLY WITH THE HELP
OF MY SENATOR HERE. TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE'S A BUDGETARY ASK
WE CAN DO TO HELP TO SUPPORT
THOSE PATHWAY PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE LOOKING AT DOCTORS
ACADEMIES AS WELL AS H. COP.
AND I WOULD SPECIFICALLY LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP AS WELL SINCE I HAVE
THE FIRST COMMUNITY COLLEGE EVER
IN OUR STATE.
THE SECOND IN OUR NATION IN MY
BACKYARD AND A FEW BLOCKS FROM
MY HOME. TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN EXTEND THOSE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS WHO GO
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
BECAUSE AS WE TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHERE STUDENTS WHO ARE BLACK AND
BROWN OR GO.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE GOING TO
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
PROVIDING THOSE PATHWAY
OPPORTUNITIES WILL HELP US TO
DIVERSIFY OUR WORK FORCE GOING
FORWARD.
SO I REALLY JUST WANTED. TO PUT
A PIN IN THAT AND SEE IF WE
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH STAFF. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE PUTTING A
BUDGET ASK IN FRONT OF THE UP
ADMINISTRATION TO LOOK AT FOR
THE UPCOMING YEAR TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE COULD CONTINUE TO
DIVERSIFY.
BUT I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT COULD
DOCTOR LEMOND ABOUT NOT HAVING A
MEDICAL SCHOOL YET BECAUSE IT'S
COMING.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO DON'T KNOW WE'VE
WORKED HARD TO TRY TO BRING A
MEDICAL SCHOOL BACK TO THE
VALLEY.
AND THIS SEPTEMBER WE WILL HAVE
OUR FIRST COHORT OF STUDENTS
STARTING AT UCSF WHO WILL BE
TRAINED UP THERE.
BUT CALM DOWN TO THE VALLEY
AFTER THEIR FIRST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO DO THE REMAINDER OF
THEIR MEDICAL SCHOOL HERE IN
FRESNO.
THAT PATHWAY THAT ABILITY TEST.
HAVE THEM SEE OUR PATIENTS WHEN
THEY ARE MEDICAL STUDENTS.
OFTENTIMES INSPIRES THEM TO WANT
TO WORK WITH THAT PATIENT
POPULATION FOR BOTH RESIDENCIES
IN THEIR LIFE.
I KNOW I MADE A DIFFERENCE FOR
ME.
WANTING TO PRACTICE IN A
COMMUNITY LIKE THE ONE THAT I
KEEP.
BUT I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT IF I COULD.
THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR PRIME
PROGRAMS.
WHICH OFTENTIMES HAVE NOT BEEN
SUPPORTED FOLEY.
AND HAVE HELPED US TO DIVERSIFY
JUST TWO DAYS AGO I WAS TALKING
TO THE UC IRVINE PRIME STUDENTS.
AS THEY CAME UP TO OUR CAPITAL
TO DO SOME ADVOCACY.
AND I WAS IMPRESSED AT THE
QUALITY OF THE STUDENTS.
AND THE DIVERSITY THAT
OFTENTIMES WE DON'T SEE IN OUR
WORK FORCE THAT I DID NOT SEE IN
MY PRACTICE AS WELL.
SO FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT PRIME WOULD BE GREAT.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION THE BILL THAT WE WORKED
ON LAST YEAR WITH WORK FORCE
WITH INTERNATIONAL GRADUATE
RESIDENTS.
FOREIGN DOCTORS WHO HAVE BOTH
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCIES.
WE PLACED FIFTY OF THOSE DOCTORS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE SUPPORT AND SCALE THOSE
PROGRAMS.
AS A BILL I HAD LAST YEAR DID
WITH UCLA.
BUT WE OFTEN TIMES STRUGGLE IN.
HEALTH CARE IF WE DON'T FIRST
EMBRACE EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR GOVERNORS LEADERSHIP.
IN INCREASING ACCESS TO ALL
YOUNG ADULTS ALLOWS US TO START
TAKING CARE OF FAMILIES AS WELL.
AND WE HAVE TO BE THANKFUL AND
APPRECIATIVE.
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
WHILE WE HAVE A HEALTHCARE
GOVERNOR WHO CARES ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR ISSUES.
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO BE A PART OF
THIS PANEL AND JUST THANK THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR THIS
CONTINUED DISCUSSION ON
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AND
DIVERSIFICATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO FALL BY
CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU M. THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION ALL OF THAT IS.
REALLY CRITICAL FOR US MOVING
FORWARD AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
POLICY BUT I HAVE A CURIOSITY
AND I'M NOT SURE YOU'D BE ABLE.
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN.
YOU KNOW AS AN EDUCATOR -- I
TRIED REALLY HARD TO TO INSPIRE
MY STUDENTS TO GO IN DIFFERENT
AREAS OF NO MEDICINE ANOTHER
CAREER PATHS AND I KNOW ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WERE
FACING.
IS SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND I FOUND THAT.
INSTEAD OF INSPIRING OUR
CHILDREN TO WESTERN DIRECTION IT
KINDA DISCOURAGES THESE LONG
CAREER PATHS OF FOR EXAMPLE I
HEARD YOU SAY.
THAT FOR SPECIALTY IN MEDICINE
IS FROM SIX TO TEN YEARS AND SO
OUR CHILDREN OR STUDENTS ARE
HEARING HOW WE HAVE OVERNIGHT
MILLIONAIRES BECAUSE READER
BLOCKERS OR I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THERE'S BEEN.
SOME KIND OF AREA OF EXPLORATION
WHERE.
WE CAN REACH THESE KIDS THAT ARE
BEING BASICALLY RAISED BY SOCIAL
MEDIA AND TRENDS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE CAREER PATHS
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT THAT WE
CAN DO.
I CAN SHARE THAT TOM.
WE IN OUR PATHWAY PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA
AND UTILIZING SOCIAL MEDIA NOT
NECESSARY TO COUNTERACT WITH
THEIR HEARING FROM OTHERS BUT
RATHER TO INSPIRE.
ON THE W. M. C. ALSO IS USING
SOCIAL MEDIA -- TO OUTREACH TO
STUDENTS -- NOT NECESSARILY AT
THE BILLY YOUNG AGES BUT
CERTAINLY AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL
AND BEYOND IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE
THEM AND TO GET THEM. TO HELP
GUIDE THEM IN THE RIGHT PATH --
AND THERE ARE NATIONAL ARE W. J.
I JUST CAME BACK FROM A SITE
VISIT IN SEATTLE ARE W. J. --
FUNDS SHOULD HAVE PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE KINDA LIKE H. COP PROGRAMS
ONLY CONSOLIDATED DURING THE
SUMMER.
AND WE ALSO HAD A CONVERSATION --
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO ABOUT
UTILIZING SOCIAL MEDIA -- AT THE
STUDENT LEVEL AND IN FACT WE
ENGAGE THE STUDENTS IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT WE WERE
DOING WRONG BECAUSE THE
INTERESTING THING IS WE THINK
WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT THINGS.
AS PROFESSIONALS IN DEVELOPING
SOCIAL MEDIA BUT IF YOU DON'T
INCLUDE THE KIDS -- THAT WERE
DIRECTING IT.
TO IT MAY NOT BE NEARLY AS
USEFUL SO I GUESS I'M LONG
WINDED ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IS
ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SOCIAL MEDIA AT THE
KIDS PLACE WHERE THEY'RE COMING
FROM WHETHER IT BE.
IN AT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL OR THE
COLLEGE LEVEL ON TO GIVE THEM
THE REAL SCOOP AND ALSO TO TO
THE JOURNEY IS LONG.
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY -- SO MANY
AVENUES TO GET THERE AND SO MANY
LITTLE.
THINGS WAYS YOU CAN GO OUT AND
BACK -- THAT KIDS DON'T THINK
ABOUT AND PART OF THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLUG IS.
TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I JUST
WANNA JUST ADD -- IN TERMS OF
THE FUTURE I WOULD REALLY LOVE
IF YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS FURTHER
AND THE REASON I SAY THIS I KNOW
THAT.
AN ELEMENTARY LEVEL AND MANY
SCHOOLS ARE DOING THIS NOW WERE
WERE USING CODING AS PART OF THE
CURRICULUM.
SO NOW THEY'RE CREATING THESE
PROGRAMS WHEN THEY'RE LIKE YOU
KNOW EIGHT YEARS OLD NINE YEARS
OLD AND I'M THINKING IN TERMS OF
THE FUTURE.
THAT'S NOW PART OF THE
CURRICULUM AND I THINK WE MAY BE.
PUSHING OUR KIDS TO GO DOWN THAT
THE DIRECTION OF OF PROGRAMMERS
AND COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY AND AND
SO THAT'S PART OF THE CURRICULUM
SO IF THERE'S ANY WAY.
IN THE FUTURE THEY HAVE IDEAS
WERE WE CAN BRIDGE.
THAT GAP AND ALSO INCLUDES THESE
TYPE OF A CAREERS EARLIER ON AT
THE OPEN TO HEAR HIMSELF THINK
KIA.
USER TO GALGIANI THE QUESTION
WAS ASKED EARLIER ABOUT WHAT WE
COULD DO TO MOVE ALONG AT A
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN IN THE BUDGET --
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER THE MCO DEAL WHERE WE
RECEIVED ONE POINT EIGHT FIVE
FIVE MILLION FOR THE THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGETS IT'S
SO WAS A TWO YEAR PLAN.
AND IT WAS TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR FORTY EIGHT NEW STUDENTS IN
THE PROGRAM IN MEDICAL EDUCATION
THE PRIME PROGRAM SO SINCE THAT
MONEY IS GONE NOW IF WE WERE TO
REINVEST IN THAT THAT WOULD GIVE
US.
A GOOD BASIS TO MOVE FORWARD --
WE KNEW WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO
BRING A SCHOOL OF MEDICINE HE'S
EVER SAID.
THAT BY THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN WE WOULD HAVE A
STATEWIDE SHORTAGES SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND POSITIONS IN THE STATE.
AND NOW AT AROUND TWO THIRDS OF
OUR PHYSICIANS ARE OVER THE AGE
OF FIFTY FIVE SO WE ARE.
ARE FACED WITH THE SILVER
TSUNAMI OF ALL OF OUR PHYSICIANS
RETIRING IF WE'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT GOING
FORWARD SO I THINK THERE'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
PRIME -- FOR BOTH FRESNO AND
MERCED TO ADDRESS OUR STATEWIDE
ISSUE.
I THINK THAT -- AS WE AS THE
STATE LOOKS AT PURSUING THE MCO
TAX AND AND WE BEGIN OUR KIND OF
PARKING LOT LIST OF OF ITEMS WE
HOPE IT WILL FUND.
WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL OF HOW
THOSE DOLLARS WERE SPENT.
DR RANDALL I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
HOLD ON TO YOUR QUESTION IS I'M
GOING TO I'M DRIVING THE TRAIN
AND I WANT TO GET OUR SECOND
PANEL UP.
AND THERE'S A QUESTION OR
STATEMENT NO IT WAS MORE OF A
THANK YOU TO DR.
KELLY AND THE CALUMET WORK FORCE
AS WELL AS THE CAL HEALTH CARE'S
TWO NEW PROGRAMS YOU GOT UP AND
RUNNING THIS YEAR THAT WE ARE
HELP SO EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT THE GALLEY LET ME
JUST SAY VERY QUICKLY AS I
LISTEN TO ALL OF THE COMMENTS
AND WE RECOGNIZE WHAT THE STATE
HAS DONE HASN'T DONE AREAS THAT
WE WE STEPPED UP -- ONCE OUR OUR
GENERAL FUND WAS BACK IN THE
BLACK AND WE WERE NO LONGER
BROKE.
AND CUTTING PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
IN MAKING COMMUNITY COLLEGE FREE.
AND WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE ADDRESS
MEDICAL SCHOOL DEBT.
BECAUSE AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
POPULATIONS WE WANNA -- REACH
OUT TO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S A
REALITY IN TERMS OF EVEN HOW YOU
WRAP YOUR HEAD AROUND HOW YOU
COULD AFFORD MEDICAL SCHOOL.
THE OTHER TWO QUICK COMMENTS I'M
GONNA MAKE A MISSILE PUT HIM OUT
THERE -- MODELING NECESSARILY
EXPECT ANSWERS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE.
YOU KNOW SYSTEMIC BIAS AND THE
IMPACT IT HAS ON POOR CHILDREN
CHILDREN OF COLOR.
YOU KNOW -- I WONDER WHAT ROLE
PROP TWO OH NINE PLAYED IN
IMPACTING MED SCHOOL DIVERSITY
IN OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED MED
SCHOOLS AS FEW AS THEY ARE --
BUT BUT WE DIDN'T HELP MATTERS
WITH PROP.
TWO OH NINE AS WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE TO HEAR
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT IMPLICIT
BIAS HOUSE ON THE HEALTHCARE.
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
THOSE OF US WHO EXPERIENCE THAT
WE HAVE TO BE MINDFUL OF OF WHAT
MESSAGE WE SENT AS A STATE.
ON WITH THE PASSAGE OF TWO OH
NINE THE OTHER PIECE I WOULD
WOULD DROP.
IS.
WITH REGARD TO THE UC SYSTEM AS
WELL AND I WASN'T AWARE THIS IT
WAS MY OWN HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
WHO IS A UC DAVIS ALONE WHO
BROUGHT IT TO MY ATTENTION THE
FORM OF A QUESTION.
WHICH IS WHY THE UC SYSTEM AND
AND AND YOUR HOSPITALS DON'T
ACCEPT MEDICARE -- FROM HIS
PERSPECTIVE HE SAYS YOU KNOW
YOU'RE PUBLICLY FUNDED
INSTITUTION AND YET IF YOU'RE
NOT A PART OF THE MEDICARE
SYSTEM AND SO I DON'T EXPECT YOU
ALL TO TO ANSWER THAT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE JUST
LAID OUT THERE.
FOR PUBLIC CONSUMPTION --
BECAUSE AS WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE
WE'VE A SYSTEM THAT MEETS ALL
NEEDS AS WE ARE BEING ASKED TO
PUT PUBLIC FUNDS INTO THE SYSTEM
TO EXPAND -- THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND AND YOU SEE
HEALTH SYSTEMS ACROSS THE BOARD
I THINK WE IT WOULD BE FAIR TO
EXPECT THAT THE UC STEP UP ALSO.
IN TERMS OF BEING -- MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS AND SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THAT WE HAVE TO DO THE
NURSE PRACTITIONERS FULL SCOPE I
STILL HAVE MISSING TEETH FROM A
BILL I. KERRY SCOPE OF WORK -- I
HEAR YOU WHEN I GET IN THE MAKES
PERFECT SENSE AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY.
THERE TENDS TO BE A LITTLE
COMPETITION -- AND SO I THINK --
I'VE HEARD THE BILL COMING I. I
LOOK FOR TO US TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT
MAKES SENSE IN OUR EFFORT TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THAT THAT HEALTHCARE AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL IS HIGH QUALITY
YES ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
AND CERTAINLY EXPANDING THE WORK
THAT NURSE PRACTITIONERS -- DO
MAKE PERFECT SENSE ANY FINAL
QUICK COMMENTS BEFORE WE YES
JUST LIKE OUR IMPLICIT BIAS --
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY PROP TO
ATTEND HEY HUGE.
IMPACT ON THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS
SEES AT UC SCHOOLS.
AND OVER TIME WE'VE GRADUALLY --
FOUND WAYS TO OVERCOME THAT --
OBVIOUSLY WE STILL HAVE A LOT
MORE TO DO -- BUT I DID WANT TO
ASK THE PANEL TO CONSIDER
LOOKING AT SOMETHING YOU'VE GOT
A BIG RESEARCH TEAM UP AT THE
CAPITOL -- I WOULD BE VERY
INTERESTED FOR YOU TO EXPLORE
[INAUDIBLE]
THE NUMBER.
ANTHONY UC FACULTY I'D.
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THAT -- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT IT WHO'S BEEN
ACCEPTED INTO OUR UC SCHOOLS OF
MEDICINE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
GRADUATES FROM CSU CAMPUSES
VERSUS GRADUATE FROM UC CAN'T --
UC CAMPUSES.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT THOSE
STATISTICS AND LET'S TALK ABOUT
HOW TO INCREASE THE NUMBERS OF
C. S. U. GRADS WHO -- MAY BE.
GETTING AN THIS ALL STOP THEIR
POINT WELL TAKEN THE POINT WELL
TAKEN.
WITH THAT WE WANT TO THANK OUR
FIRST PANEL.
VERY HELPFUL INFORMATION WE
APPRECIATE YOU WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION [INAUDIBLE] ONE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION NOW TO
OUR SECOND PANEL THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF WELL BEING FOR
CHILDREN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND WE HAVE FOUR PALACE WHEN
ACTUALLY COME FORWARD.
NOW WE ARE CLEAR THAT THESE
PANELS COULD HAVE BEEN TEN
PEOPLE WE COULD HAVE TALK FOR A
WEEK -- THAT WASN'T.
FEASIBLE AND SO -- WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FOLKS TO TOUCH ON IN
A PARTICULAR AREAS OF INTEREST
AND IT'S UP TO ALL OF US TO TO
CHALLENGE THEIR THEORY
CHALLENGER METHODOLOGY.
HAVE A BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT -- THE ISSUES AT HAND SIR
GONNA FIGHT THE NEXT PANEL COME
ON FORWARD DON'T BE SHY.
IT'S GOT A MOVER OVER YEAH THERE
WE GO.
AS THEY'RE GETTING SITUATED.
LET ME GO AHEAD WITH THEIR BRIEF
FILES AGAIN THEY'RE MORE
EXTENSIVE FILES AVAILABLE TO YOU
AT YOUR REGISTRATION THAT --
TABLE FIRST WE'VE GOT SANDRA
CELADON THE PRESIDENCY OR FRESNO
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES THE
SLOWDOWN HAS HAD EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE WORK IN THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THAT A PROGRAM MANAGER
AT CLINICAL SIERRA VISTA.
WHERE SHE DEVELOPED A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS?
LESLIE MARTINEZ LESLIE MARTINEZ
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MISS MARTINEZ IS
FROM TWO LAYER ACCOUNTING.
GRADUATE FROM UC BERKELEY.
ON SCHOOL PUBLIC POLICY AND NOW
LEADS POLICY ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING IN FRESNO
COUNTY.
WE HAVE LANGFANG PROGRAM MANAGER
THE NEIGHBORHOOD RESOURCE STERN
FRESNO CENTEREDNESS FANG AS
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF THE BONE COMMUNITY SHE
HAS A MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK AND
M. IN COUNCIL IN EDUCATION.
AND FINALLY AMERICA HERNANDEZ
THIS FERNANDES IS THE SOCIAL
SERVICES COORDINATOR AT KIDS IN
NEED OF DEFENSE ALSO KNOWN AS
KIND MS HERNANDEZ IS ALSO AN
IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO WHO WAS
RAISED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HE'S A RECIPIENT OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S DEFERRED ACTION PROGRAM
HEY I WRITE WHICH IS ALLOWED HER
TO LEGALLY WORK IN THE COUNTRY.
MR AMANDA SAYS THE BASSES DEGREE
IN CHICANO LATIN AMERICAN
STUDIES AND MINORS IN ENGLISH
AND SPANISH WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED WITH MISS
CELADON -- YOU KNOW WHAT GIRL
POWER [INAUDIBLE]
YES THAT.
WE ROLL ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THAT'S HOW WE ROLL.
CELADON THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US THANK YOU I'M SO HAPPY AT
JOIN ALL MY COLLEAGUES TODAY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A HASH TAG WHICH
IS WOMEN LEADING THE VALLEY.
WITHOUT HITTING IN ONE WOMEN
LEADING THE VALLEY WOMEN LEAVE
THE VALLEY THAT MAKES YOU STAND
THAT I WILL DO THAT ON MY
TWITTER WOMEN LEAVE THE VALLEY.
SO I'M SO EXCITED TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH I WE KNOW
THAT THEY'VE LONG BEEN
RECOGNIZED BUT THEIR IMPORTANCE
IS OFTEN OVERLOOKED.
IT HAS BEEN WELL OVER A DECADE
SINCE LITERATURE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
BEGAN TO RISE IN PREVALENCE
GLOBALLY SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR MOST
CHILDHOOD ILLNESSES AND DEATH IN
FRESNO COUNTY CHILDREN ARE THREE
POINT TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE HOSPITALIZED.
DUE TO PREVENTABLE CONDITIONS
SUCH AS RESPIRATORY ILLNESS TOO
MANY OF US HAVE EXPERIENCE
DRIVING OUR CHILD TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM DUE TO AS MY
RELATED COMPLICATIONS WHICH
ACCOUNT FOR OVER. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR -- INGESTED
FRESNO COUNTY ALONE.
CHILDREN I'M IN OTHER REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT SEEN -- QUITE
THE NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS
AS THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND FRESNO
AND WE KNOW THAT PARTLY THESE
CONDITIONS ARE DUE TO THE
CONDITIONS OF THE HOMES WHERE
OUR CHILDREN LIVE.
AND THE NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
THESE HOMES ARE SITUATED WE'VE
HEARD TIME AND TIME AGAIN ISSUES
OF MILDEW AND HOUSING PROXIMITY
OF NEIGHBORHOODS TO ROADWAY TEN
MAJOR ROADWAYS AND OTHER
POLLUTING SOURCES.
IT'S NOT A SECRET THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF HEAVY INDUSTRY USES
IN FRESNO COUNTY AND PRESENT THE
CITY OF FRESNO IS CLUSTERED IN
WEST FRESNO HE WANTS RED LINE
COMMUNITY THAT IS OUR
TRADITIONAL HOME FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND THEN IN THE FORTIES AND
FIFTIES BECAME THE PLACE FOR
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS WERE -- WERE.
FORCED TO LIVE IN WE KNOW THAT
AND CAL LARA WHICH WAS ALSO ONCE
A RED LINE COMMUNITY BUT IT WAS
THE OPPOSITE IT WAS PRIMARILY IT
WAS AN ALL WHITE COMMUNITY.
UP UNTIL THE CITY OF FRESNO
STARTED TO ANNEX THE SURROUNDING
LAND AND PURSES OWNED IT FOR
HEAVY INDUSTRY USES AND SO OVER
TIME WE SEE TODAY NOW HOW WAS
HOME 280%.
LATINO COMMUNITIES MOST --
COMMUNITIES ARE MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS.
AND SO AS WE KNOW -- WHERE YOU
LIVE WORK LEARN AND PLAY HAS A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON NOT ONLY HOW
YOU LIVE BUT HOW LONG YOU LIVE
WE ALL KNOW THE FACT THAT WEST
RESONANCE LIVE TWENTY YEARS LESS
THAN THEIR NORTH FRESNO
COUNTERPARTS?
THAT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
THIS IS BECAUSE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS INSERT.
EXERT THEIR INFLUENCE ON CHILD
HEALTH THREE COMPLEX
INTERRELATED --
INTERRELATIONSHIP OF MORE DISTAL
SOCIAL FACTORS SUCH AS INCOME
AND EDUCATION WITH MORE PROXIMAL
FACTORS SUCH AS HEALTH BEHAVIORS
WHICH ARE HIGHLY INFLUENCED BY
YOUR BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
WE KNOW THAT 52% OF RESIDENTS IN
THE CITY OF FRESNO DO NOT LIVE
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE OF A
QUALITY PARK THEREFORE LIMITING
THEIR ABILITY TED AND ENGAGE IN
PLAY.
AND EXERCISE AND AND OTHER
HEALTH CONDUCIR BEHAVIORS WE
KNOW THAT CHILDREN WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY OUT DURING
GREENSPACE OPPORTUNITIES DO
BETTER IN MATH AND SCIENCE SO AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR HEALTH
SECTOR WE'RE SETTING UP OUR
CHILDREN TO FAIL.
BUT JUST THE FACT THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A QUALITY
GREEN SPACE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THE WAYS
BY WHICH SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
BEAR THEIR INFLUENCE OPERATE
OVER TIME AND ACROSS GENERATIONS.
CREATING GREATER DISPARITIES
WITH EACH GENERATION THAT GOES
BY.
IT SHOULD BE THE OPPOSITE WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO COME TO
THIS COUNTRY IMMIGRANTS COME
HERE FOR OPPORTUNITY.
RIGHT THAT WE WANT TO SEE OUR
CHILDREN SUCCEED AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE SYSTEMS THAT
WE SET UP IN OUR COMMUNITY ARE
ACTUALLY CREATING THE OPPOSITE
CONDITIONS THAT ENABLE ACTUALLY
OUR CHILDREN. TO END UP IN
PRISON YES YOU ARE THE SCHOOL TO
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE IS
REAL. 70% OF STUDENTS ARE
INVOLVED IN IN SCHOOL ARRESTS
ARE BLACK OR LATINO.
KEEP THAT IN MIND SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHY WE DON'T DO
NOT HAVE FOLKS THAT LOOK LIKE
GUYS TREATING US AT THE HOSPITAL
EDUCATING US IN OUR SCHOOLS
RIGHT SITTING ON PANEL SUCH AS
THIS.
ONE IS BECAUSE WE'RE BREAKING A
PRIME INDICATOR OF SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND THAT
SOCIAL COHESION.
WERE FRAGMENTING THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT OUR CHILDREN
ARE ABLE TO HAVE WITH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY AND OVERALL WITH OUR
SOCIETY.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE
ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS WE
KNOW THAT THERE PROFOUNDLY
INFLUENCED BY SOCIAL AND
POLITICAL DECISIONS WHICH ARE
WELL BEYOND THE CONTROL OF
PARENTS.
AN INDIVIDUAL PEDIATRICIANS ARE
PROVIDERS SOCIETIES WE CAN
PROTECT CHILDREN AGAINST THE
ADVERSE EFFECTS OF SOCIAL
DISADVANTAGE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AT
PRESENT A BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WHICH WAS FOUNDED BY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND FRESNO TO
FOSTER AND ENCOURAGE THRIVING
COMMUNITIES WHERE ALL.
AND WE MEAN ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES CAN LIVE HEALTHY SAFE
AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING AT THIS FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS TO ADDRESS THESE
COMPLEX SYSTEMS AND POLICIES
THAT CONSTRAINT 38% OF CHILDREN
IN FRESNO COUNTY. TO LIVE IN
POVERTY. 38% OF OUR CHILDREN IN
FRESNO COUNTY LIVE IN POVERTY.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
GOALS OF FRESNO BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WE INVITE YOU TO
JOIN ME AS IN OUR COALITION --
BECAUSE THEY ARE BROUGHT THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE AND THERE ARE THEY
ARE ABSOLUTELY AMBITIOUS THEY
SPAN A WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES THAT
REFLECT AN UNDERLYING BELIEVE
THAT SOCIETAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
FACTORS ALL TOGETHER HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS A WHOLE.
AND SO WE CALL IN OUR DECISION
MAKERS AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
ALL SYSTEMS WE CALL ON COMMUNITY
LEADERS YOUTH AND ELDERS TO JOIN
US AND ADDRESSING THE
LONGSTANDING HISTORY OF RACISM
IN OUR HOUSING POLICY.
WE CAN START BY IMPLEMENTING
RENTER PROTECTIONS ARE PROMOTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS WITH
MONEY TO BACK IT.
IN NEIGHBORHOODS OF OPPORTUNITY
THREE INCLUSIONARY ZONING AND
ANTI DISPLACEMENT POLICIES.
BY PROMOTING AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE AND
OUTDOOR RECREATION AND REQUIRING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PARKS AND
OTHER OUTDOOR SPACES AND HEALTHY
PLACES IN OUR COMMUNITIES. FOR
WEST PRESENCE SHOULD NOT HAVE A
REGIONAL PARK BUILT ON A
LANDFILL.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE TO BREATHE
CLEAN AIR EVEN THE AIR THAT WE
BREATHE IN OUR COMMUNITY IS NOT
EQUAL WE KNOW THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS THE WORST AIR
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN
THE NATION.
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR TREE
CANOPY WHERE WE PROMOTE GREEN
SPACE LIKE TREES THERE'S A HUGE
STAFF DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOUTH
AND NORTH FRESNO.
AND SO TODAY I AM HERE WITH OUR
PANELISTS TO INVITE ALL OF YOU
TO CONTINUE TO ELIMINATE POVERTY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY BY DIVERSE
DEFINING OUR ECONOMY SO THERE
WERE NO LONGER RELYING.
ON INDUSTRIES THAT EXPLOIT THE
LABOR OF PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT IN
FACT VALUE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT WE EACH ME.
AND VALUE ARE INHERENT IN A
HUMAN VALUE JUST BEING PEOPLE
AND OF COURSE EXPANDING ACCESS
TO HEALTHCARE WE'VE MADE LONG
STRIDES BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT BE INCLUSIVE
UNTIL ALL COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE AND NOTED
THAT I DID NOT SAY HEALTH
INSURANCE I MEAN HAIR.
AND OF COURSE SHIFTING OUR
POLICING CULTURE FROM A
REACTIONARY.
REACTIONARY MODEL TO ONE THAT
PROTECTS AND VALUES LIVES IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK TO OUR
COMMUNITY PULLED A COMMUNITY
POLICING MODEL NOT JUST IN
FRESNO.
BUT IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WORKS WITH COMMUNITIES VIA
COOPERATIVE RELATIONSHIPS AND
MEASURABLE SHARED GOALS AND
OUTCOMES WE HAVE TO BREAK THAT
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT SUPPORT
AND SUSTAIN THEIR HEALTH.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THAT
WE'RE GONNA CHEAPER TRULY OLD IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
HELLO OKAY COOL HI US SO HI MY
NAME IS LESLIE MARTINEZ -- I AM
FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BORN
AND RAISED IN FROM A SMALL TOWN
CALLED LINDA CALIFORNIA SO A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT ARE ALSO THINGS
THAT I HAVE GONE THROUGH.
IN MY ACTUAL LIFE GROWING UP I
WORK AT LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND COUNT ABILITY WERE
BASED HERE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
BUT I I WILL NOT LOSE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO MENTION OUR
WORK IN THE EAST COACHELLA
VALLEY.
THAT HAS VERY SIMILAR -- ISSUES
AS THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THROUGH COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
RESEARCH.
LEGAL REPRESENTATION AND POLICY
ADVOCACY WE GUIDE.
POLICY ON THE LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATE LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS THAT WE WORK ALONGSIDE
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD AND THE
PRIORITIES ARE MET SPECIFICALLY
ALWAYS AROUND HEALTH.
THE OUR OUR WORK.
IS POWERED AND IT ALWAYS UNDER
THE NOTION THAT YOU CANNOT
SEPARATE CLIMATE CHANGE YOU
CAN'T SEPARATE LAND USE.
THE PRISON PIPELINE ANY OF THESE
THINGS HOW ARE ALSO GUIDE ARE
ALSO PART OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
ISSUE YOU CAN NOT WE CANNOT JUST
TACKLE ONE AND EXPECT THE REST
TO FALL INTO PLACE WE HAVE TO DO
IT IN A TOGETHER.
THE CHILDREN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY OF YOU AS YOU ALL KNOW
AND A LOT OF US HERE.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE HAVE HIGHER RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES THAN ANYWHERE ELSE WE
LIVE NEXT TO TOXIC -- MEET
RENDERING PLANTS AND WE SMELL
BAD AIR AND WE BREATHE IT AND
YET WE'RE STILL AT TRACK
PRACTICE EVERY SINGLE DAY --
SPECIFICALLY THE KIDS AT
ANDERSON WHO I SEE EVERY SINGLE
MORNING RUNNING -- IN CANNES TWO
CREEK WHICH IS I..
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND BILL HAD
MENTIONED THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY RULE CAN TO
A CREEK IS ONE HOUR AWAY FROM
THE NEAREST HOSPITAL.
CAN TO A CREEK -- THAT HOSPITAL
IS NOT IN FRESNO COUNTY IT'S
ACTUALLY KINGS COUNTY IT'S IN
HANFORD -- WHEN WE MOST
COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE A QUARREL
ACCESS TO PARKS ED THERE?
AND THE WORST PART IS THAT THEY
USE THEIR THEY TRY EVERY SINGLE
DAY THEY ADVOCATE TO HAVE
TRANSPORTATION THE ADVOCATE.
FOR RESOURCES TO COME INTO THEIR
COMMUNITY -- I THINK I HAVE I
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO BACK UP
MY WHOLE NARRATIVE SO I THINK
THE FIRST THING WE REALLY WANT
TO FOCUS ON IS THE CLIMATE RIGHT
WE NEED CLIMATE RESILIENCY
DOLLARS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WE NEED TO TARGET THOSE.
HERE AND IN THESE COACHELLA
VALLEY THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES WE'VE ALL
SEEN HOW SUCCESSFUL IT HAS BEEN
IN THE CITY OF FRESNO BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THAT
THOSE DOORS AREN'T AVAILABLE TO
CAN TO AGREE.
THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE TO LIVE
THERE THOSE ARE DOLLARS THAT
NEED TO COME TO THE COMMUNITIES
ARE FACING CLIMATE CHANGE HAD ON
M. SENATOR DOUBLES AS BE.
THREE FIFTY ONE ED IT WOULD MAKE
IT WOULD MAKE EXPLICIT THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO FOR
THE FUNDING BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
HAVE MORE INVESTMENTS THAN JUST
TCC WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR
INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE THE KIDS
CAN GET TO SCHOOL.
KIDS CAN GET TO THE DOCTOR.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SO MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES FOLKS
CANNOT GO OUT FOR A WALK IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THERE'S A
SCHOOL IN MADERA COUNTY LAVIGNE.
THEIR SCHOOL IS LESS THAN A MILE
AWAY IT'S A FIFTEEN MINUTE WALK
IF CHILDREN ARE SEEN WALKING TO
SCHOOL OR RIDING A BIKE THEY
WILL BE SUSPENDED FOR THREE TO
FIVE DAYS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO THE IT IS
UNSAFE TO WALK TO SCHOOL SO THEY
HAVE TO BE BUSTED.
AND I'VE TALKED TO KIDS IN THERE
LIKE A PLEASE JUST LET US.
PLEASE HELP US SO WE CAN RIDE
OUR BIKES TO SCHOOL THAT'S ALL
WE WANT AND THEY CANNOT -- AND
YOU KNOW WHAT ON TOP OF THIS WE
ALSO REALLY NEED AGGRESSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WATER.
WE ALL KNOW WE'RE VERY FIRST
COMMANDING EVERYBODY FOR PASSING
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER -- CENTER HOTEL FOR YOUR A
DIRECT INVESTMENT TOMBSTONE I
HAVE COMMUNITY MEETINGS THERE
ALL THE TIME AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED AND WE THINK YOU -- BUT
WE NEED MORE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT GROUND WATER IS GOING
TO BE THERE FOREVER THAT IT'S
NOT JUST GOING TO GO TO THE
SELECT FEW THAT CAN AFFORD IT
WITH -- WATER MARKETS WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THAT WATER IS GOING
TO BE CLEAN THAT'S GOING TO BE
FOR FREE OF CONTAMINANTS WE KNOW
THAT PESTICIDES CONTAMINATE THE
WATER IN FRESNO WE NEED TO FIX
THAT AND WE CAN DO THAT.
I'M AIR QUALITY WE WE SANDRA
POINTED OUT PRETTY WELL WE ALL
LIVE IN IN A TOXIC BUBBLE WE
DON'T HAVE PLACES WHERE WE CAN
GO OUTSIDE EMBRY THERE I'VE SEEN.
SO MANY TALK TO SO MANY PARENTS
WHO THEIR KIDS HAVE ASTHMA
ATTACKS AND THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I HAD THE MY COWORKER HER SON
COULD NOT GO TO A FIELD TRIP
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE HIS ASTHMA
WOULD BE TRIGGERED AND HE WAS
UNABLE TO GO TO A FIELD TRIP.
THAT EVERY OTHER KID IN HIS
CLASS WAS GOING.
TO WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE LAND USES
THAT ARE CONTAMINATING OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND OUR SCHOOLS WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE DAIRIES.
THAT ARC OF FEELING OUR FILLING
OUR COMMUNITIES WITH METHANE AND
WITH THE DERRY DIGESTERS ARE
ONLY TAKING CARE OF THE METHANE
BUT THERE'S ALSO KNOCKS INBOX
ANOTHER SECONDARY POLLUTION'S
THAT ARE HURTING COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE THAT WORK ON THAT.
ON THAT DAY -- WE NEED TO INSURE
THAT COMMUNITY THAT -- CALL WE
NEED TO SOLVE AIR QUALITY ISSUES.
IN A WAY THAT IS NOT ON THE
BACKS OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE
CANNOT SOLVE ANY ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA ANY LONGER BUY ONLY
ADDRESSING IT IN A WAY IT BY
DRESSING IN WAYS THAT DOES NOT.
DIRECTLY INVEST AND HELP THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
ALL OF THESE ISSUES INCLUDING
AIR QUALITY -- SIR -- BUT I KNOW
AND I ALSO WANTED TO TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ON A POINT THAT
XANDER MADE I'M A DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS M. DAUGHTER FARM
WORKING IMMIGRANTS AND THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
AND I I I KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE
HERE TODAY AND WATCHING HAVE
FELT THIS BUT THERE'S NOTHING
WORSE THAN WATCHING YOUR PARENTS
COME HOME FROM A TEN HOUR WORK
DAY.
COVERED IN DIRT.
AND THEIR PAYCHECK DOES NOT
REFLECT WHAT WORK THEY PUT OUT.
IT THERE ISN'T AND I AND I SURE
THIS BECAUSE WE CANNOT CONTINUE
TO DO THIS WE NEED TO FIND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN A WAY THAT
HELPS US GROW.
IN A WAY THAT KIDS CAN KIDS CAN
GO TO BERKELEY AND IT'S NOT OH
MY GOSH IT'S YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT ALL ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT LEÓN THESE ALL
ABOUT THAT'S WHAT LYNN LYNN
THERE CAN DO -- TO BECAUSE IT
WHEN WE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
TIME YOUR PARENTS AND HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY MILK.
AND YOU THINK ABOUT THE TIMES
THAT YOUR PARENTS HAD TO
SCRAMBLE AND ASK SOMEBODY DOWN
THE STREET FOR MONEY TO TAKE YOU
TO THE DOCTOR BECAUSE YOU ARE
SICK AND HAVE A FEVER OF A
HUNDRED AND THREE DEGREES.
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED TO ME
WHEN I WAS IN FOURTH GRADE.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
ISSUE AND THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO DIRECT INVESTMENT A
LOT BETTER AND THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN EAST COULD
TELL ABOUT.
WE ARE THE HARDEST WORKING
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WILL NOT BACK
DOWN FROM THAT STATEMENT BRING
IT ON BUT WE NEED.
WE NEED GOOD INVESTMENTS TODAY
WE NEEDED THEM YESTERDAY AND I'M
NOT AND AT THE SAME TIME AS I
GIVE YOU THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
I'M ALSO HERE TO HELP YOU ALONG
THE WAY.
I AM HERE TO LOBBY I'M HERE TO
WORK HARD I WILL DO WHAT IT
TAKES TO MAKE MY HOMETOWN MY
HOME MIKE LITERALLY LIKE MY
FAVORITE PLACE IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
THE BEST PLACE EVER SO PEOPLE
STOP CALLING IT THE FLYOVER
COUNTY.
OF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY WE TALK ABOUT IS THAT
THOSE GUYS THE NECKY -- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL.
GOOD MORNING WELL I GUESS IS
CLOSER TO GOOD AFTERNOON -- I
JUST WANT TO SAY BEFORE I START
I AND APPRECIATIVE AND HUMBLE TO
BE UP HERE.
THE AMAZING WORK THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY HONESTLY I WAS
SITTING IN MY C. AND I CHOKED UP.
I THINK WE ARE HERE BECAUSE ROTH
PASSIONATE.
ABOUT THESE THINGS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO US.
BUT WATCHING EVERYONE SPEAK
ABOUT IT.
MADE ME FEEL GOOD. ONE SO I'M
ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY FROM SAN
DIEGO -- I AM A PROGRAM MANAGER
RIGHT NOW AT THE FRESNO CENTER.
BUT I CAME HERE BECAUSE I WAS
THE RECIPIENT OF THE WAS THAT
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE.
I CAME A PARTICULARLY TO OFFER
SERVICES -- IN MENTAL HEALTH
AMONG.
ARMONK POLITICIAN.
AND I'M SORRY I MONNING
POPULATION EXCUSE ME SO I
APOLOGIZE I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS --
THERE'S A IT REALLY SPEAKS TO
VOICING US TO WRITE SO THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT FOR A LONG TIME
HISTORICALLY HAD HAD NO VOICE.
SO WHEN WE SET UP HERE OUR
VOICES TRAUMA.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WAITING SO
LONG TO SEE STUFF.
I WAS VERY PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE LIVING
WELL PROGRAM AND ACTUALLY THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR IS HERE TODAY
HE'S TRANSLATING.
DOCTOR D. AS LONG.
AND DURING MY TIME THERE WE
DIDN'T NOTICE FOR REALLY
PREDOMINANT DIAGNOSES.
ET IS D. MAJOR DEPRESSIVE
DISORDER PERSISTENT DEPRESSIVE
DISORDER AND GENERALIZED EXCITED
DISORDER.
IT'S A BIG DEAL THE MAJORITY OF
THE CLIENTS WE C. R. MONOLINGUAL
SOUTHEAST ASIAN.
THEY COULDN'T SIX SERVICES.
ANYWHERE ELSE FOR WHEN THE SCOTT
SERVICES THAT COUNTY MAYBE THEY
FELT MORE COMFORTABLE WITH US.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY WANT TO
KEEP TALKING ABOUT AND ECHOING
AS THE IMPORTANCE OF OFFERING --
LINGUISTIC AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S WORKING.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE TOOK IT
UPON OURSELVES.
WITH DOCTORS WRONG AS THE SPEAR
HEAD WAS CREATING A TRAINING
PROGRAM.
SO I WAS LUCKY TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM TO BE ABLE.
TO ONE OFFER MY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN LONG.
ALSO BE ABLE TO BE SUPERVISED BY
CLINICAL AND LICENSED MON
CLINICIANS.
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE --
THAT'S MISSING.
I HAVE TO MAN AFTER I LEFT IT
HAS.
GIVEN ME A DIFFERENT LINES WHEN
I APPROACH OUR CLIENTS.
I REALLY WANT TO REITERATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GROWING OUR OWN.
MAYBE PERHAPS WE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WAS OUT THERE SO WE
RECENTLY KNEW THAT WE NEEDED TO
HELP WE NEEDED IT TODAY.
AND SO WE BEGAN THIS TRAINING
PROGRAM VERY.
YEAH STILL HUMBLE -- AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE A PART OF IT -- I DO
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
FUNDING AROUND THESE THINGS.
SO MY LAST TWO THINGS THAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS JUST. ONE
PLEASE SUPPORT DISAGGREGATED
DATA FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
HEALTH AGENCIES.
HISTORICALLY THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY HAS BEEN.
COUPLE TOGETHER BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT WE WEREN'T ABLE TO SEE THE
TRUE NEED OF SOME OF OUR
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COUNTERPARTS.
THEIR NEED IS JUST UNIQUE AT THE
VERY LEAST THE MALL COMMITTEE
ONLY CAME HERE FORTY YEARS AGO.
MY PARENTS STILL SPEAK ONLY LONG.
AND EVEN WHEN WE GO TO LIKE
APPOINTMENTS I HAVE TO GO AND
TRANSLATE.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN SOME
OF OUR YOU KNOW BROTHERS AND
SISTERS HAVE BEEN HERE FOR A
LITTLE BIT LONGER.
I THINK THE DATA ITSELF WILL
HELP AND I SEE IT BETTER AND
ALSO PERHAPS GET MORE FUNDING
FOR FUNDING IS NEEDED.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS DEFINITELY LIKE
EXPANDING THESE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND CARE.
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS A BILL OUT
THERE -- EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH.
THESE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT.
AND THE LAST THING I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS.
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF PAPERS
APPEAR.
WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO HONOR
THE SPACE -- THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPLEMENTING ETHNIC STUDIES FROM
THE CATER TWELVE TO HIGH SCHOOL.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNE AND WHICH
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT PREVENTION.
WHEN WE TEACH OUR KIDS ABOUT THE
DIVERSITY THAT EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA THE HOPE SAYS THAT?
THERE WILL BE LESS POLARIZATION
AND MORE DIALOGUE.
DIALOGUE ABOUT REALLY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION.
AROUND GENDER MAYBE AROUND RACE
ABOUT SOCIAL INEQUALITIES.
AND AS ALWAYS RIGHT.
ALSO WE WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
ABC THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE
LAOTIAN HISTORIES AND CULTURAL
STUDIES.
I NEED TO BE INCLUDED.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT ELSE TO SAY
BETH ON EVEN TODAY AS A C. HERE.
I AM AN AND I GUESS.
A BY PRODUCT OF THESE REALLY
AMAZING AND SUPPORTIVE PROGRAMS
I DIDN'T GET HERE BY CHANCE.
IT WAS INSTRUMENTAL -- DESIGN
WITH COMPASSION AND INTENTION
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE A SITE
WHEN WE CONTINUE TO DESIGN OUR
LEGISLATION WE NEED TO HAVE
THESE THINGS IN MIND.
WHICH CHANGING WORDS WE REALLY
IMPACT FAMILIES THAT WE DIDN'T
MEAN TO ANTHONY THAT'S WHY I
REALLY APPRECIATED -- THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL DO SENATORS I. WHAT
YOU HAVE SAID EARLIER.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE GO ABOUT
IT WITH OUR HEARTS.
AND SO THAT MANY COMMUNITIES
WILL NOT BE FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON EITHER
YET BUT I'M AMERICA HERNANDEZ
AND I'M THE SOCIAL SERVICES
COORDINATOR FOR KIDS IN NEED OF
DEFENSE -- I'M VERY HUMBLE TO BE
HERE ESPECIALLY WITH MY
COUNTERPARTS HERE MY COLLEAGUES --
AND TO BE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT A PARTICULAR GROUP
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SEEING
IN THE NEWS LATELY A LOT BUT
DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT THEY'RE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES -- SO I WORK
WITH UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN --
THEY ARE CHILDREN WHO ENTERED
THE UNITED STATES BEFORE THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN WITHOUT A PARENT OR
LEGAL GUARDIAN -- THE MAJORITY
OF THE CHILDREN THAT WE WORK
WITH ARE FLEEING VIOLENCE
PERSECUTION NEGLECT -- INDOOR
ABANDONMENT IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES.
AND THEY LARGELY COME FROM THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE OF HONDURAS EL
SALVADOR AND GUATEMALA.
WHEN THEY ARRIVE AT THE BORDER
THEY'RE USUALLY HUNGRY TIRED AND
SCARED?
THE FIRST ENCOUNTER WITH THE US
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS RUSH
SCREENING BY BORDER PATROL OR
SHELTER STAFF.
SOME OF THEIR HEALTH PROBLEMS OR
EVEN WORSENED DURING THEIR TIME
AT BORDER PATROL CUSTODY -- FROM
DAY ONE THEIR EXPERIENCE OF THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
AFFECTS YOUR VIEWS.
EVEN AFTER THE RELEASE OF THE
DETENTION LIVING IN THE SHADOW
OF DEPORTATION AFFECTS THEIR
SENSE OF CONNECTION TO SYSTEMS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND IT EMOTIONALLY BURDENS THEM
FAR BEYOND WHAT THEIR YOUNG
MINDS CAN PROCESS.
WELL UNACCOMPANIED MINORS DO YOU
BENEFIT FROM SOME CHILD SPECIFIC
SAFEGUARDS THE US GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY CHILD
REGARDLESS OF AGE WITH THE FREE
ATTORNEY.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE TO
FACE THE COMPLEX IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM ON THEIR OWN.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT.
MINORS ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO REMAIN
SAFELY IN THE UNITED STATES IF
THEY HAVE AN ATTORNEY.
NATIONALLY CALIFORNIA AND TEXAS
ARE THE TOP TWO STATES RECEIVING
RELEASED UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
FROM OCTOBER TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
MAY TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
HAS RECEIVED OR THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN.
JUST FROM OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR
TO MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAVE SEEN OVER FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN ALREADY IN THE VALLEY.
IN CALIFORNIA I'M SORRY.
KIND WAS FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE AND IS THE LEADING
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
TO ENSURE THAT NO REFUGEE OR
UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT CHILD.
HAS TO GO TO IMMIGRATION COURT
ALONE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THREE
OFFICES WE EVER SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICE ARE FRESNO OFFICE WHICH
IS A SATELLITE OFFICE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND OUR LA OFFICE.
WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO OVER
TWENTY COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
FOR UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE ARE THE
ONLY NOT -- NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDER THAT -- WORKS
SOLELY ON ISSUES FOR
UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF THE FAMILY
SEPARATION CRISIS WE ALSO
EXPANDED OUR SERVICES TO SERVE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR FACE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS AND CHALLENGES AS
NEWCOMERS.
INTO THE US DUE TO THEIR COMPLEX
LEGAL CASES LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROGRAM PROBLEMS AND PREVALENCE
OF HAVING EXPERIENCED EXTREME
TRAUMA.
THEY ARE SET ON DIFFERENT AS
LINK IS POINTED OUT TO OTHER
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS INCLUDING.
THE DACA RECIPIENTS LIKE MYSELF
BECAUSE THEY ARE NEWCOMERS AND
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN SETS OF
CHALLENGES.
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS
FOOD EMERGENCY HOUSING MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES ARE
CRUCIAL TO THEIR WELL BEING AND
THEIR ABILITY TO THRIVE AND WORK
ON THEIR CASES.
I KIND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
PROTECTING IMMIGRANT CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS REQUIRES A HOLISTIC
APPROACH AND GOES BEYOND
PROVIDING JUST LEGAL SERVICES.
OUR SOCIAL COORDINATING SERVICES
TEAM WAS CREATED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO DO JUST THAT.
AND HOPPER CHILDREN A TRAUMA
INFORMED WEIGHT AS THEY WORK ON
THEIR IMMIGRATION CASES.
IN MY ROLE AS A SOCIAL SERVICES
COORDINATOR AND THE ONLY ONE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY I WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEYS.
AND CONNECT THE CHILDREN TO THE
SUPPORT SERVICES THEN HELP THEM
ADDRESS CHALLENGES AN ADVOCATE
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FACE MANY CHALLENGES BUT I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME SPECIFIC
THE TODAY.
NUMBER ONE THEIR LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS.
NUMBER TWO THE LIMITED
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES FOR AN
ENGLISH LEARNER.
LINK ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
THREE THERE'LL GENERAL LACK OF
RESOURCES AND SERVICES FOR BASIC
NEEDS LIKE FOOD RENT TOILETRIES
AND CLOSE.
NUMBER FOUR TRAUMA AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES A
NUMBER FIVE DIFFICULTY IN
NAVIGATING HEALTH CARE MENTAL
HEALTH AND DENTAL CARE --
SYSTEMS. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT IS THE OBSTACLE OR IN
PAN IN LIMITED OR NON EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS.
REPRESENT A BARRIER FOR CHILDREN
TO CONNECT TO REALLY IMPORTANT
RESOURCES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
OR EVEN THEIR ATTORNEYS.
CHILDREN WHO RESIDE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE TO GO TO
COURT IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH CAN
BE TWO TO FIVE HOURS AWAY FOR
THEM.
SOMETIMES OUR COURT HEARINGS ARE
EIGHT THIRTY IN THE MORNING AND
THEY HAVE TO LEAVE THE VALLEY AT
THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING TO
GET THERE IN TIME AND PAY.
PEOPLE TO GIVE THEM RIGHTS
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IF THEY MISS THEIR COURT HEARING
THEY CAN BE GIVEN A REMOVAL
ORDER.
IT IS EXTREMELY STRESSFUL FOR
THEM TO NOT HAVE OPTIONS.
THE TRAINS ARE SOMETIMES AN
OPTION IF THEY'RE HEARING IS
LATER ON IN THE DAY BUT OFTEN
TIMES THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THE SECOND HUGE OBSTACLE FOR THE
KIDS OUR CHALLENGE IS THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE TEEN YOUTH
THE CHILDREN THAT WE WORK WITH
MOST OFTEN HAVE VERY LIMITED
EDUCATION.
AND HAVE DIFFICULTY READING AND
WRITING EVEN IN THEIR OWN
LANGUAGE WHEN THEY COME TO OUR
SCHOOLS THEY'RE PLACING CLASSES
LIKE HISTORY AND PHYSICS.
IN ENGLISH AND HAVE VERY LIMITED
SUPPORT.
AND WHEN THEY ARE IN THESE
CLASSES THE OFTEN FAIL.
WHICH REALLY AFFECTS YOUR SELF
ESTEEM FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING SIGNIFICANT
LEVELS OF STRESS DUE TO TRAUMA
BEING M. IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS.
AND TRYING TO ADJUST TO THEIR
NEW ENVIRONMENTS THIS IS
DEVASTATING I HAVE WORKED WITH
DOZENS OF CHILDREN WHO COMPLAIN
OF STOMACH ACHES.
HEADACHES AND DEPRESSION LINKED
TO THEIR STRESSORS AT SCHOOL
THIS CAN LEAD TO BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS SUSPENSIONS AND POOR
ATTENDANCE.
WHEN YOUNG PERSON STRESS WAS SO
SEVERE THAT SHE HAS HAD
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE?
BECAUSE SHE WAS ASKED TO READ AN
ESSAY OUTLOUD IN ENGLISH AND
FRONT OF HER PEERS.
AND SHE SPENT A WEEK IN THE
HOSPITAL. TO ADDRESS THIS I HAVE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE FRESNO UNIFIED
MENDOTA UNIFIED.
AND MODESTO UNIFIED AND GIVING
PRESENTATIONS TO COUNSELORS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER STAFF
AN ADMINISTRATOR.
I WORK TO EDUCATE THEM ON
UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT STORIES
AND PARTICULAR NEEDS AND TO
CREATE REFERRAL SYSTEMS TO
DIRECT CHILDREN TO STAFF THAT
CAN GUIDE AND SUPPORT THEM
THROUGH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE THIRD IS A GENERAL LACK OF
RESOURCES AND SERVICES FOR BASIC
NEEDS.
ANOTHER SOURCE OF STRESSES THAT
THEY CANNOT WORK BUT THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO PAY BACK HUGE DEBTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES SOMETIMES -- OR
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR HOUSEHOLDS
SOMETIMES WE CAN CONNECT THEM
WITH FOOD BANKS CLOTHING CLOSETS
WERE SECURE DONATIONS THROUGH
GIVE CARDS COATS OR SCHOOL
SUPPLIES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
FINDING THE SORCERER'S RESOURCES
IS NOT VERY EASY. ONE CHILD THAT
WE WORKED WITH TOOK A PHOTO OF
HER EMPTY FRIDGE.
AND THE CLOSEST -- FOOD BANK TO
HER WAS FORTY FIVE MINUTES AWAY
AND THERE WAS NO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO GET THERE.
AND THE PAST YEAR I HAVE ALSO
HAD VARIOUS CLIENTS BECOME
HOMELESS IT WAS NOT ONLY
STRESSFUL INFORMATIK FOR THEM
BUT ALSO EXTREMELY STRESSFUL FOR
ME.
AS A SCRAMBLE TO FIND THEMSELVES
SAFE SHELTER IN AREAS WITHOUT
MANY OPTIONS.
HERE IN THE VALLEY THERE AREN'T
VERY MANY SHELTERS FOR YOUTH IN
FACT HERE FRESNO WE ONLY HAVE
ONE YOUTH SHELTER FOR UNDER.
EIGHTEEN AND ONE TRANSITIONAL
YOU SHELTER THAT IS NOT FULL
TIME HAS A WAIT LIST MOST OF THE
TIME.
EARLIER THIS YEAR I HAVE TO
CONNECT THE CLIENT TO SHELTER
HOURS AWAY IN RICHMOND.
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WHERE HIS
ONLY CONNECTION WAS KIND STAFF
HIS EYES GLAZED OVER IN HIS
VOICE WAVERED AS I TOLD HIM THAT
HE NEEDED TO RELOCATE. TO AN
UNFAMILIAR AREA HE DID NOT KNOW.
ANOTHER CLIENT WAS EIGHTEEN
PREGNANT IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION.
WHERE SHE WAS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
ABUSE SHE HAD BRUISES AND MARKS
AND WAS EXHAUSTED WE WENT TO A
LOCAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER
WHERE THEY INTERVIEWED HER FOR
ALMOST AN HOUR?
ONLY TO BE TOLD THAT THEY COULD
NOT HELP HER BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT HAVE CAPACITY.
THEY GAVE HER A LIST OF SHELTERS
IN OUR WAY BUT NO TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS TO GET THERE.
ANOTHER BIG OBSTACLE FOR OUR
CHILDREN IS THEIR OWN TRAUMA.
THEY ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
SUFFERED FROM TRAUMA AND OTHER
FORMS OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES THAT CREATE.
OR EXACERBATE.
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
ALL OF THE EARLIER CHALLENGES.
I AM AN ADDITIONAL YOUTH ANXIETY
AND STRESS CAN ALSO LEAD TO
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND PROBLEMS
THAT CAN MANIFEST IN PHYSICAL
WAYS SUCH AS HEADACHE STOMACH
ACHES TIREDNESS AND A LACK OF
ABILITY TO CONCENTRATE AND FOCUS
ON IMPORTANT TASKS.
AND WORST CASE SCENARIO SELF
HARM.
CULTURAL STIGMA IN SEEKING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS ALSO
DIFFICULT TO OVERCOME.
THE FOURTH CHALLENGE IS
NAVIGATING THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND DENTAL
CARE -- SYSTEMS.
IT IS DIFFICULT SOMETIMES --
BECAUSE THERE'S A LONG WAIT
LISTS NOT ENOUGH POSITIONS THAT
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE ESPECIALLY
WITH MENTAL HEALTH WHEN OUR KIDS
ARE SPEAKING INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES ESPECIALLY -- WE
REALLY HAVE A HARD TIME HERE AT
HAVING THEM ACCESS THOSE
SERVICES. ONE CHILD THAT I EXIT
ASSISTED WAS TOLD BY A MEDICAL
CLINIC THAT SHE WOULD GO BLIND
FROM AN EYE INFECTION SHE HAD
FOR HER HOME COUNTRY.
IF SHE DID NOT REALLY -- RECEIVE
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION THERE
WEREN'T VERY MANY SPECIALISTS
BUT LUCKILY I HAVE SOME REALLY
GREAT PARTNERSHIPS WITH SOME OF
THE LOCAL HEALTH CENTERS AND I
WAS ABLE TO NAVIGATE THAT SYSTEM
WITH.
HER AND CONNECTED TO A
SPECIALIZED A SPECIALIST I WAS
ABLE TO SAVE ONE OF HER EYES --
AND SHE NOW HAS PARTIAL VISION
IN THE OTHER I..
THROUGH WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THESE PROVIDERS -- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO CREATE REFERRAL
SYSTEMS ARE MORE CHILD FRIENDLY
AND TRAUMA INFORMED.
SOME OF MY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THINGS THAT I HAVE DONE TO SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROP -- PROBLEMS
ARE THE FOLLOWING -- WHEN AIMING
TO CREATE MORE MEANINGFUL
RELATIONS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMPREHENSIVE NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS TO GENERATE WARM
REFERRALS FOR UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN?
I HAVE BILL TO CAPACITY BY
CREATING A REFERRAL DATABASE OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED CONTACTS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY AT
SCHOOLS.
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS FOOD BANKS
SHELTERS AND MENTAL AND MEDICAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS.
I MENSUR ATTORNEYS WHO ARE OFTEN
NOT TRAINED ON TRAUMA ISSUES ON
PROVIDING WARM REFERRALS FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES THE EFFECTS OF
TRAUMA ON LEGAL CASE AND BUILD A
REPORT WITH THEIR CLIENTS.
I HAVE CREATED CASE PLANS BY
MAKING RESOURCE LIST FOR OUR
CLIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH
WARM REFERRALS TO ORGANIZATIONS
THAT I HAVE PERSONALLY VETTED.
AND BILL PARTNERSHIPS WITH I
HAVE ALSO WORKED ON CARETAKER
CAPACITY BY PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES AND WORKSHOPS THAT
FOCUS ON CARING FOR CHILDREN
WITH DRAMA AND GIVING THEM
GUIDANCE FOR NAVIGATING COMPLEX
SYSTEMS OF CARE.
I HAVE ORGANIZED RESOURCE FAIRS
AND FOUR CITIES FRESNO MENDOTA
MODESTO IN STOCKTON WHERE I
INVITE MULTIPLE FAMILIES AND
BRING LOCAL SERVICES PROVIDERS
TO DO WORKSHOPS ON MENTAL HEALTH.
FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND WHERE ARE KIND ATTORNEYS DO
KNOW YOUR RIGHTS PRESENTATIONS
WE GIVEAWAY DONATED FOOD
CLOTHING.
TOYS BOOKS AND SCHOOL SUPPLIES.
WE ALSO HAVE COORDINATED
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT WHERE WE GIVE
PHONES TO OUR CLIENTS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO CONNECT WITH THEIR
ATTORNEYS AND OTHERS SERVICE
PROVIDERS VIA TECHNOLOGY -- IN
THIS PROJECT WE ARE MINDFUL.
SO THAT THE TECHNOLOGY ENHANCES
THE ABILITY FOR THE CHILDREN TO
COMMUNICATE AND DEVELOP TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
ATTORNEYS RATHER THAN TRYING TO
INAPPROPRIATELY SUPPLANT
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO LEGAL
SERVICES -- IN CONCLUSION.
IN THE ONLY SERVICE A SOCIAL
SERVICES COORDINATOR IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
HAS IT'S ALL BEEN A A CHALLENGE
AFTER TWO AND A HALF YEARS I
HAVE WORKED WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CHILDREN.
AND CAN SAY FROM BOTH PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS AN IMMIGRANT AND
YOUR PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT A PERSON'S IMMIGRATION
STATUS CAN DEEPLY AFFECT THEIR
HEALTHAXIS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS VASTLY
UNDERSERVED AND IN NEED OF
FUNDING FOR MORE RESOURCES
MEDICAL PROVIDERS SHELTERS
TRANSPORTATION.
AND LEGAL AND SOCIAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS.
AND I WILL EMPHASIZE THE LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS IN THE VALLEY WE
REALLY ARE GRATEFUL FOR SOME OF
THE WORK IN -- SACRAMENTO TO
ADDRESS THE FELLOWSHIP IN THE
LEGAL NEEDS OF THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY HERE IN FRESNO -- WE
KNOW THAT THROUGH ADVERSE --
THROUGH THE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES THAT A CHILD'S
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL EXPERIENCE
CAN GREATLY INFLUENCED MANY
DOMAINS OF THEIR PHYSICAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THEIR HEALTH
PROFILE OVER TIME.
LACK OF ACCESS TO BASIC SAFETY
NET RESOURCES CREDIBLE EDUCATION
SUPPORT AND A SENSE OF STABILITY
IMPROVEMENTS CAN HAVE LIFELONG
RAMIFICATIONS AND IF JOHN.
ON A CHILD'S HEALTH.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND FOR
HEARING ABOUT UNACCOMPANIED
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN -- I HAVE
PROVIDED SOME MATERIALS THAT ARE
IN THE FRONT AND WE ARE HERE --
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR IF YOU WANT
TO OFFER SUPPORT TO OUR
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GIVE THE
PALO ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
AND BEFORE I OPEN UP THE
QUESTIONS TO MY COLLEAGUES I
JUST WANNA SAY I WANT TO THANK.
YOU ALL OF THOSE OF YOU WHO
ALLOWED US IN OUR INTRODUCTION
TO TALK ABOUT KIND OF YOUR
BACKGROUND -- BEING IMMIGRANTS
YOURSELVES ARE COMING OR BEING
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS I
THINK -- THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
FOR ME AT LEAST HEALTHY
PRODUCTIVE WAY TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE NATIONAL RHETORIC
WE'VE ALL BEEN.
TRAUMATIZED AND EXPOSED TO OVER
THIS LAST WEEK AND THE WAY WE
RESPOND IS THROUGH.
SOCIAL COHESION AND POLITICAL
COHESION AND PROBLEM SOLVING SO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE YOUR PERSONAL NARRATIVE AS
A PART OF OUR INTRODUCTION.
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES
[INAUDIBLE]
CENTER RUBIO.
THERE IS SO MUCH TOM PACKED AND
EVERYTHING THAT EACH ONE OF YOU
HAS SHARED BY FIRST LET ME THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO --
CURRENTLY I HAVE A BILL THAT HAS
TO DO WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT
MY PRIMARY FOCUS OF THAT BILL IS
JUST TRAUMA.
AND THAT'S SUCH A DIFFICULT
THING TO SCOTT HI EVERYONE'S
TRAUMAS DIFFERENT AT DIFFERENT
STAGES WHETHER IT BE YOU KNOW
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TOM I AND I HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THAT QUITE A BIT
IN TERMS OF ALL OUR CHILDREN
BEING CAGE AND NOT HAVING THEIR
PARENTS PHYSICALLY THERE.
WITH THEM AND AND I WORRY THAT
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN YEARS FROM NOW
WHEN WE SEE ALL THESE YOU KNOW
FIVE SIX YEAR OLD BEAT ADULTS
WERE -- ENTER ADULTHOOD THAT
WE'RE GOING TO START SEEING
PERHAPS ALL THE FACTS OF THAT
TRAUMA THAT.
YOU KNOW FOR WHETHER IT BE YOU
KNOW.
CRIMINAL ELEMENT TO IT A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS SINCE WHY
WORRY QUITE A BIT -- AND BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE EXPERT I'M GONNA ASK
YOU A QUESTION ABOUT A BILL
THAT'S CURRENTLY MOVING THROUGH
OUR HOUSE ONLY BECAUSE I I
STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL.
AND I I HEARD YOU SAY YOU'RE
RIGHT NOW THERE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH LEGAL SERVICES OR OR
ADVOCATES TO TO HELP SUCH A
LARGE POPULATION THAT NEEDS HELP --
AND I KNOW THAT EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY.
WHAT THEY CALL -- I THINK THEY
THEY COLUMN -- THEY'RE JUST
ADVOCATES OF THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY LAWYERS OR LEGAL
COUNSEL'S BUT THERE ADVOCATES
AND THERE'S A BILL THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE THE ASSEMBLY
THAT.
WILL MAKE IT A EAGLE. TO TO BE
AN ADVOCATE -- TEAM MEMBER --
SENATOR TOWER WHAT THE COLUMN.
AND NOW SO SO ANYHOW AT THE WHAT
THEY DO I THINK ABOUT THE A
CREDITOR REPRESENTATIVES THERE
YOU GO AND SO I WANT TO JUST
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS I GUESS AND
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
THERE'S BOTH SIDES THERE'S A
SIDE.
YOU KNOW THAT SAY THAT.
THEY MAY BE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
COMMUNITIES AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER SITE THAT SAYS.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH LEGAL YOU
KNOW ON COUNCILS OR OR ATTORNEYS
TO HELP IMMIGRATION VICTIMS SO
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT
BECAUSE I LIKE I'M STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
GOOD OR BAD CAN YOU GIVE ME YOUR
INSIGHT INTO THAT PLEASE.
THE I A A CREDIT REPRESENTATIVES
ARE GREAT BECAUSE THEY ARE
TRAINED -- JUST SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS AREA OF LAW WHICH IS
IMMIGRATION -- AND I THINK THAT
IT IS AN IMPORTANT.
ASSET TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO HAVE
THESE BA ACCREDITED AND
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT -- THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE ALREADY HAVE THEM AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM.
AND THEY ARE OFTEN TRAINED AND
AND ARE RECEIVING ENOUGH SUPPORT
FROM THE ATTORNEYS THAT
SUPERVISE THEM.
I'M.
WHAT I AM NOT IN FAVOR OF THE IS
LIKE NOT THE IDEALS OR
CONSULTANTS WHO DO NOT KNOW
IMMIGRATION LAW IMMIGRATION LAWS
EXTREMELY COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT
EVEN FOR ATTORNEYS TO NAVIGATE?
SO I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT ANYBODY
WHO IS NOT TRAINED AND DOES NOT
HAVE AN A SPECIFIC ACCREDITATION
SHOULD BE PRACTICING IMMIGRATION
LAW OR GIVING ADVICE OF ANY KIND.
SO AS LONG AS THEY HAVE SOME
KIND OF IF THEY'RE UNDER THE
WING OF A AN IMMIGRATION LAWYER --
YOU THINK THAT THAT'S ADEQUATE
OR LIKE I SAY SO COMPLEX AND FOR
SOMEONE THAT'S NOT IT YOU KNOW A
LAWYER IT'S IT'S IT'S A
CHALLENGE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE NUANCES AND WHAT THEY DO --
I HAVE SIXTY SIX MY DISTRICT AND
I REALLY TRY TO FOCUS ON BEING
PROACTIVE AND AND UNDERSTANDING
THEIR WORK I EVEN HAVE MY STAFF
GO IN CALL EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THEM AND ASK YOU KNOW ARE YOU A
LAWYER I NEED.
LEGAL ADVICE JUST TO SEE HOW
HONEST THEY WERE ABOUT WHAT THE
WORK THEY DO IN EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THEM WAS VERY HONEST
AND SAID NO I'M NOT A LAWYER.
BUT I CAN HELP YOU NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM AND SO I WAS ENCOURAGED
BY THAT NOT NOT ONE LIGHT AND
EVERYONE WAS VERY CLEAR THEY'RE
NOT LAWYERS AND BUT THEY WILL
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AS TO GETTING
THE RIGHT AND APPROPRIATE
SERVICE BUT BUT ANYHOW I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR INSIGHT BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT I WAS HAVING A HARD TIME
DEALING WITH AN AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT.
WE NEED TO KNOW DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE NOW BUT FEEL FREE TO CALLING
GIVE US ADVICE ON HOW WE CAN
PROCEED THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IN CALIFORNIA THERE HAS
BEEN SOME FUNDING FOR
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF THE MONEY
HAS GONE TO THE BAY AREA OR TO
LA WHERE THEY ARE VERY HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY -- UNACCOMPANIED
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN BUT HERE IN
THE VALLEY WE DIDN'T RECEIVE
VERY MUCH FUNDING AT ALL AND
IT'S A VERY LARGE AREA.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE AS BIG AS
NUMBERS AS THE THE?
BIG CITIES BUT WE HAVE SEEN THAT
THE CHALLENGES THAT THE KIDS
HAVE TO FACE THAT ARE LIVING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE SOMETIMES
GREATER -- BECAUSE THERE IS A
LACK OF RESOURCES SO THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU CAN SUPPORT IS
MORE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THANK YOU AND WILL FOLLOW UP ON
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T REMEMBER IF
THERE WAS A ALLOCATION KIND OF
METHODOLOGY AT ALL WE WERE
FIGHTING SO HARD TO GET THE
MONEY ALLOCATED SO WE WILL
FOLLOW UP ON THAT [INAUDIBLE]
DR.
THANK YOU AND IF I CAN I JUST
WANT TO GO DOWN THE SEQUENCE OF
PANELISTS FIRST BECAUSE SANDRA
WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR
AWHILE AND YOU ALWAYS HAVE ME AT
HELLO. FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
DON'T KNOW SON AROUND THE WORK
SHE'S DOING WITH BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES SHE ACTUALLY
ACTIVATED ME A FEW YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS A PHYSICIAN.
ADVOCATING FOR HEALTH FOR ALL
AND I'M PROUD TO HAVE INTRODUCED
A BEFORE THIS YEAR.
PROVIDING AND WORKING TOWARDS
THAT GOAL SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY AND WHAT YOU DO FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE YOU REALLY ALWAYS SPEAK
PASSIONATELY ABOUT RED LINES
COMMUNITIES AND I JUST FEEL THAT
SOMETIMES OUR SENATOR NEEDS TO
KNOW THAT IT'S THE COMMUNITY
THAT I WANT.
TO WHEN SHE TALKS ABOUT THAT
HIGH SCHOOL THAT LIVE TWENTY
YEARS SHORTER THAT'S THE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT I WENT IN SO MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WENT TO AS WELL.
BUT IF I COULD I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS WERE
MAKING AT THE STATE AND THAT'S
WHERE YOU LESLIE COMMENT.
BECAUSE SP TWO HUNDRED HELPS US
TO DEAL WITH CAN TO A CREEK AND
TO TOMBSTONE BY PROVIDING A
CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND SO THAT WE CAN DEAL
WITH.
THE HISTORIC.
RED LINING THAT WE SEE IN THE
ISSUES FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
FUTURE YEARS TALKING ABOUT
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMBING
COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE I WAS SO IMPRESSED WITH
WHAT OCCURRED HERE ON THE GROUND
OUR COMMUNITY RALLIED TOGETHER
AND CAME BEHIND A SINGULAR
VISION FOR HOW TO SPEND THOSE
FUNDS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO US
CONTINUING THOSE.
CONVERSATIONS IN THE FUTURE. FOR
LING FANG I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
LONG STORY.
FORTY AND THE EFFECT THAT IT HAD
ON ME AND THE NEEDING TO CREATE
A MODEL CURRICULUM AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL. TO HELP US TO
TEACH ABOUT THE MONNING AND
VIETNAMESE AND YES LAOTIAN
CULTURES.
THAT OCCURRED WITH OUR SECRET
WAR AND WHAT WE KNOW HERE IT'S A
STORY THAT NEEDS TO BE TOLD I
CAN ONLY BE TOLD.
BY THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
OFTEN TIMES ARE NOW PASSING AWAY
FAR BEFORE THEIR TIME.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HOW THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MAYBE THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE THE DOCTOR WEBER
CARRIES AND I'M HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN HOW THAT MODEL
CURRICULUM WE CAN INSTITUTED
HERE AT FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
BUT AMERICA REALLY WAS YOUR
ADVOCACY WORKING ON THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE WE WERE SUCCESSFULLY
ABLE TO SECURE FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WAS
SIGNED.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
AND THAT FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WILL PROVIDE A
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM OUT OF THE
NINTH CIRCUIT COURT IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THOSE FELLOWS WILL THEN GO AFTER
THE FIRST EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO BOTH THE CENTRAL
COAST AND CENTRAL VALLEY.
BECAUSE WHAT WE WERE STRUGGLING
TO HAVE AND MEET SENATOR
MITCHELL.
WAS THE ONE CALIFORNIA
REQUIREMENT THAT SAYS YOU NEED
THREE TO FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE LAWYERS.
WE COULDN'T THEN PULL DOWN THE
RESOURCES OF ONE CALIFORNIA.
THIS FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM ALLOWS
US TO HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CAPACITY BUILDING TO THEN
PULL DOWN.
FUTURE FUNDS WELL.
BUT I WANTED TO TALK IF I COULD
ON TWO ISSUES THAT YOU HAD
AMERICA AS WELL ABOUT FOOD AND
TOILETRIES.
LAST YEAR IN OUR STATE BUDGET WE
INCLUDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DIAPER BAGS TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THOSE DOLLARS CAME
HERE TO OUR FRESNO FOOD BANK.
WE'VE.
ASSIGNED EIGHT DIFFERENT
REGIONALS PLACES WHERE THEY CAN
DISTRIBUTE THOSE DIAPERS I WOULD
LOVE. TO SEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S APPROPRIATE IN THE RIGHT
PLACES.
BECAUSE IT'S HARD FOR A LOT OF
OUR FAMILIES TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND ANYWAY WE CAN HELP WITH
DIAPERS.
LAST AND I WILL I SEE THAT LOOK
SENATOR MITCHELL.
AND IT'S ON NAVIGATION.
IT'S SOMETHING I KNOW A BIT TOO
WELL WITHIN THE E. R. WHICH IS
PEOPLE WHEN THEY GET LOST IN
STONE SAFETY NET DOESN'T WORK
THEY ALWAYS COME BACK TO THE AND
SO WE CREATED A PILOT PROGRAM
AND THERE'S TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M LOOKING TO THE
HOSPITALS THAT ARE.
OUT IN THE CROWD HERE TODAY.
THERE'S TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN A GRANT PROGRAM AT THE STATE
LEVEL. TO HIRE A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OR PEER NAVIGATOR IN YOUR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS BUDGET ALLOCATION
AND FIGURE OUT IF THIS TYPE OF
POSITION WOULD HELP YOUR
HOSPITAL.
BECAUSE IT'S EVIDENCE BASED AND
IT'S WORKED OUT OF THE UC DAVIS.
AND IT'S QUITE EXCITING AND I
JUST WANTED.
TO PUT A PIN IN THAT FOR PEOPLE
IN THE CROWD THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK ON THIS PANEL AND THANK
YOU GUYS FOR ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU WE WANT TO GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR THIS
AMAZING POWER THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AFTER WE HEAR FROM PUBLIC
COMMENT I'M GONNA ASK DR GALLEON
AND MY COLLEAGUES TO BE PREPARED
FOR CUTTING YOUR CLOSING REMARKS --
FOR TODAY TO SHARE YOUR AHA
MOMENTS WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE
BUT WE'RE GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT -- THE I I'M
GONNA ASK FOLKS TO QUEUE UP
RIGHT HERE IN THE MIDDLE.
THERE HANG ON ONE SECOND I WANT
TO SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE QUEUE UP
BEFORE I CAN TELL YOU HOW.
MUCH TIME YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
THE LONGER THE LINE.
THE TIGER I'M GONNA HAVE TO
MANAGE THIS.
OKAY IF YOU INTEND TO SPEAK I
ASK THAT YOU NOT WAIT I DO ASK
THAT YOU QUEUE UP HANG ON ONE
SECOND. ONE MINUTE.
I JUST WANT TO SEE HOW MANY
PEOPLE SO THAT I CAN TELL YOU
HOW LONG YOU HAVE TO BE
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT.
SO BASED ON THE TWENTY PLUS
PEOPLE I SEE.
I'M GOING TO ASK EVERYONE. TO
REALLY WORK VERY HARD TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS WITHIN A MINUTE.
IF SOMEONE ELSE SAYS SOMETHING I
SEE WHAT YOU CAN DO IT.
TRUST ME -- IF SOMEONE IS SAID
SOMETHING THAT IN LINE BEFORE
YOU THAT HITS YOUR POINT YOU CAN
JUST SAY DITTO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
REPEAT WHAT YOUR COMMUNITY.
A FAMILY FRIEND OR NEIGHBOR HAS
ALREADY PROBABLY QUITE
ELOQUENTLY STATED.
OF WE WILL HEAR THEM AND WE WILL
HEAR ALL OF YOU. ONE MINUTE --
AND I WILL GIVE YOU THE SIGN IF
I THINK THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN.
A LITTLE BEYOND THAT FAIR ENOUGH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW TIME
FOR TRANSLATION FOR THOSE WHO
ARE TESTIFYING.
I'M HOLLY TIME FOR TRANSLATION
SERVICES.
SO AS THE LINE CONTINUES TO GET
LONGER I WANT TO BE CLEAR WITH
EVERYBODY.
ONE THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WHEN SMS ME NUMBER IS ALREADY I
MUST SAY THAT YES I COULD GET IT
DONE AND IN CENTRAL VENOUS OR
NONE OF THE SEVERAL YOU'LL IN
THE HANNAH HOW CAN YOU?
MOST OF PROGRAMAS THIS
INTRAVENOUS AND I'LL STAND -- OR
BECAUSE PSYCHE IN THE CANNELLA
FOR A SINGLE HE IN THE CONDUCT
OF THE MONTH EVERY -- THE MAN I
MEANT THE HE SAID I COULD I.
SEVEN UP THIS INTO THE STATUS OF
THE OTHER -- YOU -- THEY WILL
HAVE NO SURPLUS ALMOST GIVES THE
NUMBERS GET A SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN
THAT YEAH I BLACKLISTED THIS IN
WHICH IS BASIS SOLAMENTE
CONTAMOS HASSLES REPRESENT
DENTIST YOUR YOU KNOW IF THAT
WILL FOCUS THEN WITHIN THE
PSYCHE BUT A SCHOOL CHILD WAS
WITH COMMON VALUES.
I'M.
THEN IN ESTABLISHMENTS NINOS AS
WE I'M.
IS THE ONE C. OKAY LISTENING
YOU'LL NOTHING ON THE SPONSORS
OF THE C. AND THIS BUT A POOR
THERE.
IN VOCAB SIT IN IS TO THE ALLEN
I SAID LAST THAT AS ORDINATED
SPOTS YOU'LL SPEND ON THE ANGELS
WAY THEN -- THEN M..
MEMENTOS IN COMPILING COOL THAT
LIBERTY MEANT THEY OKAY I
THOUGHT I WOULD LET ALSO
TRANSFER MEDIA AND THEN WHEN I
PUT THEM IN.
I'M LOWER PRICES LOW THEY LOOK
AS SOON -- COMES LIKE THIS HAVE
BEEN THANK YOU TO THE FARM YEAH
I'M M. WAS NOT JUST AND I'M THE
CO DIRECTOR.
FOR THE SUBTLE YOU'LL BE NOT
WOULD BE NICE TO NOT.
AND I'M HERE -- TO TALK A BIT
ABOUT A FEW ISSUES WE DO SERVE
THROUGHOUT FRESNO AND AND MARIE --
I WANTED THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE BECAUSE THIS ISN'T THE
USUAL USUALLY WE HAVE TO COME UP
TO SACRAMENTO WHERE WE ARE
USUALLY NOT GREETED BY
YOURSELVES BUT BY YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES.
SO THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE GLAD YOU CAME TODAY
AND TODAY I'M GONNA FOCUS ON
HOUSING AND EDUCATION.
MANY OF OUR CHILDREN DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PRIVACY AND MANY
TIMES THEY ARE HAVING TO LIVE IN --
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT SPACE TO
PLAY TO EVOLVE TO JUST HAVE
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO JUST.
SHARE THOSE MOMENTS AS CHILDREN
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEY'RE HAVING TO LIVE IN
APARTMENTS WHERE IT'S MORE THAN
ONE FAMILY AND I THINK THAT.
THE COST OF HOUSING SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE ADDRESSED
ESPECIALLY FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY OUR FARM LABOR
COMMUNITY.
AND I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS IN SCHOOLS
OUR EDUCATORS NEED TO BE --
BETTER PREPARED TO GIVE OUR
CHILDREN -- LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
SO THAT THEY CAN DEVELOP -- IN A
HEALTHY WAY [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU -- SHAPE THAT NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE -- GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ERIC PAIN I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE
HERE IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA WE
ADVOCATE -- ON BEHALF OF LOW
INCOME DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
AND WE ARE THE CONVENER OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
ROUNDTABLE WITH OVER. FIFTY
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY -- WHEN MY
PANT WHEN MY GRANDPARENTS CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY IN THE LATE SIX
IN THE EARLY SIXTIES -- THEY
SETTLED IN LOUISIANA -- AND AND
MUCH LIKE THE SEGREGATED SOUTH
FACED WITH RACIAL TENSION --
THEY MADE THEIR TRANSITION HERE
TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE
LAND OF OPPORTUNITY -- BECAUSE
THERE WAS AS FARMERS -- THEY
FELT LIKE THEY WANTED TO PROVIDE --
THE AMERICAN DREAM FOR THEIR
FAMILY -- AND HERE WE ARE TODAY
IN A CLIMATE HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- THAT IS PLAGUED WITH --
INTERNAL TENSION AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN OUR COMMUNITY --
THE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WALL ST
REPORT TITLED THE WORST CITIES
FOR BLACK AMERICANS BASED ON
NUMBERS FOR A BLACK POPULATIONS
WHICH FRESNO COUNTY.
HAS THE FIFTH LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN CENSUS -- HISTORICALLY
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
IN THE CITY OF FRESNO WENT UNDER
COUNT IT BY 66% IN THE LAST
CENSUS.
THE DATA IS JARRING FOR BLACK
FRIENDS MAN'S NOTING THAT ONE IN
FIVE ARE UNEMPLOYED BLACK WOMEN
HERE FACE THE HIGHEST INFANT
MORTALITY RATE IN THE STATE.
AND MORE THAN 40% OF BLACK BLACK
RESIDENTS LIVE IN POVERTY.
IT WAS STATED EARLIER THAT
THIRTY THAT 38% OF FRESNO AND
OUR CHILDREN LIVE IN POVERTY
HERE -- THAT NUMBER IS 66% A
MONTH BLACK CHILDREN -- AND 22%
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND SO BLACK RESIDENTS FACE THE
HIGHEST VACATION REST REGARDLESS
OF EDUCATION BLACK CHILDREN ARE
IN OUR LOCAL K. THROUGH TWELVE
SYSTEM ARE UNDER PERFORMING
BELOW STATE STANDARDS IN MATH
AND DE LA.
BLACK BUSINESSES ARE NOT GETTING
CONTRACTS M. BLACK LET
NONPROFITS ARE NOT GETTING THEM
VESTMENTS.
WE ASKED THAT OUR
REPRESENTATIVES TO SOUND THE
ALARM THAT BLACKS CENTRAL VALLEY
FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING IN
SILENCE.
UNDER THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS IT WOULD TAKE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO YEARS FOR
THE AVERAGE AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILY TO ACCUMULATE THE WEALTH
OF AN AVERAGE WHITE FAMILY TODAY.
THE STATUS OF A OF BLACK
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THESE
CONDITIONS ARTISTS HEARTENING
AND OUR ECONOMIC REALITY IS TO
SMALL.
THE FIGHT FOR RACIAL EQUITY AND
JUSTICE CONTINUES BECAUSE IT WAS
NEVER ABOUT BATHROOMS JUST LIKE
IT WAS NEVER ABOUT WATER
FOUNTAINS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
THE THAT WAS THREE MINUTES SO
I'M GOING TO ASK PEOPLE -- TO
TRY TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS A
PERSPECTIVE WE HADN'T HEARD
TODAY SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM WENDY DUNCAN A PROVOST TAKE
HELL OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SCIENCES UNIVERSITY.
WE WERE FOUNDED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN BY THE SME FAMILY. TO
HELP MITIGATE THE SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A PHARMACY
SCHOOL I WILL BE MATRICULATING
OUR FIRST DOCTORS OF OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICINE NEXT JULY.
ARE ENTERING MEDICAL SCHOOL
CLASS WILL HAVE SEVENTY FIVE
STUDENTS AND WE HOPE TO HAVE.
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS IN FRESNO
AT ANY ONE TIME IN A FEW YEARS.
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO SAY THAT
WE ARE ALSO VERY INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING PIPELINES FOR
STUDENTS -- ESPECIALLY FROM
UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO THROUGH
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HIGH SCHOOLS
AND OTHER UNIVERSITIES THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
HEY AT DOCTOR TONI PACHINKO
WARNER CENTRAL VALLEY HEALTH
POLICY INSTITUTE.
BABY ROBERT IN TURN -- WE ARE --
WE JUST FINISHED TWO STUDIES I
WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT -- ONE ON
THE TINA PREGNANT WOMEN WE
BARELY BEGUN COLLECTING DATA
LAST YEAR THERE IT'S JUST BEEN
AN IMMIGRATION RAID.
AND WHERE WE WERE COLLECTING
DATA AND THE PRENATAL -- CARE
SETTING THEY WERE SEEING UP 260%
NO SHOWS FOR THEIR PRENATAL
FIRST PRENATAL CARE APPOINTMENTS --
WHAT WE SEE IN THE STUDY NOW ARE?
20% OF THOSE MOMS IN THE STUDY
HAD A PRETERM BIRTH.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES RIGHT -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN THAT ARE
MORE PRONE TO HAVE DISABILITIES
AND YOU KNOW -- SO WE NEED.
TO REALLY THINK ABOUT THE
IMMIGRATION -- ISSUE IN A WIDE
CONTEXT OF WHAT IT'LL MEAN LONG
TERM FOR COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION AND HOUSING -- WE
TRIED TO DO A LOT OF RESEARCH ON
THE IMPACT OF HOUSING IN
PARTICULAR MARKET RATE HOUSING.
IN OUR IN OUR COMMUNITY AND WE
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA AND IT'S
NOT MANDATED BY THE STATE TO
COLLECT THAT MARKET RATE HOUSING
SO WELL WE KNOW A LOT ABOUT.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHERE
MARKET RATE HOUSING IS BEING
BUILT AND HOW THAT'S TO THE IF
YOU'RE READING CONTRIBUTING TO
FURTHER SEGREGATION.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO IF THERE
IS ANY SORT OF REGULATION OR
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW WHERE
ALL OF OUR HOUSING UNITS ARE
BEING BUILT IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT WILL HELP US REALLY BE ABLE
TO TELL THE STORY BETTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND TO YOUR INTERN.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS THE C. ALASKA'S AND I
WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA I'M
SORRY CENTRAL VALLEY EQUAL VOICE
NETWORK A HERE LOCALLY.
BUT I ALSO HAVE THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
OF I. CITY UNIFIED INTO EVERY
COUNTY FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE AS
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION A
DELEGATE ASSEMBLY REGION TWELVE
WHICH ALSO COVERS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- SO I'M INTO HIS QUICK
AS POSSIBLE BUT MY BIG GAS IS
GOING TO BE TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT SCHOOL FUNDING.
KNOWING THAT THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH BOTH THE WORK FORCE A SORT
SHORTAGE THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS WITH WITH THE
LCF FUNDING WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING IN MORE SOCIAL WORKERS.
MORE BEHAVIORS BUT WE ARE SORELY
SORELY UNDERFUNDED I NOR BEACHES
SISTER TALKED ABOUT FRESNO
COUNTY HAVING CHILDREN IN
POVERTY BETWEEN THIRTY AND 38%.
THAT'S ALSO FOR MERCED COUNTY
FOR KINGS COUNTY FOR KERN COUNTY
AND FOR TELERI COUNTY OUR
CHILDREN FIVE TO SEVENTEEN ARE
IN THAT CATEGORY.
OUR FOOD BANKS ARE HAVING
TROUBLE -- GARNERING -- ENOUGH
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO SEND HOME
THOSE BACKPACKS FOR WIN FOR
THOSE KIDS THAT WE KNOW GO
HUNGRY EVERY WEEKEND -- I WOULD
BE REMISS ALSO TONIGHT SAY WE WE
HAVE SUCH WONDERFUL THINGS IN
PLACE BUT A WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
ALL THE THINGS IN IN COLLEGE AND
STUFF TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
SCHOOL STILL.
HAVE SUCH A HARD TIME FOR THOSE
OF YOU THAT DON'T KNOW IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THIS THE
SCHOOL CARD FOR THAT IS --
COMMUNITY COLLEGES 11% ONLY 11%
OF OUR LATINO POPULATION WERE
ABLE TO PASS A MATH A
TRANSFERABLE MATH OR ENGLISH.
11% OF LATINO POPULATION WE NEED
TO GET OUR KIDS READ A PREPARED
SO THAT WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE THINGS PERSONALLY FORTY
YEARS AGO HAVE BEEN.
THE GUN TO MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
DID NOT HAVE THE SUPPORTS TO
COMPLETE WE CAN GET OUR KIDS
THERE BUT WE NEED THAT BASIC
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
HI I'M SARAH HUCKLE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
AND LIKE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HOLDING THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT HEARING AND TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS HAPPY TO BE A
PARTNER IMPROVING THE HEALTH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND TO THAT END I DO WANT TO
CORRECT SOME MISUNDERSTANDINGS
ABOUT YOU SEE HEALTH.
A WE ACTUALLY HAVE 60% OF THE OF
THE PATIENT'S COMBINED WITHIN
THE UC HEALTH SYSTEM OUR MEDIC
HAL AND MEDICARE.
AND ACCORDING TO HEAR JOSH TED
THE USING MEDICAL CENTERS ARE
THE SECOND LARGEST PROVIDERS OF
INPATIENT SERVICES FOR MEDIC HOW.
THE THIRD LARGEST PROVIDER OF
OUTPATIENT CARE FOR MEDICARE ON
THE STATE.
CELL -- I CAN PROVIDE YOUR
OFFICE WITH FURTHER INFORMATION
IF YOU LIKE BUT WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT.
THE WORK IN THIS AREA I
APPRECIATE THAT PLEASE PROVIDE
THAT DATA TO MY OFFICES I WOULD
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP.
THANK YOU. TO EVERY YES WILK
WILL -- TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
LIKE MANY SAMPLE TO SHIP IT
THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS CHANTE DAVIES
BALLS AND THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR
OF MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH -- WITH
THE MARCH OF DIMES AND SO I
REPRESENT -- COUNTIES FROM
BAKERSFIELD TO STOCKTON AND I
WANT TO FIRST THANK A SENATOR
HOLLY MITCHELL AND DOCTOR RANDY
LIFE FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE -- IN RELATION TO
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
BLACK WOMEN AND CHILDREN -- BUT
I ALSO SORT OF WANT TO SHARE MY
STORY WHICH IS -- I WAS A
HOMELESS USED IN FRESNO I WENT
TO THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM -- I
GRADUATED YOU KNOW SUMA ****
LAUDE FROM FRESNO PACIFIC AND
THEN I WENT ON TO AT JOHNS
HOPKINS WHERE I COMPLETED MY MBA --
WITH A SPECIALTY IN HEALTH CARE
MANAGEMENT AND I SAY ALL THAT TO
SAY -- I ABSOLUTELY DID NOT GET
HERE -- BY CHANCE ABSOLUTELY NOT
BY CHANCE -- AND DEFINITELY NOT
BY DESIGN.
AND YOU KNOW IN FRESNO IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I FEEL LIKE
WHAT'S REALLY MISSING FROM THIS
CONVERSATION IS ADDRESSING
STRUCTURAL RACISM.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS YOU KNOW
IT'S THE MOST PERVASIVE FORM OF
RACISM ON ITS SURFACE IT LOOKS
VERY NEUTRAL -- BUT THERE'S
REALLY A FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN EQUITY AND A QUALITY.
AND YOU KNOW A QUALITY MEANS
THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO THE
SAME RESOURCES BUT EQUITY MEANS
BEING SYSTEMATIC AND INTENTIONAL
ABOUT CLOSING DISPARITY GAPS.
AND I'M SHORT ON TIME AND SO
WHAT I WANT TO SAY IN CLOSING IS --
I ASK OF FRESNO INTO ARE WORKING
ON SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES AND
POLICY MAKERS -- IS TO BE
SYSTEMATIC AND INTENTIONAL IN
YOUR PROCESS OF CLOSING
DISPARITY GAPS AND LOOKING AT
HOW WE ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
TOPIC OF WORK FOR SHORTAGE --
AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK MORE OFF
I'VE DONE SOME RESEARCH I HAVE
LOTS OF DATA HAPPY TO SHARE.
BUT WE NEED TO BE MORE
INTENTIONAL AND SYSTEMATIC ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE VERY SMALL BLACK
POPULATION THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
ENCOMPASS THAT COMMUNITY BECAUSE
OUR POPULATION IS SO SMALL BUT
OUR DISPARITIES CONTINUE TO GROW.
AND WE NEED TO BE MORE
SYSTEMATIC ABOUT SPEAKING ABOUT
STRUCTURAL RACISM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
HI I'M BROOKE FROST I'M A
CONSULTANT -- WORKING WITH A
VARIETY OF PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
NON PROFITS AND A HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES BACKGROUND OF
THIRTY YEARS OR MORE -- I AND I
WORK MOSTLY NOW WITH FRESNO
CRADLE TO CAREER I'D LIKE TO
BRING UP SOME POINTS THAT MAY BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL BUT TO
THINK ABOUT.
MEDICAL SCHOOL CURRICULUM
TEACHING PROMOTES
INDIVIDUALISTIC AND A
COMPETITIVE APPROACH DURING THAT
FOR YOUR TIME -- M. MY TWENTY
YEAR OLD NIECES AND NEPHEWS AND
THE GEN Z. GENERATION ARE
LOOKING AT COLLABORATION.
AND THE CULTURES THAT WE ARE
MISSING OUR COLLABORATIVE
CULTURES AND THAT RELATIONSHIP
MISMATCH COULD ALSO BE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE LACK OF
MEDICAL SCHOOL -- AND THEN THE
OTHER THING WAS -- RESIDENCY
LOCATION HAS AS MUCH IF NOT MORE
TO DO WITH WHERE DOCTORS.
RESIDE AGREE -- AND SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU LOOK TO THE
MEETING THE DEMAND REPORT --
WHICH I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH ON THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM HOME CARE WORKERS THIS
IS A LOWER -- AREA TO LIVE LOWER
RATE.
AND THAT IF THERE IS A SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEED OF HOME
CARE WORKERS COMING IN THE STATE
A LOT OF THEM ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED HERE IN FRESNO COUNTY AND
WE NEED BETTER PAY AND CAREER
LADDERS FOR THEM -- AND FINALLY --
SO ANOTHER SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH PARENTAL INCARCERATION
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
THOSE KIDS AND HELP THEM TO
IDENTIFY THEM BECAUSE IT'S A
HUGE IMPACT ON POVERTY.
AND AS A FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF BIG BROTHERS BIG
SISTERS I HAD TO COME UP WITH MY
OWN FORMULA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY WE
MIGHT HAVE HERE SINCE THE CHANGE
IN.
THE PRISONS I THINK PEOPLE TO
THE LOCAL COUNTY WE'D GET NO
DATA.
THANKS THAT FOR YOU DON'T GET
DATA AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
UNFORTUNATELY -- COUNTY JAILS IN
THIS AREA WHO DON'T ALLOW IN
PERSON VISITATIONS AS WE TALK
ABOUT CHILDREN MAKING THAT
CONNECTION THE FACT THAT THEY
CAN'T VISIT THEIR THEIR PARENTS
AT THE KING'S COUNTY JAIL AS A
PROBLEM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
TO APPRECIATE YOU RAISE IN THAT
POINT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
MINUTE.
YET THE FIRST AT ALL NOT ONCE
COMMA SENATE TO REVIEW IT
SENATOR MITCHELL.
I USE MY NAME IS AMBER TRAUMAS
SOME RETIREE -- MY PREVIOUS
POSITION WITH ALLEN WITH HUMANA
WHY IS THAT -- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST BASIN WAS SIGNED IN
THIS SO I USED TO HAVE A PORT
TONY IS TO GO TO SOMEONE WHO
NEEDS AND BOB AND PARK.
IN THIS DEAL MY FAVORITE
RESTAURANT IS STILL THERE AND
AND HAVING -- I USE IT SIMPLE --
REQUEST TO US BOTH OF YOU --
SENATE TO ROOM YES CENTER
MITCHELL.
OUR SENATOR NEEDS HELP OR WORKED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEEDS HELP -- IS
FAR FOR THEM IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHO WE ELECT AS FAR FOR THEM --
TO LEGISLATION EVERYONE SUPPORT
AND SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU
BANK HERE IN ESPECIALLY THROUGH --
MRS CELADON INVASION MARTINEZ.
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR THE PAST
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AND WE GOT
THE SAME PROBLEM.
THEY HAD NEVER BEEN RESOLVED OF
WHAT ANY ISSUE SO CATION ERROR
CONTAMINATION UP PROPERTY.
SO THEY NEED YOU HELP.
I PROBABLY MIGHT MIGHT REQUEST
YOU WISH TO FOR YOU TO REFER TO
ENTER THOSE LEGISLATIONS AND
ALSO TO YOUR IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE PEOPLE FROM THE VALUE WITH
THE SUPPORT OF OUR SENATE DOORS
AND AND ALSO LEGISLATORS.
I JIM NO WELL OUR PREVIOUS
SENATOR.
OKAY YEAH WITH THAT --
PETROCHEMICAL INDUSTRY AND OUR
X. ASSEMBLIES MY MATTER OKAY JOB
WITH THAT AT FIRST WITH A
PHARMACEUTICAL AND NOW WITH A
CHEMICAL INDUSTRIES.
SO IT IS HARD FOR THEM TO FIGHT
BY THEMSELVES SO I MUST BE TO
ALL OF YOU FROM THE SOUTH IN THE
NORTH. THREE INTO THOSE
LEGISLATIONS O'CLOCK DELAYS
RATIONS THE OTHER WITH THEM SO
WE CAN RESOLVE THESE ISSUES --
THAT WE HAD IN THE CENTRAL.
OTHERWISE IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
MUCH MONEY YOU PUT YEAH NO.
THAT'S WHY I'M I'M NOT HERE TO
REQUEST MONEY.
I. THAT TRUST ME ZERO AND ALSO
ON THAT NEW LOVER NOR.
THAT WELL WHEN YOU HAVE A
SUNDRESS SOLUTIONS TO OUR
PROBLEMS ON THE WEATHER ISSUES --
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY WHETHER HE
SHOULD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASHLEY TO HAAS
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
SOMEBODY'S ME THOSE AND I'M A
FRESNO NATIVE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND I WANT TO ASK YOU
TO STAY ENGAGED IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN DOCTOR GALLEY.
AND IT IS NOT BY COINCIDENCE
THAT THESE ARE HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND I LEFT MY HOME AND FLEEING
IN SEEKING SAFETY.
SIDE LEFT FRESNO FOR A GOOD
NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND AND I WENT TO SCHOOL I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF GOING TO SCHOOL
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I SPENT
MACHEN EDUCATION MY ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY THESE WERE THE CONDITIONS MY
FAMILY WAS EXPERIENCING AND
THROUGH MY EDUCATION I
DISCOVERED COMMUNITY BASED
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I DISCOVERED
ROOT CAUSES AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE ROOT CAUSE YOU HAVE TO
THINK WHO'S BENEFITING?
FROM THE SYSTEMS AS THEY ARE AND
THERE ARE FOLKS BENEFITING.
FROM THE SYSTEMS HERE.
AND THEY ARE LEADERS IN OUR
SYSTEMS AND THEY ARE.
GATEKEEPING CHANGE BECAUSE IF IT
SHIFTS THEY NO LONGER BENEFIT.
YOU NEED TO STAY ENGAGED BECAUSE
IF YOU DON'T THIS WILL KEEP
HAPPENING.
AND IF YOU JUST SEND MONEY TO
THE VALLEY.
THOSE FOLKS IN LEADERSHIP WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE CHOICES
THAT PERPETUATE THE ISSUES ARE
FACING.
THE DOLLARS NEED TO BE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED AN
ALLOCATED TO DRESS EQUITY.
AND SPECIFICALLY RACIAL EQUITY
AND THEN I'M ECONOMIC INJUSTICE
AND AND BE GROUNDED IN COMMUNITY
VOICE TO ENSURE THAT THOSE MOST
IMPACTED OR AT THE TABLE IN THE
DESIGN OF HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE
SHAPED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING WITH YOU ALL
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE
MINUTE.
THANK YOU SENATORS TO SEVEN MEN
DR -- THINK THIS OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME'S PAUL BOYER WORK ITSELF
OUT BETTER PRICES -- WE'RE
NONPROFIT THE COUNTY OR IS
SOMEONE CAN VALLEY -- OUR
MISSION STATEMENT IS TO BUILD
HEALTHY HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
AND SO I THINK THAT RELATES VERY
WELL TO THIS TOPIC -- WE'VE
HELPED OVER SIX THOUSAND
FAMILIES BUILD THEIR OWN HOMES
WITH OUTDOOR SIX THOUSAND
FAMILIES GET THEIR HOMES
REHABILITATED WITH ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MULTI FAMILY
UNITS WE DO HOME BUYER
COUNSELING.
AND ROBERT ASSISTANCE -- THERE'S
A TREMENDOUS NEED STILL IF YOU
KNOW -- WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE HAVING HEALTHY HOMES
HELPS THOSE FAMILIES I CAN SPEAK
AS A GRANDFATHER -- FOR ONE OF
MY GRANDSON TO LIVE HERE IN
SOUTHWEST FRESNO THAT GOT
LEGISLATION THAT AFFECTED HIM.
PAUL SEVEN IS LEARNING ABILITIES
AND AND THIS GROWTH THERE FOR
NUMBER YEARS.
ON WATER WASTEWATER SIDE --
WE'RE WORKING WITH OVER A
HUNDRED COMMUNITIES ABOUT TWENTY
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE WATER ISSUES --
THERE THERE'S IT'S GREAT TO THE
FOUR BALL.
SAFER FORMAL DRINKING WATER ACT
IS NOT WOULD PASS REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO DO. ONE THING THAT WE
ASK IS MAYBE LOOKING AT
RESTRUCTURING SOME THINGS ON HOW
PAYMENTS GIVE ME TO THE STATE
AND THAT'S A WHOLE THING BIGGER.
THAN JUST ON WITH ANY PARTICULAR
AGENCY -- UNDERSTAND FISCAL AL
IS IN PLAY -- IT TAKES MANY
MONTHS OFTEN TO GET FUNDS -- WE
WORK WITH FEDERAL AGENCIES CAN
DO ELECTRONIC FUND TRANSFERS
THERE SOMEWHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THREE TECHNOLOGICAL
COULD DO THAT.
AND GET PEOPLE PAYING TIME THAT
WILL HELP MOVE THESE PROJECTS
AHEAD GREATLY -- LASTLY I'D SAY
WE'RE WORKING ON ENERGY WORK --
DISPENSED MINISTERS PERCY MOVE
COUPLE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICT LOOKING AGREES THAT.
THEY'RE ALL AND ALL OR PARTIALLY
DO NOT HAVE NATURAL GAS MANY OF
THEM HAVE TO BURN WOOD. TO KEEP
THEIR FAMILIES WARM IN THE
WINTER TIME WHICH IS NOT SAFE
FOR THE AIR QUALITY WAS FAMILIES
AFFECTED SO CAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR COMING.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU.
HI SENATORS ANDERSON WOMEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
ON TRYING TO IMPROVE THE WELL
BEING FOR ALL OF US.
AND OUR KIDS MOST IMPORTANTLY
I'VE TWO MAJOR CONCERNS
REGARDING.
THE HEALTH WELL BEING AND MENTAL
WELL BEING -- DIRECTLY RELATING
TO BILLS SB TWO SEVEN SIX MOST
PEOPLE ARE COMPLETELY UNAWARE
THIS BILL IN THE IMPLICATIONS
THE PREMISE OF SP.
TWO SEVEN SIX TAKES AWAY THE
SANCTITY OF DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP GIVE THAT TO THE
GOVERNMENT OFFICER THIS PERSON
IS NEVER EXAMINED SCENE.
YOUR CHILD IS UNFAMILIAR WITH
THE MEDICAL HISTORY IT WILL HAVE
THE POWER. TO OVERRIDE THE SOUND
JUDGMENT OF A MEDICAL PROVIDER
WHO'S EXAMINE TAKING A FULL
HISTORY IMMUNE COMPROMISED
CHILDREN WHO HAVE AN ADVERSE
REACTION WILL BE AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL.
THERE ARE MEDICAL TOM
CONTRADICTIONS THAT ARE TOO
NARROW IN THIS BILL CHILD WOULD
BASICALLY HAVE TO EXPERIENCE.
ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK A DEADLY
ALLERGIC REACTION -- TO QUALIFY
FOR THE NEW GOVERNMENT EXEMPTION
FURTHERMORE IF YOU'VE HAD AN
ADVERSE REACTION THERE IS NO
RECOURSE WITH THE MANUFACTURER
WHO'S BEEN GIVEN ZERO LIABILITY
BY LAW -- SECONDLY IN THE SECOND
BILL I AM CURRENTLY VERY
CONCERNED WITH IS THAT A B.
THREE TWO NINE COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL EDUCATION BILL.
THIS BILL STAYS AT THE AGE
APPROPRIATE INSTRUCTION FROM
KINDERGARTEN TO GRADE TWELVE TO
PROVIDE.
COMPREHENSIVE SEX HAD HEALTH HIV
AIDS PREVENTION.
THAT SOUNDS IDEAL HOWEVER WHAT
THEY'RE INTRODUCING FROM K.
THROUGH TWELVE IS.
NOT APPROPRIATE AND HAS THE
OPTION IN THE LEGISLATOR OKAY
I'M SORRY ONE ONE MORE SENTENCE --
THE GRAPHIC CURRICULUM IS
COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE PARENTS
CAN OPT OUT BUT MOST ARE UNAWARE
OF THIS AND SAID THEY IF THEY
WOULD LIKE THEIR CHILDREN
EXPOSED TO THIS TYPE OF CONTENT
PERHAPS THEY SHOULD OPT IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMING NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE MINUTE.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRANDY RAMA'S
THE KIND ON THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR UCSF FRESNO THANK
YOU HONORABLE SENATORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND DR KELLY FOR BEING HERE
TODAY TO LISTEN TO US -- AND
ALSO THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DOCTOR AROUND A LOT FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THE DOCTORS ACADEMY
THE BRANCH CAMPUS AT UCSF FRESNO
IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME.
I WOULD JUST LIKE -- TO I'M
PLEASED TO SAY THAT IN JULY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE UCSF SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE RECEIVED APPROVAL
FROM THE NATIONAL MEDICAL SCHOOL
ACCREDITING BODY TO ESTABLISH
UCSF PRESENT THE BRANCH CAMPUS.
THERE SIX STUDENTS ALL FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WERE RECENTLY
ADMITTED TO THE NEW UCSF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME AND THEY
WILL BE STARTING THEIR EDUCATION
AT UCSF LATER THIS MONTH.
AND THE REMAINDER OF THEIR
MEDICAL SCHOOL TRAINING WILL BE
TAKING PLACE AT UCSF FRESNO AND
IN THE VALLEY WHICH INCREASES
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL
STAY IN THIS REGION.
THE TWO BEST PREDICTORS AWARE
PHYSICIANS WILL PRACTICE AWARE
THEY COMPLETE RESIDENCY TRAINING
AND WHERE THEY GREW UP THE
GROWING OUR OWN IS ESSENTIAL.
AND ALSO TO TWO OTHER POINTS I'D
LIKE TO MAKE YOU C. MERCED
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR PARTNER
IN THIS INITIATIVE.
AND HEARING UCSF FRESNO AT UCSF
FRESNO'S MAJOR TEACHING HOSPITAL
A COMMUNITY REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER 53% OF PATIENTS ARE
COVERED BY MEDICARE AL AND CARED
FOR THEIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TO NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
HI MY NAME'S MOLLY A DELIVERY
ALLEN I COME FROM CALIFORNIA
TEACHING FELLOWS FOUNDATION --
AND WHAT WE DO IS WE M. PLAY TWO
THOUSAND COLLEGE STUDENTS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO WORK AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT OUR MISSION IS TO
REALLY USE THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ASUS PROGRAMS TO
RECRUIT TRAIN AND DEVELOP FUTURE
TEACHERS.
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT
THERE'S A LOT INTERSECT BETWEEN
QUALITY EDUCATION AND HEALTH
CARE AND I WOULD URGE YOU.
TO LOOK AT THE EDUCATION SECTOR --
WE'RE LOOKING AT A TEACHER
SHORTAGE CRISIS AND HOW IT
IMPACTS HEALTHCARE IN THE
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS IN OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT IS ALSO
ECHOING THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
GROW YOUR OWN PROGRAMS HERE --
AND LOOKING AT INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PROGRAMS LIKE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS RATHER
CBO'S IN HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO LEAVE GATE THE
SHORTAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH YOUR
FORTY FIVE SECOND SELF THAT'S
THANK YOU FREE C. H. Q..
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MELISSA
ALSOP I REPRESENT PARENTS UNITED
FOR KIDS ONE ORGANIZATIONAL
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS
STATEWIDE.
I CURRENTLY LIVE IN BAKERSFIELD
I'M GONNA TALK REALLY FAST TO
GET THROUGH IT ALL MY HUSBAND IS
BORN AND RAISED IN BAKERSFIELD
HIS NATIVE THERE WE LIVE THERE
NOW -- HE HAS A LIFELONG ASTHMA
SUFFERERS SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON ASTHMA IT'S REALLY AN
ISSUE CLOSE TO MY HEART AND AND
WE DEAL WITH IT ON A DAILY BASIS
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
VALLEY.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
EDUCATION IS KEY FOR THESE
ISSUES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY --
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF OUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN KERN COUNTY
FOR THE EDUCATION OUTREACH THEY
DO FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY AS FAR
AS THEIR HEALTH. FOR THE FAMILY
AND NUTRITION FOR THE FAMILY
TEACHING FAMILIES AS A HOLE
THROUGH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IT'S
REALLY AMAZING WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IF YOU GET A CHANCE TO GET
DOWN TO THE GRIM ACADEMY OR WHAT
THE WONDERFUL COMPANIES DOING
WITH OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS IS
REALLY AMAZING AND INSPIRING --
UNFORTUNATELY I'M HERE TODAY --
FOR SP TWO SEVEN SIX AS WELL
THAT YOUR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THIS PANEL MOST OF YOU HAVE
SUPPORTED THE SPELL -- AND
SUPPORTED TWO SEVEN SEVEN WHICH
HAS HAD SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES -- IN THAT DOCTORS
ARE REFUSING TO TREAT PATIENTS I
CAN'T FIND A PEDIATRICIAN IN THE
FIRST BILL THAT WILL TREAT MY
SON HE HAS A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
AND I CAN'T FIND ANYONE THAT
WILL TAKE US INTO THEIR PRACTICE
SO WE'RE RELEGATED TO E. R. CARE
OR URGENT CARE -- AND JUST ON
FRIDAY ACTUALLY I HAVE A FRIEND
WHO WAS WAS TOLD THAT SHE WAS
NANCY PS CALLED ON HER BECAUSE
SHE ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT.
THE VACCINATION THAT HER CHILD
WAS SUPPOSED TO GET THAT DAY
WHICH IS.
READING PEOPLE AND WE SHOULD NOT
BE DOING THAT -- I'M ENCOURAGED
TODAY BY THE EXPRESSION OF
INCLUSION INCLUSIVITY FOR BY
THIS PANEL BECAUSE I THINK ALL
KIDS ARE VALUABLE NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR IMMUNIZATION STATUS IS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT ALL KIDS.
GETTING THEIR EDUCATION -- IN
LINE AND I INVITE YOU ALL TO
MEET WITH YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
PARENTS WHO HAVE BEEN TURNED
AWAY FROM DOCTORS BECAUSE THEY
DESERVE MEDICAL CARE.
TO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE -- I GREW UP IN A POOR
OR A SINGLE PARENT HOME AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME AND FOR TO
PERHAPS BRING IN IN A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAT HAS BEEN SAID
BEFORE.
I'D LIKE TO IMPART THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO A GOOD
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND ACCESS TO GOOD PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHICH IS NOT THE SAME
FOR EVERYONE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE A GOOD EDUCATION
BUT LUCK SHOULDN'T HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT -- EVERYONE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
PUBLIC SCHOOL REGARDLESS OF
THEIR STATUS OF RACIALLY -- IN
THE SESSION A SOCIAL -- HERRICK
EITHER IMITATION STATUS THE
VACCINATION -- SORRY THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A GOOD
PUBLIC EDUCATION ESPECIALLY --
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
GOOD SCHOOL AND ABOUT SCHOOL CAN
IT CAN BE SANCTUARY FOR A POOR
CHILD OR IT CAN BE HELL.
AND HAVING ABILITIES TO MOVE UP
IN THE WORLD SOCIALLY AND HAVE
EDUCATION TO GO TO WHERE YOU
NEED TO GO IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND ESPECIALLY FOR
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
BECAUSE A LOT OF PARENTS MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE EDUCATED.
ON HOW TO BEST GET THE RIGHT
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILD I
MYSELF HAVE A VACCINE INJURED
YOUNGER BROTHER.
AND I. E. P. MEETINGS ARE
BATTLES WITH CODE WORDS AND
KNOWING EXACTLY WHICH LEGAL TERM
TO SAY OTHERWISE YOU MIGHT NOT
GET THE SERVICES YOU NEED -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY AND I HOPE
YOU HERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE PLEASE.
I'M GONNA TALK REALLY FAST GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
JOHNSON ROSI'S I'M HERE
REPRESENTING FRIENDS RIGHT
CANONIC OPPORTUNITIES COMMISSION
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND ESPECIALLY OUR
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES FOR BEING
SUCH CHAMPIONS ON ON THIS AND
MANY OTHER ISSUES -- FRESNO YES
HE IS DEDICATED TO ERADICATING
POVERTY AND WE KNOW THAT HEALTH
CARE AND POVERTY ARE LINKED --
SUBCATEGORIES MY COMMENTS IN TWO
BROAD CATEGORIES FIRST OF COURSE
THE GENERAL SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS THE SHORTAGE OF
POSITIONS THAT ARE ACCEPTING
MEDICARE.
BUT ALSO JUST VERY POIGNANTLY
AND THERE'S A HUGE SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS FOR
PEDIATRIC SERVICES AND A VERY
SHORT LIST OF PROVIDERS HAVE
EXPERTISE IN INFANT AND FAMILY
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH.
MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT EVEN FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE INSURANCE THEY
CAN'T FIND PROVIDERS.
OF COURSE IS ACCESS THIS AFFECTS
ACCESS FOR CLIENTS BUT ALSO FOR
INTERNAL RECRUITMENT AS A
NONPROFIT WE OPERATE HEALTH AND
DENTAL SERVICES WOMEN INFANTS
AND CHILDREN HEAD START AND
EARLY HEAD START EARLY HEAD
START WHICH ALL HAVE A HEALTH
KERR COMPONENT.
AND THE MARKET SHORTAGES ARE
PARTICULARLY POINT WITH US
BECAUSE WERE REALLY LIMITED BY
OUR FEDERAL FUNDING.
ON THESE PROGRAMS ARE GRANT
FUNDING BUT MOSTLY FEDERAL
FUNDING.
AND ON THE FEDERAL FUNDING I DO
NEED TO SAY THAT THIS PROBLEM IS
GOING TO GET MORE ACUTE BECAUSE
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES IN THE RACING ON
MINIMUM WAGE IN CALIFORNIA WILL
MAKE A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES
ELIGIBLE.
ALLEN AND OF COURSE THE HURDLES
THAT OUR CLIENTS CURRENTLY FACE
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS AND HAVING
LINGUISTICALLY AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT STAFF AND AGAIN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS AND JUST FOR THE
FOLKS A LINE THAT WHEN I GIVE
YOU THIS FINE I'M GIVING
EVERYBODY THE SIGN AT THE ONE
MINUTE FIFTEEN SECOND MARKS WHEN
I'VE GIVEN YOU THE SIGN.
YOU'RE ALREADY BEYOND THE ONE
MINUTE MARK YOU KNOW AND I DON'T
WANT TO PAY ATTENTION RIGHT AND
I DON'T.
HAVE TO ACT EVEN SAY YOUR NAME
I'M GIVING YOU ALL GRACE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS MARGARITA ROACH AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CENTRAL OFTEN MEDIA ADVOCACY
SERVICES.
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES IN FRESNO
COUNTY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
IT IS A VALIDATION TO US.
WITH YOUR REPRESENTATION AND I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M VERY PROUD
OF WHO WE HAVE IN THIS ROOM
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE
WORK TO VALIDATE OUR CLIENT
YOU'RE VALIDATING USCIS
PROVIDERS -- OUR ORGANIZATION
SERVES OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
FAMILIES A YEAR IN A VARIETY OF
SERVICES AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE
REALLY SHORT ON TIME SO I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON TWO ISSUES
BECAUSE I DID -- EVERYTHING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID.
THERE WAS A NEW THERE WAS A
QUESTION ON IMMIGRATION AND
NOTARIES OR IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
AND SO I WANT TO SAY THAT AND WE
ARE AN ACCREDITED ORGANIZATION I
HAVE FIVE STAFF THAT ARE
CERTIFIED TO DO.
THE WORK THAT IS ILLEGAL IN THE
IMMIGRATION COMPONENT.
OUR EXPERIENCE IS THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS TO DO.
IMMIGRATION WORK.
OFTEN LEADS INTO SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE FAMILY.
THEY END UP NOT BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR WHAT THEY WERE APPLYING FOR
THE END UP POTENTIALLY BEING DE
PORTABLE OR DEPORTED.
THEY ALSO END UP LOSING A LOT OF
MONEY BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE ASK.
A FEE UP AND I HAD A IN ADVANCE
EVEN UP TO FIVE AND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE KNOW THIS IS THE
LIVED EXPERIENCE.
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE MUCH FURTHER CONVERSATION
ON THIS.
AND THEN THE OTHER IS I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE CURRENT FEAR IN
THE COMMUNITY ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
THE STORIES I HEAR PERSONALLY OR
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
APPLY.
DON'T YOU REALIZE BENEFITS ARE
BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND THE CHILDREN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IT FIRST TRAUMA.
IS A VERY REAL.
SO THOSE TWO ITEMS AMONG THE
MANY I. HEAD.
YES MA'AM ARE THE ONES THAT I
WANTED RIGHT HOME TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER TADO US AND
MITCHELL NUMBERS LIKE A
COMMITTEE AND UP AROUND THE FROM
WRITING THIS IS HERE INTO.
MY NAME IS JANA GAINES ALSO THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS A CLERK
THIS IS LOW SORRY.
PICK IT UP -- WE ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WHOSE MISSION IS TO
REDUCE THE BURDEN OF ASTHMA.
AND RELATED CONDITIONS THROUGH
INTERVENTION POLSKIN ELSE'S AND
ADVOCACY IMPROVING CARE AND
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION IN THE
ACCOUNT THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
ACCORDING.
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INTERVIEW SURVEY ONE IN
SIX CHILDREN THE VALLEY HAVE
ASTHMA AND ONE IN.
FIVE HAVE ASTHMA IN FRESNO
COUNTY -- BOTH THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES MEDICINE THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH SCIENCES SUPPORT THE
POSITION THAT EXAMINING
DISPARITIES ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
REQUIRES ATTENTION TO BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS AND SOCIAL
CONDITIONS.
IN COMPARISON TO TROUBLE HIS
FAMILY BELONG TO A HIGHER SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS POOR CHILDREN
ARE EXPOSED TO HIGHER LEVELS OF
FAMILY TURMOIL BISLAND
SEPARATION INSTABILITY.
AND FOOD AND SECURITY BE STOLEN
DISTRICT ARE EXPERIENCING LESS
SUPPORT AND HAVE PARENTS WERE
LESS RESPONSIVE TO THEIR OF
HEALTH KERR NEEDS.
OF THE NEGATIVE CORRELATION OF
CHILD POVERTY ALSO INDICATE C.
COMPARED TO HIGH SOCIOECONOMIC
SETS CHILDREN POOR CHILDREN ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE EXPOSED TO AIR
POLLUTION WATER POLLUTION.
ALL THE SOCIAL -- STRESSORS
COMPOUND A CHILD AND FAMILIES
ABILITY TO MANAGE CHRONIC
DISEASE LIKE ASTHMA.
THERE IS AN UNDENIABLE AN URGENT
NEED FOR SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT ADDRESS THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IN THE
VALLEY.
PROGRAMS LIKE OR AS AN IMPACT
MODEL KNOWN AS GAME -- ADDRESSES
AND I WANT TO THANK US AND
RICARDO FOR INTRODUCING SP --
TWO SEVEN TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS IN THE VALLEY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE MINUTE
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
ANEES CURRY I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN FRESNO.
AND I FIRST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS EFFORT.
UGH IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO TELL
EVERYTHING IN THE ONE MINUTE
THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN SO I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON BASICALLY ONE
THING.
MATERNAL MORTALITY IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS OUTRAGEOUS --
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU WORKED ON
THIS AND SO YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IT WHAT I WOULD CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS IN FRESNO COUNTY
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN YOUR THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE IN CHILDBIRTH.
AND THAT WINDOW BETWEEN THE DAY
OF DELIVERY AND SIX DAYS POST
PARTUM YOU ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST
WRIST.
PART OF THAT IS IS
CARDIOVASCULAR RELATED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HEART DISEASE
DURING THE PREGNANCY BUT AS WE
TALK ABOUT TRAINING PHYSICIANS
TO BE MORE AWARE WE ALSO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE STRUCTURAL
RACISM THAT MAKES.
EVEN WHEN YOU RECOGNIZE IT THE
ABILITY AND THE THE DECISION TO
ACTUALLY TREAT IN A WAY THAT IS
APPROPRIATE AND MEETS THE
STANDARD OF CARE.
IS STILL PROBLEMATIC AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SPECIFICALLY NOT JUST
THE TRAINING AND THE ACCESS.
BUT ALSO TO US BUILDING OUR OWN
PIPELINE OF PHYSICIANS AND SO
JUST AS THE SUNNYSIDE ACADEMY
EXIST AND IS PUTTING FORTH AND
PROVIDING NEW PATHWAYS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GO INTO MEDICINE.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THIS
PIPELINE IS ALSO NEEDED AND IT
WOULD HELP TO REDUCE THE INFANT
MORTALITY AND PRETERM BIRTH
MENTALITY IN FRESNO.
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING A
PRE K. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
[INAUDIBLE] ONE MINUTE
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD AFTERNOON -- THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO THE SENATORS
AND TO THE THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS ANTONIO HOW TO GAINES I
AM -- RESIDENT FRESNO ROUTE
PRODUCT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND I WAS ALSO RAISED BY
AMBASSADOR GRANDPARENTS AND SO I
HAVE STRONG ROOTS HERE IN IN THE
VALLEY.
WHEN I TRY TO TURN MY FOUR PAGES
OF NOTES INTO TWO PARAGRAPHS --
AND SO -- ESSENTIALLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- FOR THE INFORMATION
THANK YOU FOR COMING DOWN HERE
TO FRESNO -- I AM SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE WHICH IS AS A POLICY
ORGANIZATION -- THAT FOCUSES ON
BEING COMMITTED TO RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND THE ISSUE
THAT WE WANT TO BRING UP IS AB
NINE SIX TWO WHICH WHICH
PROMOTES.
HOSPITAL SUPPLIER DIVERSITY AND
WITH THAT YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK
THE CENTER -- HER DAUGHTER FOR
HER SUPPORT ALSO CENTER MITCHELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND A
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP REACHING
OUT TO YOUR OFFICES -- FOR THE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION AND HERE IN
THE HOSPITALS IN THE VALLEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE MINUTE.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS MARTHA
ESPINOZA AND TWO THINGS I JUST
WANTED -- TO AND REMIND EVERYONE
AS WE HEARD KIND OF SOME OF THE
ARE YOU KNOW HIGHER LEVEL
POSITIONS BEING TALKED ABOUT IN
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD BUT I ALSO
WANT.
TO I WANT TO STERN COURAGE --
THAT WE DON'T OVERLOOK OUR FIRST
LINE STUFF -- AND THAT WE
STRENGTHEN THOSE CAREER LADDERS
AS WELL -- BECAUSE FOR A
MAJORITY OF OUR POPULATION HERE
IN THE VALLEY THIS IS GOING TO
BE THE BEST MEANS FOR THEM TO
ENTER INTO HEALTHCARE CAREERS WE
WANT TO LOOK OUT -- PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING HIGHLY IMPACTED
LIKE OUR OUR IN PROGRAMS OR C.
N. A. R. L. B. M. PROGRAMS --
AND THEN THAT WE LOOKING OUT --
PAY WHICH HE RATES -- AND MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE ARE INCREASING
ALONG WITH THE DEMAND -- AND
THEN SECONDLY AS A PARENT I JUST
WANTED -- TO ENCOURAGES SHOULD
CREATE INPATIENT AND RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. FOR CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS -- MY CHILD AT THE
AGE OF TEN HAD TO BE
HOSPITALIZED -- FOR FOR A
SUICIDAL IDEATION AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE WAITED
IN THE E. R. FOR OVER TWENTY
FOUR HOURS FOR HIM TO FIND A BAD.
AND HE WAS SENT TO VALLEJO AND
SO LUCKILY WE HAD A OUR FAMILY
UP THERE BUT IT WAS VERY
TRAUMATIZING TO HAVE TO SEND A
TEN YEAR OLD.
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY
JUST TO GET CARE SO THAT'S THE
IMPACT OF YOU KNOW HAVING THIS
WORK FOR SO SHORTAGE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE MINUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TAMMY
MCVEIGH WITH SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES IN BY SALLY
CALIFORNIA FIRST OFF THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND TAKING
TIME OUT OF THE DAY -- I JUST
WANT TO SHARE WITH EVERYONE THAT
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES IS AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
IT'S LOCATED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE OUR SERVICE AREA
IS FROM CURRENT. TO STANISLAUS
COUNTY THING WE OFFER NUMEROUS
HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR LOW INCOME.
FAMILIES AND BUILD YOUR OWN HOME
HOUSING REHABILITATION SO IF YOU
OWN A HOME IN YOUR HOME NEEDS
REPAIRS.
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYER PROGRAM
FINANCIAL COUNSELING IN ORDER TO
BECOME A FIRST TIME HOME BUYER.
AND THE M. MULTIFAMILY APARTMENT
HOUSING WHERE M. WE ALSO
COLLABORATE WITH NUMEROUS HEALTH
CARE NETWORK THROUGHOUT THE
VALLEY.
SO WE HAVE NUMEROUS PROGRAMS
SURROUNDING ACCESS TO NOT ONLY
WATER BUT ALSO C. THING CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
AND WE WORK CLOSELY WITH SENATOR
HER DAUGHTER JUST RECENTLY.
AND M. PAST.
SP FIVE ONE THREE M..
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO PUT MORE
TO EMERGENCY TANKS ON THE GROUND
AND FILL THEM WITH WATER FOR
FAMILIES WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
SO I JUST WANT TO OFFER THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S ONE THING
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
AWARE OF SO HOPEFULLY TODAY WE
CAN SPREAD THAT WORD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
HI MY NAME IS C. ISN'T LONG I'M
ALSO A SELF HELP ENTERPRISES AND
I HAVE A COUPLE THINGS I WANT TO
TOUCH ON FIRST OF ALL.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES AND I WANNA -- KIND
OF REITERATE SOME THINGS THAT
WERE SAID ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BETH PORTABLE HOUSING
HAS A DIRECT LINK TO HEALTH.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO RECOGNIZE THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN ITS OWN IS NOT JUST
PROVIDING HOUSING BUT THERE'S
SEVERAL ASPECTS AS WE FACE A
HOUSING SHORTAGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA PERIOD BUT ALSO HERE
IN THE VALLEY.
IS THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THAT HOUSING AND WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING THAT THOSE THINGS GO
TOGETHER WE WE AND LEND
OURSELVES TO RISK OF NOT MEETING
THOSE DEMANDS AS FAR AS OUR
HOUSE HE NEEDS -- ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE A HUGE SHORTAGE OF
CONTRACTORS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND THAT.
EQUALLY IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT THERE IS ALSO A
GREAT NEED FOR TRADES IN OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE BASIC
NEEDS THAT WE ACQUIRE.
ON A PERSONAL LEVEL I WANT TO
SAY THAT -- A COUPLE COMMENTS
MENTION ABOUT EDUCATION AND
CHILDREN BEING BASICALLY ALMOST
PIGEON HOLED AND MOVING DIRECTLY
INTO -- THE THE SYSTEM THAT I
FEEL WERE -- NOT SUPPORTING OUR
CHILDREN AND THAT WAY BY
PROVIDING APPROPRIATE RESOURCES
AT THE EDUCATION LEVELS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE SCHOOL
HIGH SCHOOL. TO HELP THEM TURN
THAT TRACK AROUND THEY GET DO
ONE THING WRONG AND SUDDENLY NOW
THEY'RE PUSHED OVER HERE AND
THEY NO LONGER HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY REGARDLESS IF THEY
ARE EIGHTY STERN.
AND LASTLY THE COMMENT THE LADY
BEFORE AT TWO BEFORE ME
MENTIONED IS THE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
VALLEY.
IS TREMENDOUS I TOO SPENT FORTY
EIGHT HOURS DRIVING UP AND DOWN
THE VALLEY TO SEEK ASSISTANCE
FROM MY SUICIDAL DAUGHTER.
AT AND ENDED UP HAVING TO TAKE
HER SACRAMENTO WHERE SHE SPENT A
WEEK AWAY FROM HOME.
WITHOUT ME HAVING ACCESS TO BE
THERE.
AFTER SPENDING MULTIPLE HOURS IN
VARIOUS E. OURS AND MENTAL
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY
ONLY TO BE ASSESSED AND TOLD A
WE'RE SORRY WE CAN'T HELP YOU
ARE WE DON'T HAVE ROOM.
WE HAVE A SEVERE PROBLEM.
IN THE VALLEY WITH A LACK OF
SERVICES AND I APPRECIATE ALL
THAT YOU'RE DOING -- AND THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SHARE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FOR D.
V. AS I AM ON OUR END AND A
DIRECTOR OF THE SCENES KIDNEY
CARE.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR PROMOTING THE
QUALITY AND WELL BEING FOR TO
OUR UNDERPRIVILEGED POPULATIONS.
WIENER FREEZING IS KIDNEY CARE
ANALYSIS COMPANY THAT SERVES AND
STAGE RENAL DISEASE OR IN STAGE
KIDNEY DISEASE -- WE ARE HERE.
TO HELP OUR PATIENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTHCARE REGARDLESS OF
STATUS.
AS WE KNOW INCISIONAL DISEASE
IT'S NOT JUST PARTY EVEN FOR
YOUNG ONES IN THE FOR THE FOR
THE KIDS.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE IN TODAY'S --
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS I HAVE
ECO SYSTEM OF HEALTH CARE.
AND WE ARE ALL HERE FOR ONE
ANOTHER TO SPEAK. FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT IS JAZZ FOR OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR YARDS
UNDERPRIVILEGED OR NOT.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
I WILL CONTINUE TO PROMOTE WHAT
IS RIGHT FOR OUR PATIENTS.
HAVE A GOOD DAY THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE
I'M LIVING ANDERSON I'M WORK FOR
CHILDREN SERVICES THAT WORK AND
I'M ALSO APPARENT VOICES
ORGANIZER -- WE HAVE RICHARD BOB
FIVE HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED PARENTS
THAT WE HAVE CONTACT WITH
MONTHLY.
AND SO WHAT COMES UP A LOT IS.
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING BACK
OF ACCESSIBLE TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE AND CHILDCARE AS WELL.
SO JUST IN OUR AGENCY ALONG
REGARDING CHILD KERR WE HAVE
OVER THREE THOUSAND KIDS THAT
ARE STILL WAITING. FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT REALLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY FOR CHILDCARE.
OUR AND WHEN YOU HAVE PARENTS
THAT ARE.
PAYING FOR HOUSING HEALTHCARE
FOOD AND THERE'S NO MONEY FOR
FOR CHILD CARE OR FOR OTHER
THINGS THAT THEY NEED SO WE
THANK YOU FOR WHAT ALREADY
YOU'RE READY DOING FOR FAMILIES
AND IN HEALTH.
AND EDUCATION AND CHILDCARE BUT
DON'T FORGET US BECAUSE WE NEED
A LOT OF HELP HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MINUTE.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GRACE
VALLEJO I AM A COUNCILMAN FOR
THE CITY OF DELANO IN KERN
COUNTY.
LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND OF THE SPEAKERS I
CAN SEE WHERE THIS NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT AS A THREE SIXTY
PATHWAY -- BUT I WANTED TO MAKE
A COMMENT ON OR I SHOULD SAY
SUPPORT ON CENTER RUBEUS COMMENT
THAT WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING THE
IDEA OF THE MEDICAL FIELD
SUPPORT AT SEVEN AND EIGHT YEARS
OLD.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO START AT THAT
LEVEL NOT LOSE THEM BY THE TIME
THEY GET INTO HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
TECHNOLOGY SIDE ONLY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT AND
I WOULD SUPPORT THAT ON THE
OTHER SIDE I DIDN'T HEAR A LOT
ABOUT THE CONTAMINATE WATER THE
QUALITY WATER IN OUR VALLEY
WHICH IS SEEMS TO BE A HIGH
PRIORITY.
AND I KNOW IT IS FOR THE
GOVERNOR.
IN DELAY NO IT IS THE ONE TWO
THREE T. C. P. IS OUR PROBLEM IT
IS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE
CURRENTLY APPLIED FOR A GRANT I
WANNA THANK SENATOR HER TITLE
FOR HER SUPPORT.
IN OUR APPLICATION JUST TO TREAT
TWO WELLS IS OUR SIX MILLION
BILL. SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE APPLYING FOR
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR GRANT BUT I
THINK THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT
BECAUSE I I THINK IT AFFECTS THE
LIVES OF EVERYBODY IN EVERY
ASPECT WHETHER IT'S IN THE
SCHOOL.
IN THE JOBS ANYTHING THAT'S DONE
IN OUR LIFE IT'S AFFECTED AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING.
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
COUNCILMAN APPRECIATED.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING RAIN OCCURS AGAIN
ALSO WITH LINGUISTIC
INTERPRETING AND TRANSLATION.
WE HAVE A PROUD C. BUT OVER
TWENTY LOCAL INTERPRETERS FOR
CERTIFIED AS A MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS.
CANNOT FIND OPPORTUNITIES IN
THEIR FIELD OF STUDY DUE TO
MEDICAL FACILITIES USING THEIR
SPANISH SPEAKING STAFF MEMBERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN PROPERLY
TRAINED TO ACCURATELY AND
PRECISELY INTERPRET TO DO THE
WORK THAT SHOULD BE DONE BY
CERTIFIED PROFESSIONALS.
IT IS A GREAT CONCERN OF OURS
THAT ARE MONOLINGUAL FAMILIES
MAY NOT BE RECEIVING THAT
ACCURATE INFORMATION REQUIRED
FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
WE NEED REGULATION SO THAT
MEDICAL FACILITIES USE CERTIFIED
INTERPRETERS THAT ARE PREPARED.
AND SO THAT THEY HIRE LOCALLY
NOT HIGHER NATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
OUT OF OUR COUNTRY AGENCIES.
ARE WHO MAY NOT.
EVEN KNOW THAT THEY ARE
INTERPRETING FOR SOMEBODY FROM
MEXICO AND YET THERE --
EXPERTISE IS.
OUR FROM UNDER US OR BRAZILIAN --
SO MANY OTHER LANGUAGE --
LANGUAGE AXES INTERPRETERS THAT
ARE USUALLY HIRED A LOCAL
INTERPRETERS SHOULD BE HIRED WE
UNDERSTAND OUR COMMUNITY WE LIVE
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT WE
ALREADY FIX UP THAT WE'VE DONE
THAT LAW A QUITE AWHILE AGO.
DONNELLY ALLAH TORY ACT AROUND
IN REQUIRING THAT HOSPITALS NOT
SIMPLY USE -- MULTI LINGUAL
EXISTING PERSONNEL BUT THAT WE
HAVE CERTIFIED PEOPLE SO WE WILL
FOLLOW UP THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT TO OUR ATTENTION THESE ARE
OUR LAST TWO WITNESSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ONE MINUTE.
HI AMY LET EVEN I WOULD
LINGUISTIC INTERPRETING AS WELL
I JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW UP WITH
MY COLLEAGUE SAID -- HAVING JUST
RECENTLY GRADUATED AND ACTUALLY
GETTING MY CERTIFICATION I HAVE
BEEN UNEMPLOYED FOR ABOUT A
MONTH MONTH AND A HALF ALMOST
TWO LOOKING FOR A JOB IN
ACTIVELY SEARCHING NOT JUST
SITTING DOWN AND WAITING FOR
THOSE TO COME.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT IS TRUE
MOST OF THE TIMES WHATEVER
HOSPITALS CLINICS PLACES THAT
I'D GO THEY BASICALLY JUST SAID --
WE USE OUR STAFF FOR THAT AND
PERSONALLY AS WELL HAVING
INTERPRETED FOR MANY OF MY
FAMILY MEMBERS MY MOM INCLUSIVE
SUFFERING A WORK INJURY I WOULD
GO IN THERE AND SPY ON THE OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WOULD INTERPRET FOR
THEM AND I CAN TELL THAT THE
MESSAGE WAS BEING LOST.
COMPLETELY MY MOM AND OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS WOULD JUST LEAVE
THE ROOM AND STILL NOT BE AWARE
OF WHAT THE OPTIONS WERE EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE FACING.
AND IT JUST WASN'T CLEAR
COMMUNICATION SPEAKING ALSO ON
BEING BI CULTURAL WHEN YOU'RE AN
INTERPRETER NOT JUST BILINGUAL
YOU'RE BI CULTURAL AND MOST OF
THE WORKERS THERE SOME OF THEM
DO SPEAK SPANISH BUT LIKE SHE
WAS MENTIONING SUMMER
SALVADORIAN UNDER IT.
AND SO IT JUST KIND OF THE
MESSAGE GETS LOST COMPLETELY SO
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ASK THAT WE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND NOT FORGET
ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT AND OUR FINAL WITNESS ONE
MINUTE PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON COUNCIL MY NAME
IS NANCY SIMPLY O'NEILL I AM
ALSO AN EMPLOYEE FOR SENIORS
KIDNEY CARE MEDICAL CARE AND I
WAS ASKED TO ACCOMPANY MY DO. TO
THIS COUNCIL MEETING TODAY BUT I
DIDN'T DID NOT REALIZE HOW
IMPACTFUL THIS COMMITTEE WAS
GONNA BE TODAY ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL FOR ME.
IN REGARDS TO THE HEALTH CARE
FOR OUR CHILDREN.
SO I HAD A COUSIN HANNAH WANTED
SHARE THIS PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT A COUSIN WHO DEVELOPED POST
PARTUM -- MENTAL ILLNESS AND IT
WAS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
MEDICAL COVERAGE WAS HER
INSURANCE.
AND IT WAS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
TO FIND A PHYSICIAN TO CARE FOR
HER.
AND MOST OF THE TIME SHE WAS
SEEN A PHYSICIAN VIA SKYPE.
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T ANYONE IN
THE AREA TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE
FOR HER AND SHE LIVED IN FROM
CALIFORNIA.
SO BECAUSE OF HER NOT BEING ABLE
TO GET THE PROPER MEDICAL CARE
THAT SHE NEEDED -- SHE DID PASS
AWAY -- BECAUSE OF THOSE
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEMS AT THAT
SHE DEVELOPED AND AND HAD.
ALSO MY PARENTS ARE RAISING FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN FOUR OF WHOM HAVE
MEDICAL COVERAGE MEDICAL
COVERAGE AS WELL MEDICAID.
AND ONE OF THE YOUNGEST HAS
CEREBRAL PALSY AND HAS BEEN A
HUGE HUGE ISSUE -- IN TRYING TO
GET MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS FOR HIM
TO GET THIS THE MEDICAL
ATTENTION THAT HE NEEDS AND MANY
TIMES THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
MONTHS AND MONTHS AWAY.
AND THE OLDEST MY OLDEST PLEASE
A SHE ALSO HAS ECOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS -- SHE WAS BORN A DRUG
BABIES SO THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
THAT CAME WITH THAT.
AND ALSO SHE ALSO HAS TO SEE A
PSYCHIATRIST OR PSYCHOLOGIST VIA
SKYPE OVER TV.
SO -- WE DEFINITELY NEED TO WORK
ON THAT AND GETTING BETTER
MEDICAL.
YOU KNOW PHYSICIANS OF COURSE
WHICH WE HAVE DISCUSSED ALREADY.
BUT IT IS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
AND IT'S VERY -- IMPACTED ME --
PERSONALLY VERY MUCH I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
AND AS ALWAYS WHEN WE HAVE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ATTEND
THESE HEARINGS -- AND ARE
WILLING -- TO SHARE YOUR
PERSONAL STORIES WE APPRECIATE
THAT IS YOUR PERSONAL STORIES
THAT.
REALLY RESONATE QUITE FRANKLY --
AND HELP INFORM THE WORK WE DO
EVERY DAY SO WE THANK YOU.
VERY VERY MUCH I WENT UP.
UP DRY AS I HAND THE GAVEL OVER
TO CENTER WHO TADO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IN YOUR
PACKET THAT YOU TAKE WITH YOU.
THE WHITE PAPER -- THE THE
BACKGROUND OF PAPER THAT --
LANDON JORGE FROM MY STAFF IN
COLLABORATION WITH OTHERS WORKED
VERY DILIGENTLY IT'S AN AMAZING
RESOURCE SO I HOPE YOU WILL TAKE
IT BACK WITH YOU TO YOUR
AGENCIES AND SHARED AFTER YOU
FINISH READING IT SHARE IT WITH
SOMEONE ELSE -- SO THEY'LL HAVE
A SENSE OF ALL THE DATA THAT WAS
PULLED TOGETHER -- IN
PREPARATION FOR TODAY'S HEARING --
DOCTOR GALLEY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND STAYING HERE IN
PUBLIC COMMENT BEING A
PARTICIPANT -- I'D LIKE TO OFFER
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE SOME
CLOSING REMARKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL AND
FIRST I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS AN OLD.
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE AND
WE'RE HERE AND FOR SHARING.
NOT JUST YOUR PERSONAL STORIES
WHICH I THINK REALLY DRIVE HOME
A POINT -- BUT ALSO JUST THE
TRENDS IN FRESNO AND THE ENTIRE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S SO MUCH TO REFLECT ON
TODAY.
AND I LEARNED A LOT AND AM
EXCITED ABOUT CONTINUING TO
LEARN.
AND AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
INFLUENCE AND RESPONSIBILITY
BOTH OUR LEGISLATORS AND ALL ALL
OF US APPOINTED -- AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM HAVE WE NEED
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE STORIES
AND TESTIMONY SHARED TODAY -- I
WILL SHARE ONE LAST THOUGHT THAT
I THINK WE DIDN'T SPEND AS MUCH
TIME TALKING ABOUT BUT I'M
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN PUSHING.
WITH OUR OWN AGENCY IS -- THIS
NOTION OF INTEGRATION.
RIGHT TODAY WE TALKED ABOUT ALL
OF THE SOCIAL SERVICES AND
WHETHER IT'S HOUSE SCENE OR
FINANCIAL AID AND OTHER TYPES OF
SUPPORTS AND HOW THAT REALLY.
NEEDS TO BE INTEGRATED WITH THE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT WE
SPENT THE FIRST PART OF THE DAY
TALKING ABOUT AND THIS NOTION OF
COMPLEX CARE IN HEALTH.
THERE WERE ABOUT IT'S NOT JUST
COMPLEX HEALTH ISSUES BUT IT'S
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN HEALTH
AND SOCIAL ISSUES THAT ARE
COMPLEX AND COMPLICATED.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO DRAW ON
THE RICH WORK FORCE HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND THE POTENTIAL WORK FOR US TO
REALLY ADDRESS THAT IN NOVEL AND
INTERESTING WAYS I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR MY
AGENCY IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
ON HOW WE MIGHT DO THAT IN REAL
ORDER HERE BOTH IN THE SHORT RUN
IN THE LONG RUN SO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME BE.
AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT AND MORE
AN ACTIVE LISTENER AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU AT THIS POINT I'LL GO
AHEAD AND HANDED OVER TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMBLING FOR
CLOSING REMARKS.
THANK YOU AND I DON'T THINK IT
WAS BY ACCIDENT THAT EVERY
PANELIST WE HAD WAS FEMALE.
AND SO THE HASH TAG WOMEN
LEADING FRESNO IS QUITE
APPROPRIATE.
BUT THERE'S A WOMAN WHO'S ALSO
LEADING CALIFORNIA AT THE
MOMENTS THAT I WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO MENTION AND THAT'S OUR
FIRST EVER SURGEON GENERAL.
SHE IS A WOMAN OF COLOR SHE IS
ALSO A PEDIATRICIAN AND SHE IS
CHAMPIONING A LOT OF THE WORK ON
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A B.
THREE FORTY THAT WE PASSED A FEW
YEARS AGO.
BUT I WANTED TO DOCTOR GALLEY
JUSTIN MY CLOSING COMMENTS TO
ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTS AND PUT UP
DR CURRY'S COMMENTS BECAUSE
SHE'S BEEN A LONG TIME ADVOCATE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
TALKING ABOUT WHAT I. FRAME AS
THE CANARY IN THE COAL MINE.
THE INFANT MORTALITY AND
MATERNAL MORTALITY THAT WE C.
AMONGST TOO MANY OF OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO COMMUNITIES.
THAT ONLY CAN IMPROVE IT FOR
BEING.
INTENTIONAL AND DRIVING
RESOURCES AND LISTENING TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
SO I THANK YOU FOR COMING HERE
AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THE NEAR FUTURE
WHERE WE CAN BRING DR NINETEEN
BURKE HERIS OUR SURGEON GENERAL
DOWN. TO BOTH C. THESE PROBLEMS
FIRST HAND AND TO HEAR FROM OUR
COMMUNITY HOW WE CAN HELP TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO.
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING AND
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE.
THANK YOU FOR REMEMBER DOCTOR
REGULAR -- CENTER GALGIANI WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK ONE ONE AND
ALSO THANK EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
AND I THINK THAT WHAT WE SAW
TODAY WAS A PAN TED NEED FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN GENERAL.
ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES AND WE
DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND WE
DIDN'T GO INTO DEPTH ON
TRANSPORTATION.
BUT AS I WAS DRIVING HERE I
THOUGHT ABOUT HOW WHEN I WAS
FIRST IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND
DRIVING DOWN HIGHWAY NINETY NINE
ESPECIALLY IN THE WINTER TIME
WHEN WAS FOGGY.
YOU HAD TO REALLY BRACE YOURSELF
IF YOU WERE TRYING TO CROSS
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE BECAUSE AT
THAT TIME WE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
ANY OVER PASSES ARE UNDER PASSES
WE HAD AT GRADE SEPARATIONS --
THROUGH MERCED COUNTY WHICH I
REPRESENTED C. TO HAVE TO SIT ON
ONE SIDE AND THEN JUST GOT IT TO
TRY TO GET OVER TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE FREEWAY.
SO WE'VE COME A LONG WAY BUT
THERE STILL ARE PARTS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE WE FACE
THAT ISSUE.
AND MANY OTHERS WE'VE MADE A LOT
OF PROGRESS -- I THINK THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE -- CSU FRESNO HERE
AND YOU C. MERCED WHICH HAS SO
MUCH POTENTIAL FOR GROWTH AND WE
HAVE THE MEDICAL PARTNERSHIPS --
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK THAT WE
CAN DO AND WE CAN FOCUS
FINANCIAL RESOURCES ON PROGRAMS
THAT THOSE TWO UNIVERSITIES
WHERE WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS HERE.
IN THE CENTER VALLEY KNOW THAT
THOSE SLIDES THOSE THOSE
STUDENTS FLIGHTS ARE FOR THEM
AND THAT THEY WILL ASPIRE TO THE
HEALTH CARE FIELDS.
AND STAY HERE PROVIDE MEDICAL
CARE WE KNOW IT'S A STATEWIDE
ISSUE -- WE KNOW IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT HERE
THOSE ARE JOBS THAT WE CAN'T
EXPORT -- SECONDLY WE'VE
PROVIDED RESOURCES BY EXPANDING
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL BUT IT'S NOT
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL IF YOU CAN'T
HAVE ACCESS IF YOU'RE WAITING
TWO MONTHS TO GET AN APPOINTMENT
WITH A PHYSICIAN OR PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANT OR WHATEVER THE
PROFESSIONAL MIGHT BE.
THAT'S NOT ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
THE DEMAND IS DEAF LEAVE THEIR
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE OUR COLLEAGUES TO
REALLY GET BEHIND AS WE LOOK
TOWARD WHAT OUR GOALS ARE FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
SO I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
FOR EXPRESSING THOSE SENTIMENTS
AND I HOPE THAT THIS WILL NOT BE
THE LAST THAT THE FIRST OF OF
MANY HEARINGS THAT WE CAN HAVE
HERE WITH OUR CENTER VALITY
PARTNERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES -- I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T
REALLY HEARD TOO MUCH FOR ME
TODAY BUT IT JUST MEANS THE
WORLD TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUES HERE
THIS THIS MORNING AND AND INTO
THE AFTERNOON TO HEAR YOUR
VOICES -- I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
AND A WONDERFUL AND AMAZING
CHAMPION IN SACRAMENTO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DR WALKING AROUND THAT --
AND AND IN FIGHTING FOR YOU AND
AND EXPRESSING YOUR VOICE AND
I'M DOING AS MUCH AS I CAN ON MY
END.
AND SO YOU KNOW.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO LISTEN TO HERE TO HAVE OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE YOU AS WELL --
AND I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THAT.
COMMUNICATION GOES BOTH WAYS IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN SACRAMENTO.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH US BECAUSE WE NEED TO KNOW.
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES ON THE
GROUND AND IF WE DON'T KNOW IT'S
IT JUST?
IT'S DIFFICULT TO ADVOCATE FOR
SOMETHING WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY -- THE STORIES
THAT YOU SHARED ARE VERY --
PERSONAL TO ME IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I'VE EXPERIENCED YOU KNOW
GROWING UP IN SINGER IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY.
AND SO PLEASE CONTINUE TO COME
TO US TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND AT THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING SO THIS AND ARE
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
CHILDREN'S WELL BEING THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED